THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING AGING AND
LONG TERM PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIADEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND PROGRAMS LIKE THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES KNOWN AS I.
HSS. AND THE SOCIAL SECURITY
INCOME AND STATE SUPPLEMENTARY
PAYMENT SS I SS P. PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AS A SIGN OF THE CHANGING TIMES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE TODAY
WE WILL HAVE PANELISTS
PRESENTING BOTH IN PERSON AND
VIRTUALLY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN IF
YOU ARE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THAT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. THOSE WHO ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MADE DO SO IN PERSON
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AT THE
CAPITOL IN ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR.
WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED
THEIR QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL.
THERE WILL BE NO VOTES TAKEN IN
TODAY'S HEARING AS THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO DISCUSS
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THAT ADDRESS
IS BUDGET SUB ONE. OUT ASM DOT
CA DOT GOV. BEFORE WE INVITE OUR
FIRST PANEL TO BEGIN I'LL MAKE
JUST A FEW INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS
AND OPEN IT UP. TO SEE IF ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO DO THE SAME.
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED IN PRIOR
HEARINGS OR FOCUS FOR SUB ONE
THIS YEAR IS TWO FOLD. WE ARE
FIRST REVIEWING PRIORITY ISSUES
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
SECOND WE ARE EXERCISING OR
CRITICAL OVERSIGHT ROLE FOR
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION PHASE
. AS PART OF BOTH OF THESE
EXERCISES WE DISCUSS AND
DELIBERATE ON WHAT ADDITIONAL
MEANINGFUL CHANGES IN THIS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUDGET. CAN
FACILITATE TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARD SOLVING SOME OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS FACING OUR
STATE. TODAY WE WILL TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE LARGEST AND MOST
SIGNIFICANT AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE.
WHICH SERVE SOME OF OUR MOST
NEEDY AND VULNERABLE SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE
EMBARKED ON A LONG URGED EFFORTS
TO CREATE A MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING. IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE MASTER PLAN WAS
PUBLISHED AND THERE'VE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FUND. THIS
GRADUAL WORK IN SMALL MEDIUM AND
LARGE WAYS TO PROMOTE MEANINGFUL
AND LASTING CHANGES SO THAT MORE
PEOPLE CAN AGE WITH DIGNITY AND
SUPPORTS PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
CAN BE KEPT IN COMMUNITY. TODAY
WE WILL HEAR AN UPDATE AND THE
NEXT NEAR TERM GOALS IN THE WORK
OF THE MASTER PLAN. AND WHAT I
URGE FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PUBLIC IS
TO KEEP IN MIND HOW OUR BIGGEST
MOST RELIED UPON PROGRAMS
SERVING OLDER CALIFORNIANS HI
HSS SSI S. S. P. AND ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES CAN BE
STRENGTHENED AS THE PILLARS AND
THE FOUNDATION THAT THEY ARE.
UPON WHICH THE MASTER PLAN IS
BEING BUILT AND WILL BE REALIZED
. IF THESE PROGRAMS REMAIN
ACCESSIBLE FORTIFIED AND HEALTHY
THEN THERE IS A STRONG BASIS FOR
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS TO SECURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AS THEY AGE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE AGENDA
IZED TODAY WITH THAT I'LL OPEN
IT UP TO AN EMAIL MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. WE WILL
BEGIN THEN WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
WHICH IS ON THE TOPIC OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND RELATED KEY
INVESTMENTS. FOR THOSE PANELISTS
WHO ARE PRESENTERS CAN YOU
PLEASE PRESENT IN THE ORDER IN
WHICH YOUR NAME APPEARS IN THE
AGENDA. WE HAVE EIGHT
DISTINGUISHED PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL. INCLUDING SUSAN THE
MORRIS DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
MARK BECKLEY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. CAROL
TOWARDS LENDER THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING ALEX CLIMAX
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JALIL BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. JACKIE BUT OSSEO
WITH THE L. A. HERE IN PERSON
HOW MY CAR COSTA AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND BECKY
DUFFEY THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES. CAN WE-
LET US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR SUSAN
TO MORRIS. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM SUSAN TO
MORRIS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
SCENTING ARE BUDGET OVERVIEW TO
YOU FOR MY VERY FIRST TIME IN MY
NEW ROLE. I WANTED TO START WITH
A MAJOR MILESTONE WE HIT JUST
LAST WEEK CDA NOW HAS TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN ITS HISTORY THANKS TO
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR. AND ONE TIME FEDERAL
CARES ACT ARPA AND H. C. B. S.
FUNDING. I WANT TO THANK OUR
INCREDIBLY HARDWORKING CD
EIGHTEEN FOR SIMULTANEOUSLY
RESPONDING TO THE KOBE PANDEMIC.
IMPLEMENTING THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING MODERNIZING OUR CORE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND
LAUNCHING EIGHTEEN NEW
INITIATIVES TO STRENGTHEN THE
AGING AND DISABILITY NETWORK.
ALL OF THIS IS DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND OUR EVER EXPANDING
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTIONS. THE RELEASE OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAS
TRANSFORMED OUR THINKING AS A
STATE. AS AN AGENCY AND AS A
DEPARTMENT TOGETHER WE'RE
PREPARING FOR THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY ONE ONE AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE AGE SIXTY
OR OLDER. AT CDA WE ARE PROUD TO
LEAD THE MASTER PLAN WORK BUT
IT'S THE STRONG COLLABORATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. OUR SISTER
DEPARTMENTS OTHER AGENCIES AND
THE LEGISLATURE THAT HAS ALLOWED
US TO MAKE SO MUCH PROGRESS IN
SUCH A SHORT TIME. EARLIER THIS
YEAR WE RELEASED OUR FIRST
ANNUAL MASTER PLAN PROGRESS
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
REPORT FOCUSED ON THE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO PRIORITY
INITIATIVES IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS. OUR MESSAGE THEN AND
TODAY IS WE'RE JUST GETTING
STARTED ON THE TEN YEAR
BLUEPRINT FOR OUR STATE. WE'RE
EXCITED TO SHARE GREATER DETAIL
NEXT WEEK AT THE ASSEMBLY AGING
AND LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEES
MPA OVERSIGHT HEARING. I WANT TO
CLOSE MY OPENING STATEMENT BY
SAYING HOW MUCH CDA VALUES THE
ROLE AND INPUT OF DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS. OUR DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY LEADS SEVEN
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUPS THAT
MEET QUARTERLY WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BRINGING LOCAL
PERSPECTIVES TO OUR WORK. WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO LEARN FROM SO MANY
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE ON
TOPICS SUCH AS EQUITY. ELDER AND
DISABILITY JUSTICE ALZHEIMER'S
AND FAMILY CARE GIVING. BEFORE I
TURN OVER- TO CTA'S CHIEF DEPUTY
MARK BAGLEY WHO WILL WALK
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENTS- BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS AND THE JANUARY
BUDGET I WANTED TO RESPOND TO
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENDA RELATED TO THE MASTER
PLAN AND DEPARTMENT PRIORITIES.
OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS
BUILDING STATEWIDE CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN SUPPORT OF A
PERSON CENTERED INTEGRATED
NETWORK OF CARE. WITH A LASER
FOCUS ON A NO WRONG DISSED OUT
AND NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM THAT IS
ANCHORED. IN A SEAMLESS PHONE
WEB AND IN PERSON NAVIGATION
ORIENTED TOWARD CONSUMERS.
EXPANDED ACCESS TO LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
AFFORDABILITY FOR ALL INCOME
LEVELS AND RACIAL EQUITY AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. THIS IS A
MULTI YEAR EFFORT IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE CALAIS MINISH
IT IS. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AS IT RELATES TO
HSS. YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM MARK
ON THIS AND I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS TODAY. OUR
SECOND PRIORITY IS WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH H. CHI THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON A CONTINUUM OF
DIRECT CARE WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES ACROSS A VARIETY. AT
EIGHT CBS SIGHTINGS.
SPECIFICALLY CDS LEADING ON THE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR NON I H. S. S. WORK- THAT
IS CENTERED IN SEA BASS ADULT
DAY HEALTH CARE THE PROGRAM FOR
ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY M. S. S. P. AND OTHER
MEDICAL WAIVER SETTINGS WE HELD
A WEBINAR TO LAUNCH OUR
STAKEHOLDER WORK AND WE'RE NOW
MAPPING CTAS INITIATIVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
HSS CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
CONSISTENCY EFFICIENCY AND
EXPEDIENCY. SARAHSPAIN HOUSE AND
LEADS THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS
WORKFORCE INITIATIVE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE WORKING IN
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AS
WELL AS WITH THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. SO
I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MARK TO
WALK THROUGH- OUR BCPS BENNETT
ANY POINT IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR EITHER OF US WE'RE HERE FOR
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GREAT
THANK YOU SUSAN AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN PANEL
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MARK BAGLEY
ON THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AGING.
AND I'LL START OFF BY WALKING
THROUGH. OUR PROPOSED BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS AND SO WE HAVE
THREE BEFORE YOU- THE FIRST
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL IS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO. ADDRESS
STAFFING- ISSUES OF DEFICIENCIES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT- AS YOU
KNOW CA HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
SMALL DEPARTMENT OF LESS THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY- STAFF MEMBERS- AS
SOON AS I MENTIONED WE'VE BEEN
GROWING AT. FIVE QUICKLY AND
HAVE JUST REACHED OUR TWO
HUNDRED STAFF MEMBER. AT
BEGINNING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF. IN ORDER TO
HELP. IMPLEMENT DEVELOP- THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING AND IF IT
FELL ITS CORE OBJECTIVES AND
GOALS- PRIOR TO REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR FISCAL
STAFF DID DO AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE EXISTING DEPARTMENTAL
FUNDING LEVELS. DETERMINE IF
EXISTING RESOURCES COULD BE
DIRECTED REDIRECTED TO PROVIDE
FOR THE ADDITIONAL STUFF THAT WE
NEED- AND- IN PARTICULAR THE
STRATEGY THAT THEY LOOKED AT IT
IS. REDUCING OUR RELIANCE ON
TEMPORARY HELP POSITIONS ON THE
DEPARTMENT HISTORICALLY. I HAD A
HEAVY RELIANCE ON TEMPORARY
HELP. WE SCALED BACK THOSE
POSITIONS AND I CREATED THE
FUNDING THAT WE- NEED TO.
ESTABLISH PERMANENT POSITIONS I
REQUEST. THAT IN THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. I'M I'M ABOUT
SECOND- BUT CHANGE FOR. WHICH IS
YOUR ADDRESS MINISTER WORKLOAD-
WITH THE OF THE GOT MASTER PLAN
FOR A AS WELL AS OUR NEW HD S.
M. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED FIFTY THREE
NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS- FORCE%
DEVIATE EMPLOYMENT THE MPA AND
H. C. B. S. INITIATIVES- IT IS
ONLY IN THIS CURRENT BUDGET
REQUESTING- AT TWELVE ADDITIONAL
SESSIONS TO FURTHER IMPLEMENT
THE MASTER PLAN- CALLS- THREE
OUT OF THE FOUR CAUSES. THAT
REQUEST YEAR HR POSITIONS- THAT
WILL BE CRITICAL IN HELPING US
TO RECRUIT HIRE QUALITY STAFF.
TO STOP THESE NEW INITIATIVES AS
WELL AS LEADING INITIATIVES-
THESE NEW POSITIONS WILL HELP US
PROVIDE ADEQUATE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT FOR ALL THE NEW PROGRAMS
WE'RE STANDING UP. THE EIGHT
THIRTY CPA IS TO HELP US
CONTINUE WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- AS
WE GO ALONG AND UNDERTAKE NEW
INITIATIVES FOR THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING. WHERE I'M EXPANDING
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND STAFF
CAPACITY TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR INITIATIVES. I'M IN THIS
REQUEST REQUESTING TWELVE NEW
POSITIONS BROKEN OUT AS FOLLOWS-
FOUR RESEARCH POSITIONS TO BEGIN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF CPA'S RESEARCH
AND IT OPERATIONS. TO SUPPORT
THEM INITIATIVES AND THE MPA
DIASPORA TRANSITION FROM CDPH TO
CDA AS WELL AS REDUCE OUR NEED
FOR EXTERNAL CONSULTANTS TO HELP
US MAINTAIN THE PASSPORT- BY
DOING SO THIS WILL HELP THE
SPPORT DATA DRIVEN DECISION AND
POLICY MAKING. AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF DATA INFORMED
PROGRAMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE- CD
EIGHT IS NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
RESEARCH POSITIONS BEYOND ONE
CURRENT. RESOURCE AT RESEARCH
RESOURCE. THE- SO THIS THAT WERE
CHECKING GROUPING OF. I HAVE TO
DEAL WITH OUR FOCUS ON EQUITY
STILL REQUESTING SHE EQUITY TO
ENSURE THAT EQUITY IS EMBEDDED
IN ALL AGING PROGRAMS AND NEW
MPA INITIATIVES AS WELL.
INTERNALLY TO CBA'S HIRING AND
RECRUITMENT PROCESSES. WERE ALSO
REQUESTING ONE TRIBAL LIAISON
THAT WILL PARTNER WITH
CALIFORNIA STRIVES. TO ENSURE
THAT THE TRIBES ARE WHERE HAVE
ACCESS TO ALL AGING PROGRAMS AND
THAT THE NEEDS OF TRIBAL ELDERS
ARE PROPERLY CONSIDERED IN OUR
AGING PROGRAMS. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRED ONE SENIOR STAFF
POSITION THAT WILL REPORT
COMMITTEE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
AGING POLICY RESEARCH IN EQUITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS WILL
PROVIDE DAY TO DAY DIRECTION AND
OPERATIONS OF THE DIVISION AS
WELL AS LEADING HE- AND ITS CBS
INITIATIVES. WE'RE ALSO ASKING
FOR COMMUNICATIONS POSITIONS TO
EXPAND OUR INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS ABILITIES AS WE
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND- OUR H. C. B.
S. INITIATIVES WE'RE COMMITTED
TO ENSURING THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ARE INFORMED AND
ACTIVELY ENGAGED. IN THE I'M
GOING TO ELEMENT IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MTA AND
THAT THERE ARE ALSO INFORMED AT
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING
ON OUR INITIATIVES. AND THEN
FINALLY THEY WERE REQUESTING ONE
POSITION TO ACT AS A LIAISON
WITH LOCAL PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S
OFFICE IS- WHICH CHANNEL-
DISCUSS NOW AS IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION. PRAYER ASK
QUESTIONS READ THREE- THE
QUESTION IS HOW WILL THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN LAYS ON INSURE PROGRAM
CONSISTENCY AND EQUITY OUR
OUTCOMES BEING MEASURED AND HOW
WILL THIS INFORMATION BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. SO CITY
PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL MCCARTY
AND OFFICE SAYS AS IT RELATES
SPECIFICALLY TO PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND THE LOCAL PUBLIC GUARDIANS
NOT AS WE KNOW ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
ESTABLISHING A SYSTEM OF
SUPPORTS FOR VULNERABLE OLDER
ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR WORK IS
INTEGRATED WITH ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING UNDER THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- IN
PARTICULAR. MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE CLOSELY CO ORDINATED
WITH THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITH THE ELDER JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL. IN TERMS
OF ENSURING EQUITY AND
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE IN
SPEAKING WITH THE T. A. P. G. P.
C. ASSOCIATION. IT'S CLEAR ABOUT
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
NEEDS TO BE ACQUIRED REQUIRED
FULL COMPREHENSIVE DATA ABOUT-
PROBATE CONSERVATORSHIP- THAT
STATUS CURRENTLY HELD BY THE
COURTS- SOMEWHAT COCONSPIRATORS
WILL. ALSO COLLECT SOME OF THIS
DATA BUT IT'S- ON A VERY AD HOC
BASIS SO WE REALLY WANT TO
ESTABLISH A STRONG DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM. ON THE NUMBER
OF- TOTAL CONSERVATORSHIP IS
THERE ARE STATEWIDE BUT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE- WHAT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE POPULATIONS
BETTER SERVED AT THREE
CONSERVATORSHIP. AND WHAT SORTS
OF GAPS IN NEEDS I'M EXIST. THAT
ARE DEMONSTRATED THROUGH THE
DATA. WE THE LASER POSITION AS
CAN BE AND TABLES. ON THE
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS DISCUSS
THE NEEDS AND GAPS OF THE
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS AND HOW
TO STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM
OVERALL- SIMPLISTIC HOLDERS WE
SEE AND WHAT IT MEANS TABLES
WOULD BE. OF COURSE THE LOCAL
PUBLIC GUARDIAN OFFICE SAYS THAT
PAP'S GPC ASSOCIATION. THAT IS
WHAT COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL
SUPERIOR COURTS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND ADVOCATES WE SEE THE
OUTCOME OF THESE DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS AND CHECK OLDER
DISCUSSIONS. TO BE A LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL BUILD
TOWARDS IMPROVING STATEWIDE
EQUITY AND. CONSISTENCY OF THE
PROBATE CONSERVATORSHIP. WELL
NOW MOVES YOU- QUESTION FOR
WHICH ASKS YOU PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW. OF OUR KEY- H. C. B.
S. M. NGA INITIATIVES- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. SO THE- FIRST HERE
IT IS ON SENIOR NUTRITION-
THAT'S REMAINS STEVIE'S LARGEST
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF DOLLARS AND
PEOPLE SEARCH. AND WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT IN
EDUCATION AUGMENTATIONS THAT CD
RECEIVED BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
HAVE HAD A VERY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON- REDUCING THE MAIL GOT
STATEWIDE- FOR OLDER ADULTS. SO
PRIOR TO THE PANDA IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE TRIPLE A.'S THROUGH
THEIR NUTRITION PROVIDERS SERVED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN MILLION
MEALS A YEAR- IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THE NETWORK
WAS ABLE TO EXPAND AND GROW AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION MALES- FOR A TOTAL
OF TWENTY EIGHT MILLION BALES
SERVED- OVER A HUNDRED ANNUAL
BASIS. FOR THIS CURRENT YEAR
WE'RE EVEN GETTING CREATES OUR
MAIL SERVER- EVEN GREATER AND
GET UP TO THIRTY TWO MILLION
MEALS SERVED SO AS WE CAN SEE
THERE HAS BEEN JUST A TREMENDOUS
GROWTH AND IMPACT ON- ADDRESSING
SENIOR HUNGER NUTRITION
STATEWIDE. IN TERMS OF CHALLENGE
- THERE WERE TWO KEY CHALLENGES
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT- FOR THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM- DURING THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC. OF THE
FIRST ONE OF COURSE WAS THE
REQUIREMENT DOROTHY- THE NEED
FOR OUR NUTRITION PROVIDERS TO
GREATLY GROW AND EXPAND THEIR
OPERATIONS- CALVET HEAD AS
QUICKLY AND THEY HAVE TO RESPOND
QUICKLY- BUT THEY ARE ALL
DEFINITELY ROSE TO THE OCCASION
AND WITHIN A MATTER OF TWO TO
THREE MONTHS- ARE TOOK PLACE
YOU'RE ABLE TO. AMEND THEIR
NUTRITION CONTRACTS AND OUR
PROVIDERS ARE ABLE TO STAFF UP
EXPAND THEIR OPERATIONS. CENTER
INNOVATIONS LIKE- RESTAURANT
PARTNERSHIPS GREATLY EXPAND
THEIR OPERATIONS AND SERVICE ALL
MALES. SO REALLY CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT OUR NUTRITION
PROVIDERS THEY REALLY- WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND AND IN MEETING
THE MOMENT. CALVET THE SECOND
CHALLENGE WE HAVE WAS JUST THIS
PAST SUMMER- THE H. REPLACE HER
POSITION TO REOPEN THEIR IN
PERSON AND CONGREGATE MEAL
SITES. BUT WITH THE EMERGENCY OF
THAT DELTA AND ALL CRIME%
VARIANTS THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
PLANS- NOW THAT THE CASE RATES
ARE DECLINING- ARE TRIPLE A.'S
CENTER AS SENIOR- CENTERS ARE
NOW LOOKING TO. RESUME THEIR
CONGREGATE MEAL SITES AND OF
COURSE ALL THE THIS A PLEA-
WITH- FOLLOWING PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS- BASS CONFECTION CONTROL
PRACTICES. AND ENHANCE EQUIPMENT
. THE NEXT PART OF THE QUESTION
SPEAKS TO THE NUTRITION GAP IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'D LIKE TO POINT
YOU TO RECENT STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTED TO ATTEMPT TO
QUANTIFY THE NUTRITION GAP IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FIRST STUDY IS
FROM THE NATIONAL ON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION CALLED FEEDING
AMERICA AND THEY PUBLISH AN
ANNUAL REPORT ON SENIOR HUNGER
CALLED THE STATE OF SENIOR
HUNGER IN AMERICA. IN THE REPORT
THERE'S A TABLE THAT SHOWS THE
FOOD INSECURITY RATE BY STATE.
THEIR LATEST REPORT WHICH COVERS
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
ESTIMATES THAT SIX POINT 3% OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULT
POPULATION EXPERIENCES SOME
LEVEL OF FOOD INSECURITY. AND
ONE POINT 9% EXPERIENCED VERY
LOW AFTER THE SECURITY. THE
SECOND REPORT I'D LIKE TO POINT
TWO ITS REPORT COMPLETED BY
JANET JOHNSON AND ASSOCIATES AND
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ON BEHALF OF C. FOR A WHICH IS
THE FIXATION THAT REPRESENTS
LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
STUDY ESTIMATED THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN RECOVERED EIGHT HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MALES WERE BEYOND THE
REACH OF LOW INCOME- OLDER
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA. DO THE
EXPANSIONS OF CALFRESH BANKS
BUILDER AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS LEGISLATIVE
AUGMENTATIONS. THE STATE WAS
SUCCESSFULLY ABLE TO REDUCE THIS
GAP. AND THE FOOD GAP HAD
SHRUNK- I FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO MILLION MEALS TWO THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION MALES.
CITY IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH. RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
ARE PARTNER DEPARTMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO- BETTER REFINE AND
DEFINE MAIL CAP IN CALIFORNIA
FOR OLDER ADULTS- BUT WE WILL
LOOK TO THE SAP RESEARCH. TO
GUIDE US IN OUR STUDIES- I WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO AND THIS IS P.
AND THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS IS PAM
THE RECENT- SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS THAT WERE REQUESTED SO
THE- CURRENT BUDGET DID INCLUDE
A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT FOR MSSP
PROVIDERS- TO INCREASE THE RATES
THAT REQUESTED SENT TO CMS WE'RE
HAPPY TO SAY THAT REQUEST IS
APPROVED AND SO THE MSSP RATES
AT WILL AND WILL CONTINUE HIGHER
RATES- THAT BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED
AN EXPANSION OF MSSP SITES
RETURN THEM TO THEIR SLOT.
LEVELS PRIOR 220-008-2000 TEN
RECESSION LEVELS- THE MSSP SITES
ARE CURRENTLY STAFFING UP TO-
SERVICE OFFICIAL PEOPLE IN
RESPONSE AND- HAPPY TO SAY THAT
MOST OF THE SITES HAVE A 75280%
FILL RATE FOR THEIR SITES SO AS
A STEP UP WE DO EXPECT THOSE.
PERCENTAGES TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. ALL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY PROJECT. SO
THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'RE
ENGAGED IN WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION-
TO ALLOCATE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDS TO
COUNTIES IN ORDER TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES- PRIMARILY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF REDUCING FEELINGS OF
SISTER SOCIAL ISOLATION
DEPRESSION- THROUGH THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. THAT WE HAVE HAD TWO
MEETINGS WITH CW DA AND-
BOLLINGER COUNTY PRESENTERS TO
HELP US DEFINE THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM- THE REQUIREMENTS.
FUNDING ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
AND EVALUATION- RIGHT NOW WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY. AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE DECISIONS MADE ON
THAT WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH TO
TWO MONTHS- WILL THEN- GO OUT
WITH GRANT SOLICITATIONS THE
COUNTIES. SINCE THIS IS THE
GRANT PROGRAM. AND WE EXPECT
RESPONSES BACK BY SUMMER AND TO
ACTUALLY ALLOCATE. OUT THE
FRANCE BY LATE SUMMER. I'M NOT
MOVING. SHE REPRESENTATIVE. AT
CDA IS CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF STANDING UP THIS NEW OFFICE-
AT THIS OFFICE WILL THEIR
DEATHS- FOR BACKGROUND- FOR- FOR
THE PUBLIC HI THIS PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE- REPRESENTATIVES TO
INCAPACITATED AND REPRESENTED
RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. TRAPPERS NOT HEALTH
CARE WISHES ON FACILITY
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAMS. AND
GENERATED WE HIRED EXECUTIVE TO
LEAD THIS DEPARTMENT SOMEONE
FROM WITHIN OUR ORGANIZATION WHO
HAS GREAT HISTORY AND BOTH
WORKING IN FACILITIES AS WELL AS
ON ELDER JUSTICE ISSUES- SAID
SHE WAS A GREAT HIGHER PRICED-
ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH WE KICKED
OFF THE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
THAT INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM CALF CANNER- AT CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
COMPASSIONATE CARE. L. A. L. T.
THE LEGISLATURE- RIGHT NOW FOR
THE PROCESS OF SOLICITING-
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE LOCAL
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVES AND AT
THE SAME TIME CDA IS CONTINUING
TO DEVELOP POLICIES THAT WILL
COVER MISTER PROGRAM- WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF HIRING A TRAINING
MANAGER WHO WILL SET UP TRAINING
FOR THE NEW REPRESENTATIVES. AND
WE WILL HAVE A PLANT IN. THE
STATE NAY PROGRAM PROVIDES OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH IS THE
COURT ORDER DATE FOR PATIENTS
SENSE TO BE AVAILABLE. AT
FACILITIES. AND THEN I'D LIKE TO
BROAD DATE ON A EIGHTY R. C.
PROGRAM WHICH I WILL LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT AS SEASONAL MENTIONED
KEYSTONE PROGRAM- ADRC ARTISTS.
ESSENTIAL AND CORE TO. OLDER
ADULTS INDIVIDUALS WITH JUST.
BECAUSE TRULY DO YOU AND- IN THE
FUTURE. WILL SERVE THAT SINGLE
DOOR THAT PEOPLE CAN GET WITH.
TAXES OFFICE IN SUPPORTS OUR
BRAVE WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY. SO
IT WILL IS A PROJECT US- WE'RE
HAPPY TO REPORT WE DID ALLOCATED
FOR BOTH THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. FISCAL YEARS- ARE
DESIGNATED AND EMERGING ADR
SEAS- AS A RESULT OF THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS WE DID
HAVE MORE TRIPLE A.'S AS WELL AS
I'LL SEE STEP UP TO EXPRESS
INTEREST- WE- INCREASED ARE
DESIGNATED OR ESTABLISHED EIGHTY
OUR SEEDS FROM SIX TO FIFTEEN.
AND WE HAVE SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
ARE SEIZE EMERGING PARTNERSHIPS
IN PROGRESS SO CURRENTLY WE HAVE
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY R. .'S BACK
COVER 51% THE STATE'S
POPULATION. SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
AUGMENTATIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND SEPARATE
FULL TO OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
WHICH REPLACED AND I'LL SEIZE.
PERCEPTION QUARTERBACK WAY TO-
TO STAND UP RCA'S. I WILL SAY
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN. CHALLENGE
AND- SANTA UP THE SAME PROGRAM-
DURING BETTER HELLO OF RADIO IS
A REALLY CARE TOWARDS WERE.
MEETING MOMENT PROVIDING A
SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC SO THEY
WERE IT HAS SOME WARNING TO HIRE
NEW STAFF AND REALLY THAT SO.
INFO BUT WE DID THAT WE DECLINE
CALVET REYES UP ALLOW HAVE THIS
. AND TO- INCREASE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- SET UP
STRONG- PROGRAMS CHARLIE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM DETERMINE WHAT
THEIR GROWTH RATES WILL LOOK
LIKE. NEXT YEAR- OKAY SO COVERS
MY PROGRAM UPDATES NOW LET'S
MENTION AT CITY HAS EIGHTEEN
CURRENT INITIATIVES UNDER WAY-
OR BETTER MPA AND EACH CBS
INITIATIVES. SO THIS IS JUST
SOME OF OUR LARGER NATIONALS.
SEASON AT HER OPENING REMARKS AT
ALSO TALKED ABOUT OUR DIRECT
CARE WORKFORCE INITIATIVE WHICH
IS ANOTHER. LARGE AND
SIGNIFICANT INITIATIVE THAT
WE'RE ALSO IMPLEMENTING. SO I
JUST WANTED THOSE- I THOUGHT I'D
GO INTO THE LAST QUESTION ON THE
AGENDA WHICH TALKS ABOUT
INTEGRATION. AND WITH SOCIAL AND
HEALTH PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS OUR
PARTNERSHIPS YES ASK. IN ON
THAT- THAT SAY THAT IN THE AREAS
OF HEALTH- WE'VE BEEN VERY
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATIONS AROUND CAL IN
GAME- THE HEALTH BENEFITS THAT
ARE BEING OFFERED WE DO THINK
THAT THE EIGHT YEAR SEES ARE
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT- IN
TERMS OF THE FOR. TO THESE NEW
BENEFITS REFERRALS TO HEALTH
PLANS- AS WELL AS MEDICAID
WAIVER PROGRAMS SEPARATELY
ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON.
CONVERSATIONS ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS DETERMINE
HOW WE CAN RELATE BETTER SHARE
INFORMATION INTEGRATE AND
COORDINATE SERVICES. TRULY
PROVIDE PERSON CENTRED CARE THAT
WERE ALL YOU KNOW LOOKING FOR
DRONE ADRC SYSTEM- IN TERMS OF
THAT SAFETY AN ELDER JUSTICE
ISSUES AGAIN- EIGHTY HER SEATS
CAN SERVICE THAT FOCAL POINT TO
REFER PEOPLE H. GAS. OR LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AND
CHARLIE PUBLIC GUARDIAN PROGRAM.
AND ADDRESS ANY SORT. OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES THAT THEY
MIGHT. AND THEN IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW SOCIAL PROGRAM- STEP
BEHAVIORAL HOW. MORE MINERS FOR
ONE TO DRAW A PEOPLE'S SEARCH
AND MOST MADE- WE DO- ARE EIGHTY
YEARS YOUR- ARE AT I. PROVIDE AS
WELL AS YOUR FOR TO OTHER
COMMUNITY- OTHER WORKING
PARTNERS I WOULD SAY WITH DSS
JUST AND- THERE'S A LOT OF
COOPERATE ON DIGITAL DIVIDE
MISSION IS. ON VACCINATION
OUTRAGE AS WELL AS A VACCINATION
TESTING- TO LOCAL FACILITIES-
YEAH WE THINK THAT WE'RE REALLY
WELL COORDINATED AND INTEGRATED
WITH. DSS UGS AND OUR SISTER-
HHS DEPARTMENTS. SAN BACKING
BECAUSE MY ROOM AND LOOK AT ANY
QUESTION YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR K. SWARTS
LAND WHOSE EXACT DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAROL
SPORTS LANDER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING THE
COMMISSION IS AN INDEPENDENT
ADVISORY BODY ESTABLISHED IN
STATE STATUTE TO SERVICE THE
PRINCIPLE ADVOCATE BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE AND STATE
AGENCIES ABOUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULTS.
COMMISSION MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR IN BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE COMMISSIONERS
REPRESENT THE STATE'S CULTURAL
AND GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY AS WELL
AS A RANGE OF EXPERTISE WITHIN
AND OUTSIDE THE FIELD OF AGING.
ASIANS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
REQUESTS TO PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS AND AN INCREASE IN
FEDERAL FUNDED THIRTY OF THREE
HUNDRED NINE THOUSAND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND TWO HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND I'M GOING TO PROVIDE
THE COMMISSION WITH RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MEET STATUTORY
MANDATES AND AN INCREASED
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MASTER PLAN IMPLEMENTATION.
SUPPORTING COMMISSION MASTER
PLAN PRIORITIES REQUIRES FOCUS
STAFF WORK SUCH AS MONITORING
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND RELATED INITIATIVES
LIKE CAL AIM AND THE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE TASK FORCE.
CONDUCTING RESEARCH AND POLICY
ANALYSIS AND SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RECORD MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND DROPPING
FACT SHEETS AND POLICY
DOCUMENTS. THE REQUESTED
POSITIONS ARE NOT ONLY CRITICAL
BREASTED EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT
MASTER PLAN IMPLEMENTATION
THEY'RE ALSO IMPORTANT TO HELP
CREATE A PROMINENT SOCIAL
PRESENCE TO EDUCATE AND SOLICIT
INPUT. FROM FROM DIVERSE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ON DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THEM AND TO PARTNER WITH
CDA ON THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AGES CAMPAIGN TO ADDRESS AGEISM
SUPPORT INCLUSION AND EQUITY FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. AND PROMOTE
A POSITIVE. IMAGE OF EIGHTEEN
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN. IN RESPONSE
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT HOW- THE
COMMISSION IS WORKING ON-
IMPLEMENTATION FIRST OVER THE
PAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS THE
COMMISSION WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH AND
SUPPORT CDA IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE MASTER PLAN. AND TODAY
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION BY PROVIDING
EXPERT GUIDANCE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PARTICIPATING ON MULTIPLE
ADVISORY GROUPS SUCH AS THE
ELDER AND DISABILITY JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL AND
DISABILITY AND AGING COMMUNITIES
LIVING ADVISORY COMMITTEE. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE COMMISSION
IDENTIFIED FOR PRIORITY MASTER
PLAN FOCUS AREAS OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND INNOVATIVE
MODELS THAT INCREASE ACCESS TO
THE COORDINATION. AND
ACQUISITION OF LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. TO
SUPPORT THESE AREAS THE
COMMISSION SUBSTITUTED SUBMITTED
A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW
LEADERSHIP POSITION FOR
GERIATRIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. THIS POSITION
WOULD PROVIDE SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT IN ADDRESSING THE
WELL DOCUMENTED UNMET BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS. WE FILL THIS
POSITION IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL
TODAY GIVEN THE INCREASED SOCIAL
ISOLATION EXPERIENCED BY OLDER
ADULTS DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
ASIAN HAS ALSO IS LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD ALLOW APPLICABLES
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY OR RCMP'S CURRENTLY
SERVING SIX OF YOUR INDIVIDUALS
TO NOW SERVE MORE THAN SIX
INDIVIDUALS. FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND RCMP'S
CLOSE THEIR DOORS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE EXPECT THIS BILL TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF AVAILABLE BEDS
ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE THE
SMALLER RCMP'S WILL BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE GREATER ECONOMIES OF
SCALE. AND FINALLY THE
COMMISSION IS SPONSORING A FORM
IN MAY FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RELATED TO JUST THE
DIRECT CARE WORKFORCE
GERONTOLOGY GERIATRICS IN
RELATED FIELDS. AND WE'LL HEAR
FROM INDUSTRY LEADERS
RESEARCHERS EDUCATORS AND
WORKERS THE COMMISSION'S GOAL IS
TO DEVELOP AND SUBMIT CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WILL
INCREASE DIVERSITY AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN THESE FIELDS. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM ALEC
COMMACK ANGELI OLD PARKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALKYLATED PRODUCT
LINES- WE ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ALL QUESTIONS. WHERE
MEMBERS ADDS A LITTLE BAKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WITH THE
COMMISSION ON AGING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JACKIE BUT OSSEO WITH THE L. L.
CHECK A ROSY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE WE'VE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSALS- UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND THE
COMMISSION ON AGING AND WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME. ONE
THING THAT WE WOULD FLAG THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
MENTIONED IS- DURING THE
PANDEMIC THERE WERE. ONE TIME
DOLLARS PROVIDED BOTH BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE STATE
TO INCREASE NUTRITION SERVICES
ESPECIALLY- FOR OLDER ADULTS WHO
MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS. TO FOOD AT
THE TIME. AS THOSE FUNDS RAMPED
DOWN- THERE IS A QUESTION OF A-
HOW WOULD WE GO ABOUT
MAINTAINING SERVICE LEVELS-
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT. DURING THE
PANDEMIC- SOME FOLKS MAY HAVE
EXPERIENCED A TEMPORARY CRISIS
AND FOOD ACCESS. BUT ALSO WE
KNOW THAT THERE WAS- PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC AN UNMET NEED A
FOOD- ACCESS IN GENERAL. SO FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY STILL
BE FACING CHRONIC FOOD
INSECURITY- POST PANDEMIC- THE
SUB COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION. POLITICAL
ABOUT TRACKING. AND THE IMPACT
THAT THESE WERE ON THE RAMP DOWN
OF THESE ONE TIME DOLLARS MAY
HAVE ON SERVICE LEVELS- BUT ALSO
WHAT OUR OPTIONS THAT COULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE- TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS. THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE CHRONIC FOOD INSECURITY-
STILL HAVE ACCESS TO SOME LEVEL
OF FOOD ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM HELLO
MICHAEL COSTA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF AREA AGENCIES ON AGING. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M MICHAEL COSTELLO
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN MY ROLE AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE PRIMARILY
TO DISCUSS OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING YOU KNOW
CHEATING THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES OF THE MASTER PLAN
AND HOW THAT FITS WITH OUR
FOUNDING MISSION. WHAT WERE
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS AN AMENDMENT TO THE
OLDER AMERICANS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE. FUNDAMENTAL TO THEIR
PURPOSE WAS AND IS THE GOAL OF
HELPING VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS
HOME AND IN COMMUNITY. SERVICES
OFFERED BY TRIPLE A SIMPLE FALL
FROM A NARROW SET OF COURSE
SERVICES INTO A WIDE RANGE OF
INFORMATION REFERRAL AND OTHER
SERVICES. INCLUDING PROVISION
TRANSPORTATION CASE MANAGEMENT
AND A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
ADDRESSING SOCIAL ISOLATION.
CHIPOTLE'S ACCOMPLISH THIS BY
EITHER PROVIDING SERVICES
DIRECTLY OR CONTRACTING WITH
COMMUNITY NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
FORMING INFORMAL AND FORMAL
LOCAL PROVIDER NETWORKS IN THE
PROCESS. IF YOU LOOK AT IT
HISTORICALLY THE TRIPLE LIKE
NETWORKS INVOLVED OVER THE SAME
PERIOD THE MODERN HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER NETWORKS DEVELOPMENT.
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE NEVER TALKED
TO EACH OTHER MUCH. TELLING
PROVIDES THE VEHICLE FOR THAT
CONVERSATION BY PROVIDING THE
PLATFORM FOR INTEGRATION OF
SOCIAL AND HEALTH CARE SERVICE
DELIVERY HE HAD AIMS TO
ESTABLISH A TRUE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. THAT WOULD ALLOW OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENT AND COMMUNITY FOR AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE. THERE ARE SOME
SUCCESS FACTORS THAT NEED TO BE
MET FOR THIS TO REALLY HAPPEN
HOWEVER. WHAT IS A GOOD SOCIAL
SERVICE AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS NEED TO SHARE THE SAME
GOALS. AND THEY NEED TO SPEAK
THE SAME LANGUAGE WHAT IS CASE
MANAGEMENT TO A SOCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS NOT NECESSARILY.
DEFINED IN THE SAME WAY AS IT IS
FOR A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. AND
YOU ALSO NEED TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY IN THE FOR AFFECTED
MOST OF THE DELIVERY NETWORK.
AND RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT ARE
DELIVERED BY REIMBURSING
PROVIDERS ADEQUATELY. OF COURSE
THE MASTER PLAN PROVIDES
GUIDELINES FOR ACHIEVING. THAT
AS WELL INTERPOLATION THERE
PARTNERS ARE THERE AT THE- OF
PROOF SERVICE THAT ADDRESS.
MASTER PLAN GOAL. SOME OF THE-
MASTERPLAN GOAL NUMBER ONE
HOUSING FOR ALL AGES CHEVROLETS
PROVIDE HOUSING NAVIGATION AND
ASSISTANCE AND HOME MODIFICATION
ASSESSMENT AND REMEDIATION NOW.
BUT COULD ALSO PROVIDE A VARIETY
OF RENT SUBSIDY AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ACTIVITIES
IMPLEMENTABLE WITH ADEQUATE
FUNDING. GOOD HEALTH REIMAGINED
. WHO IS MADISON CRITICAL TO
ADDRESS THE EXISTING NEED IS
MAINTAIN WILL BE ENHANCED LEVEL
OF MEAL PROVISION ACHIEVED
DURING THE PANDEMIC BY USING
STATE FUNDS TO REPLACE EXPIRING
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AS THE
SPEAKER- I MEAN WE PUT BEFORE ME
MENTIONED I WANTED ACCENTUATE
OUT AS WELL THE EXPIRING FUNDS
ADDRESSED MUCH OF THE NEED BUT
THERE STILL REMAINS A DEFICIT.
TO- AN ESTIMATE THREE SEVENTY
MEALS A YEAR MILLION A YEAR
WHICH SHOULD BE ADDRESSED GOING
FORWARD. DEMENTIA AND
ALZHEIMER'S MAY WELL BECOME THE
DEFINING DIAGNOSIS FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS BUILDING A
DIMENSION A DIMENSION
APPLICATION PROGRAM CAN START BY
DEVELOPING PILOT PROGRAMS FOR
DEMENTIA AND ALZHEIMER'S
NAVIGATION SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE SOMETHING WHICH WE- AS A
GROUP. AS AN ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS ADVOCATE. GOAL NUMBER
THREE INCLUSION NOT ISOLATION
VOLUNTEER TRAINING RETENTION CAN
BUILD BACK THE SUPPLY OF
VOLUNTEERS FOR MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
DECIMATED DURING THE PANDEMIC
MANY OF WHICH ARE AWFUL BUT BY
TRIPLE A.'S AND THEIR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. WE HAVE A PROPOSED AN
APPROACH THAT IS PART OF OUR
BUDGET ASK. NUMBER FOR CARE
GIVER SUPPORT EXAMPLES OF
EXISTING TRIPLE A CAREGIVER
DIRECTED SERVICES INCLUDE
INFORMATION ASSISTIVE DEVICES
CASE MANAGEMENT CARE GIVER
COUNSELING LEGAL RESOURCES
RESPITE SUPPORT CAREGIVER
TRAINING AND HOME ADAPTATIONS.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER THINGS TO
CONSIDER PUTTING SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW RECIPIENTS
TO PURCHASE RESPITE SERVICES
ADULT DAYCARE AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE. IN THE END-
TRIPOLI'S OFFER AND ARE
PROPOSING IN IN OUR BUDGET ASK-
CARE GIVER SERVICES THAT CAN BE
BUILT ON GOING FORWARD. CAN WE
DO THIS ALONE OF COURSE NOT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO STRENGTHENING
COLLABORATION WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
PRODUCTIVE CLIENT COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
ARMS BEEN VERY OPEN TO THAT WE
WILL BOTH IT IS. TO ACHIEVE
MASTER PLAN GOALS WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT AVAILABLE IN PIPELINE
FUNDING ARE USED WISELY AND WE
ARE REASONING TOGETHER TO PLAN
AND DELIVER SERVICES MORE
EFFECTIVELY. IT'S ESPECIALLY
HEARTENING TO SEE THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF UP IN A VARIETY OF AREAS.
TO BE BETTER ABLE TO PERFORM
THEIR VARIOUS ROLES AS IT
pFRANKLY TO THEIR INTERACTION
WITH THE TRIPLE IT. WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT THE SERVICES. BOTH
EXISTING AND PROPOSED THAT I
MENTIONED. HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
BECKY DUFFY WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULT DAY
SERVICES. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
DR ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY AS YOU JUST MENTIONED I'M
BECKY DUFFY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES. IT'S A MEMBER
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT SERVICES AN ADULT DAY
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OVER FORTY THOUSAND LOW INCOME
FRAIL ELDERS AND ADULTS RELY ON
OUR SERVICES TO AVOID NURSING
HOMES AND COSTLY HOSPITAL
VISITS. CENTERS COMBAT SENIOR
ISOLATION. AND IT HAS BEEN AT A
PEAK DURING COBIT AND IT DOES
LEAD TO COGNITIVE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL DETERIORATION. 96% OF
THE PARTICIPANTS IN OUR PROGRAMS
ARE MEDICARE AL 60% ARE WOMEN
67% ARE WOMEN THAT WE SERVE A
VERY ETHNICALLY DIVERSE
POPULATION 44% OF OUR
PARTICIPATE ARE PARTICIPANTS.
LIVE ALONE AND THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT BENEFIT FROM CARE
AND THE SOCIAL INTERACTION
THAT'S PROVIDED AT OUR CENTERS.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC BECAME- BEGAN
AND CURRENTLY CENTERS HAVE HAD
LOTS OF CHALLENGING STAFFING
ISSUES I WOULD SAY STAFFING IS
THEIR NUMBER ONE ISSUE. THE MAIN
PROBLEM THEY HAVE IS THAT THEY
CAN'T COMPETE WITH HOSPITALS IN
TERMS OF GETTING REGISTERED
NURSES AND THEY ARE ALSO DEALING
WITH THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN RAISED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE AND WE
ALL KNOW HOW THE COST OF LIVING
HAS INCREASED. DRAMATICALLY
SINCE THEN AND THEY CANNOT
OPERATE WITHOUT THE MINIMUM
REQUIRED NUMBER OF REGISTERED
NURSES AND SOCIAL WORKERS. THE
FEDERAL SPENDING PLAN DOES
INCLUDE ALLOWANCES FOR HARDSHIPS
AND STAFFING AND WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT AGING THEY'VE BEEN A
WONDERFUL PARTNER FOR US THEY DO
HAVE SOME HELP COMING DOWN THE
PIKE FOR WORK FORCE ISSUES
HOWEVER AT THIS POINT THOSE
PLANS DON'T INCLUDE REGISTERED
NURSING STAFF- DID JUST HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH SERWIS DEAN
HOUSE AND YESTERDAY ABOUT THAT
AND WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
HER. CENTERS ALSO CONTINUE TO
FACE CHALLENGES PROVIDING
SERVICES TO KEEP PARTICIPANTS AS
SAFE AS POSSIBLE POST PANDEMIC.
AS WE KNOW FRAIL ELDERS ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE TO COPE IT AND
ARE HIGHER RISK OF DEATH FROM
INFECTION CENTERS HAVE REMAINED
OPEN DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT
THEY'VE HAD TO RELY ON TEMPORARY
APPROVED EMERGENCY SERVICES
THROUGH THE STATE AND PERHAPS TO
HAVE PROVIDED FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND INFECTION CONTROL
AND INCREASED INFECTION CONTROL
TO KEEP THE SENIORS THAT. HAVE
BEEN COMING IN POTENTIALLY EVEN
ON A ONE ON WAIT ONE BASIS TO
THE CENTER SAFELY. SO AS WE MOVE
FROM PANDEMIC TO ENDEMIC AND
RETURN TO CENTER. THEY HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO RETURN TO CENTER IN
FULL CAPACITY. SO THEY NEED TO
MAKE NECESSARY MODIFICATIONS TO
THEIR PHYSICAL SPACES TO HARDEN
THEIR SPACES TO ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN. IT INCLUDES IMPROVING
VENTILATION SYSTEMS MODIFYING
INDOOR SPACES THANK YOU KNOW
ALLOWING FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
REPLACING WINDOWS AND UTILIZING
OUTDOOR SPACES IN WAYS THEY MAY
NOT HAVE HAD TO USE THEM BEFORE.
THEY ALSO HAVE THE HARD THE
CENTERS IN CASE THERE ARE FUTURE
PUBLIC EMERGENCIES. AND EVEN
PREPARE FOR THINGS LIKE
WILDFIRES. ALL OF THESE ARE
UNBUDGETED EXPENSES THAT
FACILITIES HAVE HAD TO PAY FOR
OUT OF POCKET DURING THE
PANDEMIC. ANOTHER HUGE ISSUE
THAT THE CENTERS ARE FACING AS
TRANSPORTATION AND I HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES ON NOT- IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO RETURN TO CENTER.
TO GET PARA TRANSIT READY FOR
PARTICIPANTS IT CAN TAKE UP TO
SIXTY DAYS IF IT'S EVEN
AVAILABLE- IN OXNARD I HAVE A
CENTER. WHERE THEIR DRIVERS ARE
BEING STOLEN AT GAS STATIONS AND
RECRUITED BY FEDERAL EXPRESS SO
THEY REALLY HAVE TROUBLE KEEPING
TRANSPORTATION GOING. AND THEN
THE L. A. N. ORANGE COUNTY
CENTERS HAVE ANOTHER UNIQUE
PROBLEM THEIR CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS KEEP GETTING STOLEN.
AND AS SOON AS THEY REPLACE THEM
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE IN GATED.
AND IN THESE AREAS THAT THEY
JUST KEEP HAVING TO REPLACE THEM
AGAIN. SO ALLOCATING FUNDING IN
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET TO CREATE
GRANTS FOR THE FACILITIES TO
TACKLE THESE EXPENSIVE
CHALLENGES WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD. AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE STATE NEEDS
TO INVEST IN ADULT DAY SERVICES
FOR THE SIMPLE REASON THAT THESE
SERVICES SAVE LIVES AND KEEP
SENIORS OUT OF NURSING HOMES.
THEY KEEP THEM OUT OF ISOLATION
AND IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE THEY
CAN SURVIVE AND THRIVE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS- I WILL KEEP IT HERE AT
THE CHAIR. MY FIRST QUESTIONS
GOING TO BE FOR DIRECTOR DUMB
MORRIS AS WELL AS MISS WARS
LANDER I'M TRYING TO REALLY. GET
WHAT ARE THE MOST DIRE NEEDS.
THAT WE HAVE AT THIS CURRENT
MOMENT IS IT- AS AN EXAMPLE
EITHER SENIOR HOMELESSNESS
SENIOR HUNGER. OR IS IT HEALTH
DISPARITIES CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT AND THEN HOW WILL THE
MASTER PLAN BE ABLE TO PIVOT TO
THESE PRIORITY ISSUES- BASED ON
CURRENT EVENTS THAT WE HAVE
COMING DOWN HOPING YOU CAN
PROVIDE SOME INITIAL COMMENTS.
SURE THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
I'LL GO AHEAD AND START AND THEN
CAROL IF YOU WANTED TO FOLLOW-
YOU YOU HEAD ON- EXACTLY WHAT
THE LEADING ISSUES ARE AND I
DON'T THINK WE CAN SAY THAT
THERE IS ONE ISSUE- IF YOU MAP
IT TO THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
THE FIRST GOAL AREA IS HOUSING
FOR ALL AGES AND STAGES. WE KNOW
FOR A FACT THE RESEARCH WORK OUT
OF UCSF THAT THE LARGEST AND
FASTEST THE FASTEST GROWING
DEMOGRAPHIC IN OUR STATE OR-
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IS AMONG
OLDER ADULTS. SO WE ARE WORKING-
IN WITH- OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
ACROSS AGENCIES AND I DO
PARTICIPATE ON THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS. AND
THAT'S A NEW ADDITION TO HAVE
THE VOICE AND PERSPECTIVE OF
AGING ON THAT. ON THAT BODY WERE
SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION WORK THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND DEFINITELY THROUGH THE AGING
AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTIONS AND OUR TRIPLE A
PARTNERS WE ARE LINKING
INDIVIDUALS AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL WITH HOUSING ASSISTANCE-
WHERE WE CAN- IN TERMS OF SENIOR
NUTRITION WE ARE VERY PROUD AS
MARK BECKLEY MENTIONED. TO HAVE
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF MEALS
THAT ARE DELIVERED AND WE KNOW
THERE ARE STILL GAPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
PARTNERS FOODBANKS MEALS ON
WHEELS. AND OTHER LOCAL PARTNERS
AS PART OF A NETWORK CDA PLAYS A
KEY LEAD ROLE AND WE'RE NOT THE
ONLY MALE PROVIDER IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- IN TERMS OF OTHER
CHALLENGES THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES FACING OUR NETWORK. I
THINK THE GROWTH IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF CARE TODAY AS AS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA LIVE LONGER
WE HAVE THE SECOND. LONGEST
LIFESPAN IN THE NATION- THAT
COMES WITH MORE COMPLEX CARE
NEEDS IN THE AIR IN OF
SPECIFICALLY AS KAREN MENTIONED-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ALZHEIMER'S
AND DEMENTIA AS MICHAEL COSTA
MENTIONED- AND A DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS WHO
ARE AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
AT HOME. WHICH PLACES A HIGHER
RELIANCE ON THE DIRECT CARE WORK
FORCE. US TO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE LEADING CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE- WORKING ON AS A
DEPARTMENT AND ALSO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. IT WILL MISS WORST
WONDER. I'M GONNA CONCUR WITH
DIRECTOR DEMAREST THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO CHOOSE ONE- THE
COMMISSION HAS A STRATEGIC PLAN
AND WE HAD PRIORITIES BUT
ACTUALLY WE- AT THE END OF LAST
YEAR WE REALIZED ALL THESE NEW
ISSUES WERE COMING TO THE
FOREFRONT SO THAT'S WHY WE
PRIORITIZE THOSE FOUR AREAS. AND
IN PARTICULAR OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH I MEAN THE
PANDEMIC JUST RAISE THE PROFILE
OF THE IMPACT ON OLDER ADULTS
THEN HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ISSUES AND MENTIONED THAT FOR
FASTEST GROWING POPULATION IS
FIFTH AGE FIFTY AND OLDER AND
THEN WORKFORCE THAT REALLY CAME
TO THE FOREFRONT SO. IF I HAD TO
PICK MY TOP THREE IT WOULD BE
THERE BUT ALSO NUTRITION IT S
HARD TO CHOOSE THERE'S SO MANY
COMPETING NEEDS BUT THAT'S HOW
THE COMMISSION PRIORITIZED OUR
OUR RESOURCES AND FOCUS-
DIRECTOR OMINOUS. WITH SENIOR
NUTRITION AND FOLLOW UP ON THE
L. A. O.'S QUESTION IF I CAN.
WHAT'S GOING TO OCCUR WHEN THESE
ONE TIME FUNDS RAMPED DOWN HOW
ARE WE GOING TO BE TRACKING
WHAT'S- GOING TO BE OCCURRING
WITH SENIOR FOOD AND SECURITY
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS- TO THOSE
WHO REMAIN FOOD INSECURE AFTER
THIS- WE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT THE
SENIOR MEALS GAP BEING AT THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY. MILLION WHAT
OCCURS POST THE CLIFF WHEN THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING RUNS OUT. I'LL
TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THAT AND THEN
I'LL INVITE MARC BECKLEY TO WHO
HAS BEEN MORE- TOGETHER THAN I
DO- BUT THAT IS SOMETHING WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON LOOKING
AT THE STATE FISCAL YEAR AND THE
DIFFERENT FEDERAL SOURCES
INCLUDING THE OLDER AMERICANS
ACT ARE STAGGERED- SO THERE'S
NOT ONE. ONE DATE WHERE THE CLIP
WILL HAPPEN IT WILL BE STATE SO
I'M GONNA ASK MARK TO ELABORATE
A BIT ON ON THE FORECAST THAT
WE'VE MADE AT THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS AND I'M
HAPPY TO DO SO MISTER CHAIR. SO
YOU KNOW FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OR- PROVIDING
ONGOING AUGMENTATION FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN NUTRITION
FUNDING- THAT IS DEFINITELY
GOING TO HELP- STAVE OFF THE
QUICK SOMEWHAT. ALTHOUGH BUT YOU
KNOW CLEARLY THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE THROUGH
FEDERAL STIMULUS MONEY- YOU KNOW
IT WAS MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT
LEVEL. BUT THAT IS GOING TO
HELP. A BIT WITH THAT GAP- AND
YOU KNOW WILL BE LOOKING FOR
OTHER FEDERAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES- OTHER STATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO- YOU KNOW IF
THE NEED TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THE MAIL GAP IN CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL AS LOOKING AT OTHER
PROGRAMSSUCH AS CALFRESH- THE
FOOD ANKS- LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS TRY TO KEEP UP THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. AND COORDINATE OUR
ACTIVITIES TO TRY TO CAST PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE. AND IN. NEED OF
NUTRITION SERVICES STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ARE I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE TOGETHER- I'D
LIKE TO ASK MY LAST QUESTION IF
I CAN ON. EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF FUNDS AND I WILL ASK IT FOR A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS AND
UNDERSTAND YOU MIGHT. NOT HAVE
THE INFORMATION TODAY. BUT I'LL
BEGIN ON PAGE NINE OF THE
AGENDA. IN REGARDS TO THE
TECHNOLOGY ACCESS PROGRAM. FIRST
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT GOALS DO
YOU HAVE AROUND ENSURING WE HAVE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
FUNDS AND SECOND. CAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING PLEASE
PROVIDE US A MAP WHICH SHOWS HOW
THE FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED ONCE
THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE. I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A SIMILAR REQUEST
FOR MAPPING AND DISTRIBUTION.
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW IT WAS
DECIDED FOR THE SENIOR NUTRITION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING OF FORTY
MILLION. AND FOR THE EIGHTY R.
C. INVESTMENTS TO KNOW WHERE THE
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY OR SEIZE ARE
LOCATED. CAN THE DEPARTMENT
PLEASE PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE ON ATR SEES NOW AND
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY ACCESS AND
SENIOR NUTRITION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVENTS INVESTMENTS ONCE THOSE
ARE AVAILABLE. BUT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE JUST WALK US THROUGH HOW
THE PROCESS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
IS MINDFUL OF THOSE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION CALLS. YES THE
STRUCTURE AT THIS IS MARC
QUICKLY I CAN PROVIDE YOU THE
HIGH LEVEL METHODOLOGY THAT
WE'RE USING- FOR OUR- NUTRITION
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY- PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT WE DO IT'S YOU- STRIVE
TOWARDS- EQUITY SO FOR OUR
NUTRITION PROGRAM WE- DISTRIBUTE
THOSE FUNDS THEY'RE WHAT WE CALL
OUR IF FORMULA OR THE FEDERAL
INTERSTATE FUNDING FORMULA. THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE PERCENTAGE OF
OLDER ADULTS- AND ARMOR- YES
THEY BOUNDARIES AS WELL AS
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS FOR A LOW
INCOME RURAL SO THERE'S- A FEW
FACTORS THAT WE LOOK AT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DISPUTING THE
FUNDING EQUITABLY- ACROSS THE
PSAS AND THAT'S TRUE FOR ALL OF
OUR OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAMS. UP FOR THE ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
IN DISCUSSIONS- RIGHT NOW WITH
CWD A ABOUT. ONE OF THE OPTIONS
IS TO DO A- FUNDING FORMULA
SIMILAR TO THE F. TO LOOK AT
PERCENTAGE OF OLDER ADULTS AND
THOSE ARE LOW INCOME- AND THOSE
WHO HAVE SIGNIFICANT NEEDS SO
WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS BUT ONCE WE HAVE THAT. I
WANT YOU TO FIND WILL BE HAPPY
TO SHARE THAT- AND- WRITTEN. SO
LET ME SEE SO TECHNOLOGY-
NUTRITION. HOW EIGHTY OUR SEATS
SO WITH A EVER SEEN IT IS ALSO
IT'S ACROSS- LOOKING AT THE
LEVEL ADULTS AMENDED- INTO WITH
DISABILITIES AND DIFFERENT OF
THE STATE. AND THEN A BASE
COMPLEMENTED THAT THEY GET AND
THEN ADJUSTING THAT BASED ON
THOSE OTHER FACTORS AND ALSO
NOTE THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO
REFINE THAT FUNDING FORMULA
SOMEWHAT WE'RE NOTICING THAT-
DEPENDING ON HOW DIFFERENT
EIGHTY OUR SEATS OR STAGE IN
THEIR GROWTH RATE THEY MIGHT NOT
NEED AS MUCH MONEY OR THEY MIGHT
NEED MORE MONEY UP FRONT SHE
REALLY GET THEIR PROGRAMS OFF
THE GROUND. START TRYING TO DO A
MORE NUANCED APPROACH WITH HIS
INITIAL ALLOCATIONS- AND THEN
WILL DEFINITELY. CREATE A
STANDARD- OUT OF CARE. YOU SAID
IT WAS PERCENT OF OLDER ADULTS-
IS THAT OLDER ADULTS INCLUSIVE
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS OR ARE THERE
LIMITATIONS- SINCE IT'S A
FEDERAL PROGRAM. ON HOW WE ARE-
COUNTING OLDER ADULTS. RIGHT SO
WHAT- UNDER THE- FEDERAL OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAM- IT'S
BASED ON OLDER ADULTS OR SIXTY
PLUS- SO THAT'S THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR THAT SO THAT'S THE
POPULATION OF WHERE THAT WE LOOK
AT I WILL THE NEXT ASK THE
QUESTION EXPLICITLY- CITIZENS
VERSUS- OTHER CALIFORNIANS- WE
YOU KNOW WE- ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
IN ORDER WE ASK ABOUT SOMEBODY'S OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. SO IT'S ALL OLDER ADULTS
. THANK YOU FOR THAT- WITH THAT
BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
I FIRST WANT TO THANK THIS PANEL
FOR HELPING US TO UNDERSTAND THE
LANDSCAPE OF WORK INVOLVED IN
THE MASTER PLAN OF AGING.
INCLUDING THE UPDATES ON
INVESTMENTS WHICH WERE MADE AS
PART OF OUR RECENT BUDGET WE
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK CLOSELY AT
THESE AREAS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
ON ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS THAT
MAY RESULT FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO SPENDING PLAN WITH
THAT WE WILL HOLD OPEN ISSUES
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO. WITH
ISSUE TWO WE WILL BE DISCUSSING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
OVERSIGHT ISSUES FOR THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IHS US
PROGRAM. WE WILL HAVE EIGHT
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL FOR
ISSUE TO. FIRST WILL BE DIRECTOR
TIM JOHNSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOLLOWED BY LEORA. FEEL CENA THE
ADULT PROGRAMS DEPUTY DIVISION.
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES A
NOM COM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JACKIE BUT OSSEO WITH
THE L. A. HELLO KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD'S WITH CW DA. TIFFANY
WHITEN SENIOR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ADVOCATE WITH SEIU.
EVERLY YOU WITH UT W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND
ELIZABETH ZURICH OR THE MANAGING
ATTORNEY FOR THE HEALTH CARE
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES PRACTICE GROUP WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
LET US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR
PHILO SCENE OF DSS WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMBERS I CAN
JOHNSON CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW THAT
LAST PANEL AND ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE ART
. ALAMEDA AT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
BURKE BROADLY ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
IMPLEMENTATION AND MANY OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE
TOGETHER. I ALSO JUST ADD DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AS
WE'RE LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT ONE OF
THE INTERNAL OPERATIONAL CHANGES
WE'VE MADE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS TO
ORGANIZE OURSELVES IN THE WAY TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN THOSE
INTEGRATION OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING. THE CREATION OF A
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR POSITION
FOR DISABILITY ADULTS IN HOUSING
INTEGRATION AND THAT IS CLEAR
RAMSEY WHO YOU'LL MEET OUR NEXT
PANEL JUST A MOMENT. I ALSO JUST
WANNA HIGHLIGHTS THE CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND SUPPORT SO
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BLIND OR OVER SIXTY FIVE OR WHO
ARE DISABLED OR PERSONAL CARE
AND OTHER SERVICES. I APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR AGENDA OUTLINES THE
NUMEROUS COVERT SUPPORTS AND
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WE WERE
WORKING TOGETHER X.
OPERATIONALIZE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE SOME OF
THOSE IN IN EVEN GO FURTHER SUCH
AS THE BACKUP PROVIDER PAYMENT
SYSTEM WHICH WILL TALK TO YOU
JUST ABOUT A MINUTE ABOUT IN
TERMS OF TRANSITION AND
PROPOSAL. AT TO MAKE THAT
PERMANENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF THE PARTICIPANTS
IN RECIPIENTS AN IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK FORCE. I AM
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE CAN MAKE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IN THE SPACE
AT THE HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES PLANETS REFERENCED IN
YOUR GENDER SPEAKS TO. ASK SOME
OF THOSE INVESTMENTS INCLUDING
THE CARE. ECONOMY PAYMENTS IN
RECOGNITION OF THE EFFORTS OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF I. HSS
WORKERS REALLY DID SUPPORT YEAH
INDIVIDUALS. OVER THESE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND SOMETHING TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT SUPPORT ABBAS
WAS REALLY A GREATLY RECEIVED.
AND WE'RE GLAD TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THEM MAKE THOSE RESOURCES.
WE ARE ALSO EXTRA. EXCITED ABOUT
TO BECOME PATH. WERE THAT WE
DOING I WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
IS A FOLK ON RECALL. NEW HSS
WORKER READ. EXISTING I JUST AS
WORKERS AND ALSO PROVIDING
UPWARD CAREER MOBILITY
OPPORTUNITIES AND PATHWAYS FOR
THOSE MEMBERS OF THE EXISTING I
JUST LAST WORKFORCE. DID YOU
WANT TO. FURTHER IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THROUGH VARIOUS LISTENING JEFF
SESSIONS WE INTEND TO DATE. OUT
TO HEAR THE EXCITEMENT FROM THE
FIELD THEMSELVES THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO EAGERNESS TO
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN THEIR OWN
CAPACITIES AND COMPETENCIES
AROUND AREAS LIKE DEMENTIA.
ACCEPT READ BUT ALSO- JUST
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ENGAGE IN
ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING. WITH
THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE SENATE
TO ANSWER THE SPECIFIC.
QUESTIONS IN YOUR AGENDA IN HERE. TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOLLOWING THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THE COMPANY.
IT IS THAT RIGHT- WELCOME. THREE
BILLION DOLLARS- DUE TO
CONTINUED CASE MOST ROBUST. MISS
PHYLLIS IN- JUST- WE HAD A
TECHNICAL COLLECTION MISSED THE
PAST MAJORITY OF YOUR TESTIMONY
THUS FAR I MAY ASK YOU TO BEGIN
AT THE BEGINNING IF THAT'S OKAY-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. SURE
DEFINITELY CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME
NOW. LOUDLY AND CLEARLY THANK
YOU PERFECT ALL RIGHT SO I WAS-
GOING OVER THE OVERVIEW OF THE
HSS BUDGET SO THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET REFLECTS AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS REALLY- DUE TO
CONTINUED JAMES SPOKE PRO OSCAR
OUR WORK AND THE WORST PER CASE-
THIS BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES A FULL
YEAR OF COST OF THE INCREASE TO
MINIMUM WAGE. TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS
PER HOUR. SOME OF THE NEW ITEMS
IN THE BUT INCLUDES THE
PERMANENT PROVIDERS. THE
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE- PHASING IN
THE MEDICAL ASSET LIMIT REPEAL.
OF A TEMPORARY SIX POINT TWO F.
MAP INCREASE RELATED TO OBEY IT
AS WELL AS- THE EVENING ETERNAL
REDOX. OF HALF OF THE YEAR. I'LL
GO AHEAD AND GO TO- NUMBER TWO.
WHAT THE RISKS OF MEDICAL
REDETERMINATION EXPECTED TO
OCCUR JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOUR I JUST AS RECIPIENTS CAN
HELP THE FEET THE- ATTEMPTS TO
AVOID A POTENTIAL LOSS OF
SERVICES PROVIDES US WITH THE-
SO OUR PLAN IS TO WORK WITH THE
H. C. S. TO REALLY MAXIMIZE
CONTENT. CONTINUITY OF COVERAGE
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
ENSURE THAT WE KEEP THE PROCESS
AS SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE FOR OUR
JUST AS RECIPIENTS. AND REALLY
HUMANS ARE STAKEHOLDERS-
COUNTIES CONSUMER ADVOCATES
CETERA AS MESSENGERS. AT AND OUR
AUTOMATED- MESSAGING
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS TO
DISSEMINATE OUTRAGE MESSAGING TO
REALLY REMIND PEOPLE TO.
COMPLETE THEIR MEDICAL
RETIREMENT EACH. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT BEACH
YESTERDAY TO EXPLORE A NUMBER OF
FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY IN THIS AREA
AND WE PLAN ON WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THEM ON ON
THESE POLICIES AS IT RELATES TO
MEDICAL. REDETERMINATION AND THE
NEED FOR POLICY GUIDANCE TO THE. THE QUESTION NUMBER THREE IS
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE BEING RAISED
REGARDING THE PERMANENT PROVIDER
BACKUP SYSTEM AND WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE. WHAT
IS THE STATUS OF STAKEHOLDERS
SPECIALISTS AND WINNABLE A NEW
VERSION OF TRAILER BILL BEING
RELEASED. SO WE'VE SO FAR
RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM OUR LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS CAPITAL C. WAMC'S
FACT- THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED INCLUDED- ASKING FOR THE
WAGE DIFFERENTIAL. UP TO BE
ICLUDED IN THE LANGUAGE SIMILAR
TO THE EMERGENCY BACK UP
PROVIDER SYSTEM FOR KOBE- I
THINK THEY'RE FLYING LANGUAGE TO
DEFINE TERMS IN CONSIDERATION OF
THE INCREASE IN THE EIGHTY HOUR
CAP- WE ARE STILL ENGAGING IN
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE INTEND TO
RELEASE A REVISEDTRAILER BILL
BY THE END OF APRIL- WE'RE- AND-
OF. AS ALWAYS WE ARE COMMITTED
TO IDENTIFIES SYSTEM THAT
ENSURES HSS RECIPIENTS RECEIVE
THE SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED A
THROUGH THE EMERGENCY BACKUP
PROVIDERS SYSTEM. THE NEXT
QUESTION IS PLEASE DESCRIBE THE
DIFFERENCES AND NEED FOR THE I.
HSS IMPORTER DEFINITION TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL. SO WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WE LET EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT WE CONSIDER THIS
TRAILER BILL TO BE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND IT DOES NOT PROPOSED
TO CHANGE EXISTING LAW RATHER
CODIFIED- FIELD LABOR CODE THAT
THE COUNTING IN THE STATE ARE
NOT THE. HERE BEING OF EXISTING
IS REALLY TO STOP A- IN WHICH
AGENTS RESEARCH HAVE THEM BEING
RULES TO HIRE ALL OF I AS- WELL
. PROVIDING COLLECT BARGAIN AND
TO THOSE HSS PROVIDERS WERE PART
OF THE REGISTRY. EXISTING ONE
NEVER INTENDED TO REQUIRE THE
STATE'S GOING TO ASSUME LEGAL
LIABILITY FOR THE ACTIONS ARE
YOU JUST AS RECIPIENTS WHO ACT
AS EMPLOYERS IN THEIR OWN HOMES. NEXT QUESTION PLEASE PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE IHS US CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM AND SHARE ANY ISSUES OR
CHALLENGES OF WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE AWARE. IN
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WE ESTABLISHED TO GENERAL CAREER
PATHWAYS ARE RICH ARE REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL IN THE PREPARATION
OF OTHER HEALTH CARE FIELDS AND
AN ADDITIONAL THREE SPECIALIZED-
PATHWAYS WHICH ARE REALLY MEANT
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES THAT ARE HSS RECIPIENTS
RECEIVE. WE HOSTED THREE I'M
LISTENING SESSIONS WITH A
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. OF THE
MOST RECENTLY WAS ON MARCH TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO A LOT OF
REALLY GREAT FEEDBACK FROM I
JUST AS PROVIDERS WERE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY WE- HAVE BEGUN
WORKING WITH COUNTIES AND PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES WEEK SENT A SURVEY-
TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY OF THEM
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN BEING
PART OF THE CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. IN TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES
EXPRESSED INTEREST- SO WE WILL
BE WORKING WITH THOSE CHINESE
MOVING FORWARD. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON BRING ON A CONSULTANT
WILL ASSIST WITH THE BUILDING OF
THE ACTUAL CAREER PATHWAY
CATALOG FOR THIS PROGRAM AS WELL
AS THE- ASSISTANT AND THOSE
TYPES OF. THAT INFORMATION THAT
PROVIDERS WILL NEED. AN ALL AND
MOST RECENTLY WE ISSUED THE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL OR PROPOSAL
ON MARCH ELEVENTH- FOR TREATING
VENDORS THE R. P. WILL BE- WILL
CONCLUDE ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND IT CAN BE
EITHER ON THE KALECKI PORCHER.
WEBSITE SO DEFINITELY MORE TO
COME. A CAREER PATH THANKS. AND
THEN THE QUESTION IS. HOW DOES
YOU ASSESS OF THAT IS A
PROCEDURES FOR I AS A LINE WITH
THE WITH THE MASTER PLAN EACH.
HAS OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING SPOKE ABOUT
WE DEFINITELY WORK WITH THEM
VERY CLOSELY ADDITIONALLY WE
PARTICIPATED THROUGHOUT THE
MATCH UPON AGING PROCESS WITH
MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
HSS WAS INTEGRATED INTO THE- HAS
BEEN THE- SEVERAL THE- AND
INITIATIVES- MY CAREER PATHWAYS-
ARE BEING THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON THEM ANYTHING AND-
THE REST. WERE RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE AS PART OF THE MASTER PLAN.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
SERVICES THAT'S DEFINITELY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AS WELL AS WE
ARE ONE OF THE STATE MEMBERS UP
ON THE DISABILITY. COMMUNITY
LIVING ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH
IS WORKING ON A LONG LONG TERM
SIR SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ALONG
WITH OTHER TOPICS TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
HSS RECIPIENTS AND AREN'T
ALIGNED WITH THE MASK. H. SO
THAT INCLUDES THE- THE QUESTIONS
. GEN X. Q. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
ON KA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINAL. CONFERMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
HAPPY ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM JACKIE BUT
I WOULD THE L. A. HELLO- IT IN
RESPONSE TO THE FIRST QUESTION-
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON JUST SOME
TECHNICAL BUDGET QUESTIONS BUT-
IN OUR INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE I
JUST AS BUDGET A FEW THINGS THAT
WE WOULD FLAG. IS ONE WE'RE
STILL CONTINUING TO SEE THAT THE
GROWTH IN H. SAYS PAID CASELOAD
AND CONTINUES TO BE SLOWER THAN
IT WAS IN PRECOVERED NINETEEN
RATES- IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. ON THIS TREND
CAN BE DETAIL RECIPIENT STILL
FEELING APPREHENSIVE ABOUT
LEADING NON FAMILY NON LIVE IN
PROVIDE SERVICES BUT ALSO THIS
TREND COULD BE POSSIBLY DUE TO
RECIPIENTS HAVING DIFFICULTY.
LOCATING AND HIRING PROVIDERS-
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO GET ADDITIONAL DATA
ON APPLICATION IN CASE LOAD
INFORMATION- TO SEE IF THERE IF
WE CAN FURTHER IDENTIFY ANY
OTHER POSSIBLE REASONS THAT THIS
COULD BE HAPPENING AND WE'LL
MAKE SURE TO REPORT BACK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- AS MORE
INFORMATION BECOMES AVAILABLE.
SECOND THING THAT I WOULD FLAG
IS- IN OUR ANALYSIS WE ALSO FLAG
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER- THE FUTURE USES OF THE
POPE IN NINETEEN PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES THAT THE STATE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE ACCESS
PROGRAM SOME OF THESE INCLUDED-
WAVING. FINGERPRINTING
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND INSTEAD
USING NAME BASED BACKGROUND
CHECKS OTHERS INCLUDED- ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO CONDUCT REMOTE
REASSESSMENTS- IN OUR ANALYSIS
WE JUST FLAG THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
ANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
FLEXIBILITIES MERIT-
CONSIDERATION FOR AN EXTENSION.
OR ALTERNATIVELY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER WHETHER IT
SHOULD DEVELOP GUIDANCE- AND
RULES AROUND POSSIBLY
MAINTAINING THESE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT COULD THEN BE ACTIVATED-
WITH ANY FUTURE COLBERT NINETEEN
SEARCHES ARE JUST EMERGENCIES IN
GENERAL LIKE. WILDFIRES IN
CERTAIN REGIONS. I'M TO GET TO
THE SECOND. IN THE AGENDA
REGARDING THE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE ISSUE AS THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES ASSUME THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THE STATE TO TEMPORARILY
WAIVE OUR PA'S MEDICAL
REDETERMINATION- THIS
FLEXIBILITY HAS AND IT HAS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR ABOUT TWO YEARS.
HOWEVER ONCE THIS FLEXIBILITY
EXPIRES- THAT ESSENTIALLY MEANS
THAT COUNTIES WILL BE REQUIRED
NOT ONLY TO RESTART MEDIKAL
REDETERMINATION BUT ALSO GO BACK
AND PROCESS THOSE. FROM
REDETERMINATION THE- FROM THE
PAST TWO YEARS- SEWING
COMPLETING THOSE REACH
TERMINATIONS WE JUST KNOW
NATURALLY SOME INDIVIDUALS MAY
SUBMIT THEIR PAPERWORK AND WE
MAY FIND THAT THERE ARE NO
LONGER ELIGIBLE BASED OFF OF
CERTAIN PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
RULES. HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT
STILL MAY MEET MEDICAL G. BILITY
ROLES. BUT JUST BECAUSE THEY
FAIL TO COMPLETE THE PAPERWORK
ON TIME AND SUBMIT IT. WILL BE
TERMINATED FROM MEDIC CAL. I'M
SO FOR THOSE I JUST AS
RECIPIENTS WHOSE MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY DUE TO FAILURE TO
COMPLETE THE MEDICAL
REDETERMINATION PAPERWORK- TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION IN THE
AGENDA- SOME WAYS IN WHICH- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER-
PROVIDING SOME LEVEL OF
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
COULD BE. PROVIDING MORE
FRONTEND SERVICES WHEN IT COMES
TO ON PROVIDING APPLET. REACH
TERMINATION ASSISTANCE IN
FILLING OUT THE PAPERWORK- BUT
ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE FLAGGED
AS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING TEMPORARY I
JUST AS BRIDGE SERVICES. THAT
WOULD ALLOW- RECIPIENTS SOME
TIME TO SUBMIT THE PAPERWORK-
GET BACK ON MEDIC CAL AND THEN
TRANSITION BACK TO THE FEDERALLY
FUNDED I JUST AS PROGRAM IN
THOSE BRIDGE SERVICES. I'M COULD
BE OPERATED A COULD BE OFFERED
THROUGH THE STATE ONLY I JUST AS
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE. OF COURSE
BOTH OF THESE OPTIONS THERE
WOULD BE COST CONSIDERATIONS BUT
ALSO- ADMINISTRATIVE- COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPLICATIONS AS
WELL THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
THOUGHT THROUGH- BUT HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM KATHY SUNDERLAND WITH
DONALD LET'S SEE WTF. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
IN PERSON TO TESTIFY KATHY
CENTER LIMITADA LET'S SEE WTA.
WE WERE ASKED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT COUNTY I TO
ASSESS PROGRAMS ARE SEEING ON
THE GROUND. AND I THINK IT DOES
TRACK VERY MUCH TO WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND
FROM HIS BRO CO THAT WE SAW
LOWER DEMAND DURING THE PANDEMIC
NOT SURPRISINGLY- PEOPLE KIND OF
HUNKERED DOWN. A LOT OF FOLKS
WERE AT HOME AND WE JUST DID NOT
SEE AS MANY APPLICATIONS COMING
INTO THIS PROGRAM AS WE MAY HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE CALFRESH
PROGRAM WE DID SEE. QUITE A
SPIKE THAT HAVE STARTED
INCREASING BACK UP RECENTLY AS
THINGS HAVE RE OPENED WE HAVE
SEEN THAT IT'S ON UP TECH AND
APPLICATIONS AND I KNOW THE
STATE IS PROJECTING ABOUT A TWO
AND A HALF 23% INCREASE. IN THE
COMING YEAR THAT'S COMPARED TO
MORE LIKE 526% HISTORICALLY
WHICH IS MORE IN LINE WITH OUR-
SORT OF AGING OF OUR POPULATION
IS AROUND THAT FIVE TO SIX
PERCENT. AS NOTED THAT IS ONLY
PAID CASES SO THERE MAY BE MORE
INDIVIDUALS COMING ON TO THE
PROGRAM WHO IS NOT YET SECURED A
PROVIDER AND WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT TO YOU- WE'RE NOT
SURE OF COURSE THAT THIS IS MORE
OF A SHORT TERM ISSUE WITH THAT
PANDEMIC RELATED. IS IT- SORT OF
BY PRODUCT WHAT MANY OF US ARE
SEEING AND COUNTIES- AT THAT THE
WORK FORCE HAS JUST CHANGED AT
LEAST TEMPORARILY AND WHO IS
AVAILABLE TO WORK IN THESE
POSITIONS OR IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE ONGOING OR
FOR OTHER REASONS. IT REALLY
BEARS LOOKING AT THAT TOGETHER
WE THINK WITH STAKEHOLDERS- THAT
APARTMENT THE L. A. IT'S
SATURDAY I'M TO TRY TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS THAT THAT
QUESTION. THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES- WE ARE ALSO FACING
WORKFORCE ISSUES LOCALLY-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TURNOVER-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF BURN OUT.
OF THERE IS DIFFICULTY HIRING
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING THAT TO
AN COUNTIES JUST AS EVERYONE IS-
AND SO WE DO APPRECIATE THE-
THAT WE'VE HAD. AROUND OUTCOMES
AND SORT OF OUR QUALITY WITH
THE- THE STATE WE KNOW AT SOME
POINT OBVIOUSLY. THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET GOING AGAIN BUT NOT
HAVING ENOUGH STAFF IS CERTAINLY
GOING TO. AFFECT THE OUTCOME
MEASURES WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE
KNOW THE STATE KNOWS THAT AS
WELL CALLIE'S ARE TRYING I MEAN
OUR STAFF THAT WE DO HAVE ARE
TRYING. AS HARD AS THEY CAN. AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS THE
FLEXIBILITIES- WE WERE ASKED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. I WOULD SAY
I'M PRETTY MUCH ANY AND ALL OF
THE ONES THAT ARE LISTED IN YOUR
AGENDA. WE SUPPORT AND WOULD
REALLY LOVE TO SEE CONTINUE.
SPECIFICALLY USE SELF
ATTESTATION WHEREVER POSSIBLE
DOING ASSESSMENTS OR
REASSESSMENTS- WHATEVER COULD BE
DONE VIRTUALLY WHETHER THAT IN
PERSON THAT DOES. NOT ONLY KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE AS WE KNOW COVERT
HAS NOT DISAPPEARED IN THE
POPULATION WE WORK WITH. IS
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION- EVEN STILL THAT ALSO
SAVES TIME OF COURSE AS WELL FOR
STAFF THEY MAY BE ABLE TO DO.
MORE OF THOSE IN A DAY OR A WEEK
THAN IF THEY WERE TRAVELING. TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES- OF COURSE THERE
MAY BE TIMES AND BEING IN PERSON
MAKES THE MOST SENSE AND SO WE
WOULD WANT TO- THINK THROUGH
THAT WITH THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. AS WELL- BEING ABLE
TO SUBMIT FORMS VIRTUALLY OR BY
MAIL OR FAX RATHER THAN HAVING
TO COME. TO THE OFFICE TO SUBMIT
THEM IN PERSON TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE WE SAW THAT IS
VERY USEFUL AND- DON'T REALLY
SEE MUCH OF A NEED TAKEN. YOU
KNOW KIND OF GET BACK TO THAT IN
PERSON SUBMISSION- PEOPLE ARE I
THINK USED TO DOING. PROVIDER
PROCESS WERE VERY INTERESTED IN
THAT OF COURSE- WE AGREE WITH MR
LETS YOU KNOW THAT THEIR BEEN
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS. THERE
WAS A MEETING JUST YESTERDAY
THAT I HAD STAFF AT. AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE UNIONS WITH CAP OTHER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IS HERE- I
WILL NOTE THAT SOME QUESTIONS
AROUND ENSURING. SUFFICIENT
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS FOR THE
COUNTIES- WERE NOT AWASH IN
FUNDING SO MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING A GOOD JOB WITH THE
STATE OF. ESTIMATING THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ON OUR END
WOULD BE HELPFUL AS WELL
THINKING ABOUT THE START DATE WE
WOULD WANT THIS TO WORK WHILE.
AND CURRENTLY I BELIEVE- THE-
PROPOSED STATE IS- AT THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR THE STARTOF THE
NEW FISCAL YEAR- WERE SUGGESTING
YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER.
SCOOTING THAT OUT JUST A FEW
MONTHS PERHAPS EXTENDING WHAT WE
HAVE NOW WHICH THERE IS A BACK
UP SYSTEM NOW IT'S JUST NOT SORT
OF THE ON GOING- IDEAL SYSTEM.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT IT TAKES US
ALL A LITTLE WHILE THE KIND OF
LAND. THE PLANE OF THE LANGUAGE
AND GET EVERYTHING- PUT TOGETHER
FOR THE ON GOING. THE OTHER
THING WILL I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION IS JUST- WE ARE
PROPOSING. A NEW ASSESSMENT
PROCESS OF REASSESSMENT PROCESS.
THAT SORT OF BUILDS ON WHAT'S
CALLED VARIABLE REASSESSMENTS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
CREATED. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR BUT IS ONLY AVAILABLE
FOR A LIMITED- SET OF R. I. H.
SETH RECIPIENTS. THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE RECIPIENTS WHO ARE
STABLE HAVE VERY LITTLE CHANGE
IN THEIR HEALTH CONDITION AND
THERE'S VERY LITTLE CHANGE N
THEIR HOURS FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
AND SO- WE THINK THAT BEING ABLE
TO DO MORE OF A PAPER BASED
ASSESSMENT. FOR THEM FOR SAY TWO
YEARS AND THEN DOING A FACE TO
FACE IN THAT THIRD YEAR WOULD
MAKE SENSE- WE- I HAVE
LEGISLATION THAT WERE WORKING
ON- AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO. ON
THE OR CO SPONSORING WITH
JUSTICE IN AGING THAT WOULD DO
THIS AND- WE THINK THAT IT WOULD
HELP. SORT OF IN THE VEIN AS
WELL AS THE OTHER FLEXIBILITIES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. INSURE
THAT WERE ABLE TO FOCUS THE
LIMITED SOCIAL WORKER. TIME ON
CASES THAT ARE VARIABLE FROM
YEAR TO YEAR NEW PEOPLE COMING
IN THAT WE REALLY NEED TO FIGURE
OUT KIND OF WHAT'S GOING ON OR
WHAT DO THEY NEED. AND THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS SO THAT'S WHERE
THAT PROPOSAL COMES FROM. THANK
YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM TIFFANY WHITEN WITH
THIS YEAR YOU. THANK YOU. ANYWAY
WITH AS A YOUTH CAL. THING YOU
CHAIR. DA LEADING. I FOR THE
APP. TO WITH THE- WE REPRESENT
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE WORKERS
REPRESENTED BY SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I WAS GIVEN TO
QUESTIONS THE ANSWERS I'LL JUST
JUMP RIGHT INTO THOSE THE FIRST
QUESTION IS HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
ENSURE THAT THE AGE OF SAYS
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL FOR EXISTINGAND
FUTURE- PROVIDERS. FIRST WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO UPLIFT AND INVEST
IN THE HSS WORKFORCE AND IN THE
CARE THAT THEY DELIVER TO THEIR
CONSUMERS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH
DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND HER TEAM.
TO DISCUSS THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE-
LEGISLATURE IN THIS COMMITTEE.
TO ENSURE SUCCESS WE BELIEVE YOU
HAVE TO FIRST MEET THE PROVIDER
WHERE THEY'RE AT. I JUST AS
PROVIDERS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS. OLDER THAN THE
WORKING AGE POPULATION AT LARGE
AND HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION
OR LESS. ANY TRAINING PROGRAM
MUST RECOGNIZE THIS AND ADDRESS
THE STRUCTURAL BARRIERS AND
INEQUITIES MANY I. HSS PROVIDERS
SPACE. THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
MODELED ON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT FOSTER EQUITY AND
ACCESS AND PROMOTE LEARNING
RETENTION AND ADVANCEMENT AMONG
ADULT LEARNERS. THE PROGRAM WILL
UTILIZE AN ONLINE PROGRAM WHICH
THERE IS A NEED FOR HOWEVER WE
WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THE OPTION
FOR IN PERSON TRAINING AND
CLASSES. AS WELL AS A HYBRID
APPROACH WE KNOW ALL COUNTIES
ARE NOT THE SAME AND IN SOME
AREAS ACCESS TO THE INTERNET CAN
BE DIFFICULT SO ENSURING
TECHNOLOGY AND INTERNET
CAPABILITIES. ARE ASSESSABLE AS
WELL AS A PHYSICAL SITE ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR SUCCESS. WE WILL
EACH PATHWAY SHOULD HAVE LEVELS
OR MULTIPLE CLASSES WITH IN IT.
EACH STEPS ALLOWED FOR SKILL AND
KNOWLEDGE PROGRESSION. BY GIVEN
THE PROVIDERS A ROBUST TRAINING
PROGRAM WITH STACKABLE
CREDENTIALS ALLOWS PROVIDERS TO
MOVE ALONG THE CAREER LADDER. AS
WAYS OF ADVANCEMENT OUTSIDE OF
THE MORE TRADITIONAL COLLEGE
PATHWAYS. IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE- RESTRICTED THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR THE
SPECIALIZED CAREER PATHWAY TO
ONLY PROVIDERS WHO TAKE ON A NEW
CLIENT. ACTUALLY CREATES
PERVERSE INCENTIVES SUCH AS
GREATER TURN OVER. THE BENEFITS
OF A TRAINED I HSS PROVIDER
EXTENSIVE BOTH NEW AND EXISTING
CONSUMERS. THIS PROGRAM HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE FOR BOTH. PROVIDERS
AND CONSUMERS AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO DISCUSS AS WE ALL
HAVE THE HAVE THE COMMON GOAL TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM A SUCCESS. AND
ADVANCE HIGH QUALITY HOME CARE
JOBS TO DELIVER THE BEST CARE AS
POSSIBLE TO THE CONSUMERS. THE
SECOND QUESTION IS WHAT- CHANGES
WOULD FURTHER SUPPORT HSS
PROVIDERS IN ADDITION TO HAVING
A HIGH QUALITY HOME CARE JOB
PROVIDERS ALSO NEED RETIREMENT
SECURITY. CAL SAVERS AS YOU KNOW
IS A RETIREMENT PROGRAM FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT DO NOT
HAVE AUTOMATIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT OPTIONS SUCH AS R. I.
HSS PROVIDERS. THE PROGRAM GETS
PROVIDERS THE ABILITY TO
CONTRIBUTE ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS
AND THEY CAN OPT IN OR OUT OF
THE PROGRAM AS DESIRED.
CURRENTLY I HSS PROVIDERS HAVE
TO SELF AND ROLL INTO THE
PROGRAM AND MANUALLY MAKE THEIR-PAYMENTS EACH MONTH BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO AUTOMATIC
DEDUCTIONS. JOINTLY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON- WE
PROPOSE TO ALLOCATE THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME- FUNDING TO REPROGRAM
SIEMENS THE AGE OF SETS A
PAPERLESS SYSTEM. TO DO
AUTOMATIC PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS FOR
PROVIDERS THAT CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIPHATE
THIS PROGRAM THIS AUTOMATIC
DEDUCTION IS IMPORTANT TO
IMPLEMENT AS THERE WILL BE A
STEP AND HAVING MORE I HSS
PROVIDERS IN ROLE IN THE
CALIPHATE FIRST PROGRAM AND
ULTIMATELY. TO HAVE RETIREMENT
SECURITY IT'S A MODEST
APPROPRIATION WITH THE HUGE
IMPACT AND WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
FURTHER SUPPORT AGES AS
PROVIDERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM BEVERLY YOU WITH
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY. MISTER CHAIRMAN. REALLY
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL THREE
NINE THIRTY. WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS STATEWIDE. THANK YOU FOR
THE HEARING TO BE APPRECIATE
THAT ACCOMMODATION TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY WITH THE QUESTIONS
TODAY. BURKE WHAT ARE SOME
PARAMETER THE STATION CONSIDER
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ISIS
THAT'S OF THE PCS FROM THE
BACKUP SYSTEM. IN CREATING A
FRAMEWORK FOR CORNERBACK SYSTEM
HE W. S. YEAH YOU URGE CONSIDER
. THE FIRST PAIN PROVIDERS IN
THE BACK OF SYSTEM A MINIMUM OF
A TWO DOLLAR WASTE A FACTUAL
THIS PROVISION MUST BE
EXPLICITLY LAID OUT ESPECIALLY
TO PREVENT A DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION DURING THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS. THE
SECOND CONSIDERATIONS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE LANGUAGE THAT LIMITS
CONTRACTORS EXISTING CONTRACT.
VOTE SENATE. ANY CONTRACT LOW
NEED TO BE WITH THE- STATES
LET'S LOOK. I PROCESS THAT
SCHOOL BY SECTOR THESE OUR BEING
BY A FACTOR PROVIDER ICE OUR-
THE TO BE. BY WORKER THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE OF CARE IS
PROVIDED I SUFFER. IS ALSO SET
STANDARDS FOR CONTRACTORS TO
ENSURE THAT THE OPERATE ABOVE
BOARD IT'S A GOOD ACTORS WHO
ISN'T PUTTING PROFIT. ABOVE
PAYING THEIR WORKERS ASKED WE
HAVE SEEN SO FREQUENTLY IN THE
GIG ECONOMY. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. ON THE
PROVIDER CONSISTENT. SECOND
CLASS. HOW CAN THE STATE'S. NOW
OUT PREPARED AND RISK THIS I TO
MESSED UP. PROVIDERS MISSISSIPPI
. YOU DON'T AS HE ARE YOURS
GROUP CHAMPION SIMPLY SANTIAGO
IMPROVE PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
LIGHT PROGRAM. CURRENTLY OVER
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND I
JUST AS PROVIDERS OVERSEE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO GEOLOGIC CONDITIONS AND
CLIMATE CHANGE WE EXPECT TO SEE
EARTHQUAKES LONGER FIRE SEASONS
INTENSE WINTER STORMS AN OVERALL
INCREASE IN NATURAL DISASTERS.
DURING NATIONAL DISASTERS OLDER
ADULTS INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE
LIMITED RESOURCES LIKE MANY OF
OUR ISIS CLIENTS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LEFT BEHIND.
THIS WORK IS WHAT TO INDIVIDUAL
CARE HEALTH OF FROM NATURAL
DISASTER ALSO WORSEN INDIVIDUALS
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND THEY ARE
NOT FACT WE DIDN'T FIND AND
PROVIDED CONTINUITY OF CARE.
DURING NATURAL DISASTERS I JUST
AS PROVIDERS ARE MANY CASES THE
ONLY INDIVIDUALS WHO KNOW THEIR
CLIENTS NEEDS AND LOCATION. AND
ARE WILLING AND ABLE TO GO CHECK
ON THEIR CLIENTS HOLDEN BACKING
AWAY AND PROVIDE CARE CLIENTS
ARE DISPLACED. I JUST PROVIDERS
ARE GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
TYPICAL CALL FOR CARE TO ENSURE
THEIR CLIENTS ARE HEALTHY AND
SAFE. FOR EXAMPLE MANY PROVIDERS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ACTIVE FIRE
ZONES TO HELP THE FACT THAT YOUR
CLIENTS. EARLY MAKING ALLEN FIND
JUST THE CLOTHES ON THEIR BACK
AND NECESSARY MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
PROVIDERS ARE TRAVELING WITH
THEIR CLIENTS IN YOUR SHELTER OR
METALLIC PROVIDING CARE IN A
COMPLETELY NEW LOCATIONAL.
DURING AFTER DISASTERS ARE
PROVIDERS MUST BE RESTORED TO
THE SET UP FOR CARE TRYING TO
MAKE INTEREST MEALS GOING TO
DONATION CENTERS GET SUPPLIES.
ONLY ON BEHALF OF THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CLIENTS FOR FOOD STAMPS
HOUSING. VOUCHERS AND GAS CARTS
TO GET AROUND. I LOCATION TO
PAYCHECK COVER THE CHILD. BY OUT
OF FOR SICKNESS. TO SURVIVE. IN
A PROVIDERS NOT WAIT FOR THE
CLIENTS TO GET THEIR OUR SUCCESS
AND KEYBOARD BECAUSE THERE
SIMPLY ISN'T THE LUXURY OF TIME
. THE CURRENT PROCESS PRETTY
MUCH AS THE RESPONSIBLE PARENT
IS UNDER THE ISIS PROGRAM. IS
NOT SUFFICIENT ENSURING THE
SAFETY OF BOTH HOME CARE
PROVIDER FOR THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THEY SERVE. COUNTY
OFFICES ARE OFTEN SHUT DOWN THE
PHONE LINES ARE JAMMED YOUR
EMERGENCY LEADING RECIPIENTS
RIGHT COMPLETELY UNDER ISIS
PROVIDERS. THIS IS A
CONSIDERALE BURDEN FOR BY THE
MOBILE WORKFORCE MADE UP
PREDOMINATELY. COLOR WE HAVE A
VERY MODEST PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU.
CAME PROVIDER A MINIMUM OF A TWO
DOLLAR BASED DIFFERENTIAL FOR
FORTY OF A CLIENT SUCCESS HOURS
DURING A DECLARED STATE OF
NATURAL DISASTER COUNTY. THIS IS
JUST HOPEFULLY A STARTING POINT
WE URGE MORE TO BE DONE FEARFUL
TO WORK WITH THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. TO HELP OUR PROVIDERS
ON A CLIENT'S OUT DURING TIMES
OF EXTRAORDINARY MEET INCREASING
OPPORTUNITY COMMENT TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORK
THE LEGISLATURE STATION YES
ASKING ALL STAKEHOLDERS DURING.
THIS BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU.
THE YOU NOT WELL HEAR A LIVE.
SIR WITH THIS RIGHTS. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON- I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S TIME TODAY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE OUR
COMMENTS WEWILL BE FOLLOWING UP
WITH DETAILED WRITTEN RESPONSES
TO SUPPORT MY TESTIMONY TODAY.
SO IN ADDITION TO BEER SKEWS
COMMENTS ON THE BACK OF
PROVIDERS SYSTEM IN CAREER
PATHWAYS I WANT TO FIRST ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THE
LABOR CODE CHANGES FURTHER
DEFINING THE IRISH ASSASSIN BLOW
YOUR COMPLAINT RELATIONSHIP.
CDSS IS AWARE OF OUR STRONG
OBJECTION TO THIS LANGUAGE WHICH
WE FEEL IS AN UNNECESSARY
IMPOSING LIABILITY ON I JUST AS
CONSUMERS FOR COUNTLESS UNKNOWN
ISSUE. AS NOTED BY THE TVL IT
APPLIES TO ALL PROVISIONS OF
STATE LAW OUTSIDE OF THE WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE AND CAN
INVOLVE SERIOUS CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL LIABILITIES. CURRENT
GUIDANCE I JUST SAYS CONSUMERS
REGARDING OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR
AYE TO SUCH PROVIDERS DOES NOT
INCLUDE INFORMATION ON A WIDE
RANGE OF EMPLOYMENT RELATED
LEGAL RSPONSIBILITIES THAT WILL
BE IMPOSED BY THIS TIME. IF
INDEED THIS IS NECESSARY AT SOME
POINT IT CANNOT BE PUSHED
THROUGH WITHOUT CAREFUL ANALYSIS
AND SIGNIFICANT INVOLVEMENT OF
STAKEHOLDERS. AND IMPACTED
CONSUMERS. BACK UP. AS WE HAVE.
THE INCREASE FUNDING. AT THE
PUMP. I JUST AS BACKUP SYSTEM.
OUR PRIMARY. CONCERN ARE
ENSURING IS A- THAT. GETS PEOPLE
THE BACK PROVIDER SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED INCLUDING ON WEEKENDS
AND HOLIDAYS. YES ASKED WHICH
INCLUDE THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF
URGENT WHICH MAY CAUSE CONFUSION
ABOUT WHEN SOMEONE IS ENTITLED
TO A BACKUP PROVIDER. THE BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING FROM FACILITIES
YOU MAY NOT YET HAVE A REGULAR
PROVIDER. I NEED FOR AN
EXCEPTION TO THE EIGHTY HOUR CAP
PER YEAR. AND PROBLEMS WITH HOW
THE WORK WEEK EXEMPTION WILL BE
RATES WAIT. I'M IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE THAT ANY PROPOSED
REQUIREMENTS FIRST USING I JUST
SENSE REGISTRY ONE ACCOUNT
EUROPEAN I CAN USE THAT CONTRACT
MODE FOR BACKUP BUYERS MUST NOT
HAVE EFFECTIVELY MADE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS TO GET THE CARE THEY
NEED. WE THINK A WAGE
DIFFERENTIAL WILL. HELP IMPROVE
ACCESS. PORT APPLE. THE FOCUS OF
THE BACKUP SYSTEM SHOULD BE TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO CARE AND TO
AVOID INSTITUTIONALIZATION. IN
TERMS OF THE CAREER PATH WE
PROVIDED WRITTEN THAT'S JUST A
GUESS HI MARK IN ADDITION TO
ENSURING WAX SAYS CONSUMER
PROTESTED IT LIMITATION OF THE
SPECIALIZED SKILL PATHWAYS TO
PROVIDERS WHO WORK WITH NEW
PARTICIPANTS WE READ THAT
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE TO BE
BROADER AND ARE CONCERNED THAT
PARENT AND FAMILY MEMBER
PROVIDERS MAY BE PRECLUDED FROM
ADDITIONAL TRAINING. AND
COMPENSATION OPPORTUNITIES. AS
THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED. PLEASE ME TO MY
FINAL COMMENTS REGARDING ACCESS
ISSUES AND I JUST SAT. EVEN THE
SHORTAGES IN PROVIDERS WHICH WE
HOPE CAN BE ALLEVIATED BY BOTH
THE BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM AND
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM WITH THE
IMPROVEMENTS WE HOPE TO SEE D.
R. C. RECOMMENDS THAT CDSS
REMOVE BARRIERS TO FAMILY MEMBER
PROVIDERS SPECIFICALLY IN RULES
RELATED TO PARENTS AND ABLE
APPEAL AND AVAILABLE SPOUSES
WHICH ROUTINELY MAKE ACCESSING I
JUST SAT SERVICES EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED. AND GO BEYOND WHAT
IS REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL
MEDICAID LAW FOR EXAMPLE
CURRENTLY CHILDREN FOR I JUST
SAYS ELIGIBLE BUT DO NOT HAVE A
PARENT WAS LEGAL STATUS TO BE
AND I JUST PROVIDER FROM THEM
ARE UNABLE TO RECEIVE I JUST
SENSEFROM A LONG TERM PROVIDER
IN CERTAIN SCENARIOS BECAUSE OF
THE WAY CARE PROVIDER WILLS ARE
WRITTEN. THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN HOW IMPORTANT
FAMILY MEMBER PROVIDERS ARE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES LIVING
IN THE COMMUNITY MAKING THE
PROCESS OF GETTING I JUST THAT
SERVICES SERVICES SIMPLER AND
MORE ACCESSIBLE IS CRITICAL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WILL BRING
IT UP THE DIET I WILL IT HE- AT
THE CHAIR. I'M GONNA ASK MY
FIRST QUESTION- OF- DIRECTOR
JOHNSON IF I CAN I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD'S QUESTION ON PANDEMIC
FLEXIBILITIES. SHE HAD STATED- A
DESIRE TO HAVE ANY AND ALL
FLEXIBILITY IS EXTENDED BEYOND
THIS. PANDEMIC THAT I WAS HOPING
TO HEAR FROM YOU DIRECTOR WHICH-
FLEXIBILITIES YOU WERE LOOKING
TO CONTINUE TO EXTEND BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC AND IF THERE WERE ANY
THAT YOU WERE. NOT GOING TO BE
CONTINUING. SURE THANK YOU CHAIR
FOR THAT QUESTION AND AT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LIFTING HAPPENED
AGAIN THE QUICK WORK OF ALL
PARTNERS AT TOP ORIGINAL IS THE
MANY FLEXIBILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY RESOURCES WE WERE
ABLE. TO WORK ON TOGETHER WE ARE
RIGHT IN THE MIDST AT THAT
PROCESS TO HAVE A SET THAT
STANDARD WITH DONALD'S POINT
AROUND OUR WHAT WE AGAIN HAVE
WARRANTED WHERE. THERE'S
POTENTIAL FOR THE NEED OF THESE
FLEXIBILITIES IN THE FUTURE WE
ARE AT CERTAINLY LOOKING AT THAT
AT TODAY IN TERMS OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUEON- I
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR AGENDA
OUTLINES THAT THE DATES BY WHICH
SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITIES HAVE
EXPIRED AND SOME THAT WILL
EXPIRE AT THE END OF. THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY- I THINK
THAT AT THE AS WAS NOTED THAT
THERE ARE GOING TO BE CERTAIN
INSTANCES AND TIMES WHERE BEING
IN PERSON MATTERS. IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT THOSE ESPECIALLY
THE INITIAL ASSESSMENTS ARE ARE
ARE DONE IN A WAY THAT IS
SUPPORTING AND GIVING TIME AND
SPACE. ADD TO ENSURE THAT THAT
RECIPIENTS RECEIVING ALL OF THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN STAYING HOME SO. I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT CERTAINLY
WE HAVE HAD SOME THAT EXPIRES
THAT'S KIND OF THAT I GUESS THE
ORIGINAL THAT THE FIRST PIECE OF
YOUR QUESTION THAT'S THE ANSWER
THERE BUT- IN TERMS OF THOSE
THAT ARE CONTINUING INTO IN IN
TERMS THAT THEY NEED TO LOOK
FURTHER DOWN THE LINE. AB AS TO
WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE THE NEED FOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUTURE
WE ARE. GLAD TO CONTINUE
EXPLORING AND HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD. I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT TIE- ALWAYS
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE OUT TO
DO SO THE MORE FLEXIBILITY AS WE
CAN GIVE WILL ALLOW US TO DO
JUST THAT- I WOULD LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON MRS WORKERS COMMENT
WITH DRC REGARDING. THE I. HSS
EMPLOYER. TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND- THIS WE JUST NEED TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT BUT AFTER
HEARING THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD
TODAY IT IS UNCLEAR TO ME WHY
THIS TRAILER BILL IS NEEDED- IF
THE ADMINISTRATION ASSERTS THAT
IT IS THEN I WANT TO URGE THE
GOVERNOR TO PURSUE THE POLICY
PROCESS FOR THIS PIECE SO THAT
IT CAN BENEFIT FROM THE REVIEW
FROM BOTH THE HUMAN SERVICES
POLICY COMMITTEE AND POTENTIALLY
THE JUDICIARY AND LABOR
COMMITTEES AS WELL- I. WANNA
JUST BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE
HEARD AND THE CONCERNS FROM D.
R. C. I TAKE THOSE QUITE
SERIOUSLY AND- WANTED TO MAKE
SURE TO CONVEY THAT TO YOU HERE
TODAY- I WILL ASK MY NEXT
QUESTION OF THE PERMANENT BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM AND WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON- WHAT MISS WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
REGARDING THE START DATE- AS
WELL AS I THINK BEVERLY YOU HAD-
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
TIMING AND AGAIN. PURSUANT TO
THE TRAILER BILL THAT WE ARE
WORKING TO RESOLVE HOW ARE WE
GONNA MEET THIS ENVISIONS JULY
FIRST DATE WHAT ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THOUGHTS ON THE
TIMING GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND CONCERNS THAT NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED AND RESOLVED IN
THIS TRAILER BILL AND THE
PRACTICALITIES OF OPERATIONALIZE
IN ALL OF THIS TIMELY DO WE NEED
TO CONSIDER A LEADER
IMPLEMENTATION DATES TO ASSURE
THAT THIS LAUNCHES APPROPRIATELY
WHAT WOULD BE NECESSARY TO
EXTEND THE CURRENT BACKUP SYSTEM
IF MORE TIME IS NEEDED.
AND SO I GUESS I'LL TAKE THAT UP
SO I THINK WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS IT THIS WAS
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP DURING OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH- THE
COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR- I WOULD.
PREFER TO MY FINANCE COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE THERE'S OBVIOUSLY GOING
TO BE SOME UP BUDGET CONCERNS
WITH REGARD TO EXTENDING IT
BEYOND THE CURRENT- DEADLINE- SO
I WOULD. LIKE TO FOR- FOR SURE
ON THAT. NONCONFORMING OPINIONS
I THINK OUR INITIAL THOUGHTS IS
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS WERE HAD LOTS
BUDGET CYCLE THAT WE'D BE ABLE
TO REACH A CONSENSUS ON. WITHIN
THAT TIME FRAME ON EXTENDING THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THROUGH THE END
OF THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR WHEN
ENSURE THAT THERE WASN'T A GAP
IN THE SERVICES BUT AGAIN.
HAVING TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND
TAKE THAT BACK. LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT HEARING THE TESTIMONY AGAIN
TODAY I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO HAVE A BACKUP PLAN IF
WE'RE NOT READY BY THE FIRST OF
JULY AND- I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO. BE WORKING TO
INSURE THAT WE HAVE ONE OR THE
OTHER. I'M WITH THAT I'M NOW
GOING TO TURN TO CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE- I KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS ON
BEFORE BUT I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW WE ARE ABLE TO AVOID
INAPPROPRIATE TERMINATIONS FROM
THE MEDIKAL AND IHS US FOR THE
COMPROMISED POPULATIONS ONCE THE
RE DETERMINATIONS DO BEGAN ON
THE FIRST OF JULY OF THIS YEAR.
OR IF IT'S ANOTHER TIME LATER
WHAT ARE WE DOING AS A STATE IN
ADVANCE TO ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS
DON'T FACE A LOSS OF SERVICES.
I'M HEARD SOME HERE TODAY BUT
REALLY WANT U TO DIG IN A
LITTLE MORE IF I CAN- I. HAVE
THIS CONCERN BECAUSE I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WERE VERY ACTIVELY
ENGAGED ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS TO AVOID THE
UNNECESSARY STRESS THE TURMOIL
AND THE OTHER NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES IF WE DO NOT
COORDINATE SIMPLIFY AND EXECUTE
WHATEVER IS IN OUR POWER AS A
STATE TO FACILITATE THIS
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR SENIORS.
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND%
NEED WHAT ROLE WILL OUR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY. LAY
AND PLANNING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU CHAIRED BY
QUITE EXPAND A LITTLE BIT AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY TO YOU THAT WE
SHARE. THE SAME CONCERN THAT AS
THE CONFUSION AROUND AT HAVING
THE ABILITY TO PAUSE BUT NOT
THIS TIME IT REALLY ENSURING
THAT EVERY AT PARTICIPATE
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE DO NEED THEM
TO COMPLETE. THIS PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
FOR THOSE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE IS
CERTAINLY A KEY PRIORITY FOR US
AS WELL I THINK SOME OF THAT
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
SIMPLIFICATION WAYS IF AT ALL WE
CAN BE LOOKING TOWARD SOLUTIONS
THAT CAN PRE POPULATE
INFORMATION SIMPLIFIED TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN- ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT IT REALLY DO
RECOGNIZE- THE ULTIMATE DESIRE
TO CONTINUE SERVICES TO NOT
DISRUPT SERVICES. TO ANYONE WHO
IS ELIGIBLE TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THEM SO I WOULD JUST IN
THE HOPE THAT AS AS WAS
MENTIONED AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS LOOKING
AT A MEMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES AT
WITH THE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SIMPLIFY SOME OF
THESE PROCESSES WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK AS WAS MENTIONED WITH.
ALL ANY AND ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH AT THE AT A
BENEFICIARY TO ENSURE THAT WE
ALL HAVE THAT CONSISTENT
MESSAGING AND UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS AND TIME LINES FOR THAT
BUT I JUST WANT TO HOLD SUMMIT
LEAGUE EXPRESS. THAT IT IS TO A
PRIORITY FOR US ADD TO ENSURE
THERE'S NO DISCONTINUITY AS.
THAT CONTINUE TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM. MISSPELLED ENOM TO
BRING YOU IN HERE WELL AND I
WILL REALLY- MOVED WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE PERMANENT
PROVIDER BACK UP HOW YOU SPOKE
ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT- WE RECEIVE SUPPORTS THAT
OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS I. IN THAT
SAME VEIN WANT TO MAKE SURE WITH
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE THAT PER
PROVIDING THE SUPPORTS THAT OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS- HE YOU WENT
THROUGH A NUMBER OF WAYS IN
WHICH WE WILL BE DOING OUTREACH
TOWARDS COUNTIES AND- COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO HELP US TO COMPLETE
THIS. BUT IT IT IT SEEMS AS IF
WE WILL HAVE SOME PEOPLE WHO
WILL FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
WITH THIS. HOW HOW CAN WE HAVE A
GRACE PERIOD OR HOW CAN WE
ENSURE- THAT THOSE WHO MIGHT NOT
FULLY COMPLETE THEIR
REDETERMINATION IS ON TIME ARE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED. SO AS-
SKILL ALLUDED TO- WE DO HAVE A
SOMEWHAT OF A SAFETY NET FOR I
JUST THAT WAS THAT SO WE WANT TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN ON THE
FRONT END. USE ALL OF OUR
COMMUNICATION METHODS THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM. LOSING THEIR
MEDICAID. HOWEVER IF SOMEBODY
HAS LOSE THEIR MEDICAL BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT COMPLETE THEIR
REDETERMINATION BUT ACTUALLY-FALL INTO THE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM. AND AT THAT POINT- OUR
CHILDREN'S SOCIAL WORKER FOR I
JUST SENSE REALLY. IS A BIG PART
OF WORKING WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL
AND MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY TO
REESTABLISH THAT PERSON'S
ELIGIBILITY AND GET MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CONTINUE WITH THEIR
SERVICES SO THAT IS NOT EXPECTED
TO CHANGE. IS THAT THE
REDETERMINATION ASSISTANCE- THAT
WAS MENTIONED OR IS THAT THE
TEMPORARY I. HSS BRIDGE
SERVICES. AND DO EITHER OF THOSE
PROGRAMS NEED TO BE SUPPORTED AS. WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
TRANSITION. SO THAT IS THE SO
THE I US RESIDUAL PROGRAM IS-
WHAT WAS ALLUDED TO AS THE
TEMPORARY BRIDGE SERVICES OF
THOSE ALREADY EXIST TODAY- THEY
ARE STATE ONLY FUNDED. AS MS
BROOKS HILLS ALLUDED TO AS WELL-
SO THAT EXISTS TODAY AS WELL AS
I BELIEVE SHE WAS ALSO SPEAKING
ON GIVING SOME SUPPORT TO
COUNTIES. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE WELL FOR SOMEBODY
LOSES THEIR MEDICAL AND THAT
WOULD REALLY BE ON THE L. AT THE
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY SIDE. NOT SO
MUCH ON THE IHS SIDE FOR US WE
RECEIVED INFORMATION AFTER ALL
OF THE ACTIONS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
ON THE MEDICAL SIDE SO THIS IS
REALLY- UP PROCESS THAT'S OWNED
BY R. T. H. U. R. NURSE. M. AND
SO THAT'S KIND OF WHAT THE WAY
IT WORKS FOR US. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IF I MIGHT KATHY SANDERLING
CPA- YOU KNOW WE DO MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY TO SIDE WEARING A
COUPLE HATS HERE- SO. A COUPLE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT ABOUT WHAT THE H.
C. S. R. THE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
CONTACT INFORMATION IS UPDATED.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN TWO
YEARS WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY STOP
THE REDETERMINATION PROCESS
PEOPLE THINK WE DID BUT IN FACT
ON OUR COMPUTER SYSTEMS CONTINUE
TO TRY. TO RENEW PEOPLE
AUTOMATICALLY IN AN EX PARTE WAY
END SEND PACKETS TO PEOPLE THEY
WERE JUST TOLD DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THE PACKETS YOU'RE FINE DON'T
SEND THEM BACK. THERE WAS
CONFUSION AROUND THIS IT WAS NOT
IDEAL BUT IT NEVER STOPPED AND
SO THERE'S COMMUNICATION THE
NEEDS TO HAPPEN I THINK BOTH TO
SAY OKAY NOW IT'S FOR REAL YOU
ACTUALLY DO HAVE TO SEND THIS
BACK. IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO DO IT
AUTOMATICALLY AND SEND THE
PACKET OUT BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THAT CONTACT INFORMATION IS
UPDATED SO THAT KIND OF JUST GOT
ME THINKING HERE- AND- KIND OF
MADE EYES AT THAT BOB IS WHITE
IN HERE- PERHAPS WE COULD THINK
ABOUT IN ADDITION. TO COUNTY I
JUST SAYS ALSO THE THING ABOUT
TO USE THE- NOW AND- PROVIDERS.
HOW AN INTEREST IN SERVING
THEIR- WHICH EITHER FAMILY OF
COURSE AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO WORK BECAUSE
THAT IS THEIR JOB. SO THERE'S
SORT OF MULTIPLE REASONS WHY YOU
COULD THINK THAT MAY BE WORKING
WITH THE UNIONS AND KAPPA
POTENTIALLY STARTED TO YOU INTO
THE- OF MISTRUST CHILD BUT-
MAYBE THERE'S SOME THINGS WE
COULD DO HERE TO DO SOME
COMMUNICATION WORK. IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS- SINCE WE DON'T A
100% NO WHEN THE PHD LEFT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. THAT THE STATE
IS SUPPOSED TO GET A SIXTY DAY
NOTICE SOMEONE THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AT MINIMUM. AND SO WE
HAVEN'T GOT IT YET SO IT'S AT
LEAST. TWO MONTHS FROM NOW IT
COULD BE LONGER I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING IT'S GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW SOMETIME DURING THE SUMMER.
AND THEN I'LL JUST MENTION IF
IT'S ALL RIGHT THE STATE'S ARE
BEING GIVEN- BETWEEN TWELVE AND
FOURTEEN MONTHS TO DO THE
REDETERMINATION WORK- THE WAY IN
WHICH WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH THE-
YES IS. THAT WE WILL- BASICALLY
JUST KEEP PEOPLE ON THEIR
SCHEDULE SO YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN JUNE OR JULY
WE WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
STARTING THE PROCESS FOR THEM.
AND SO THOSE FOLKS THEY WON'T BE
DUE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
WILL SORT OF WANTS THAT- THAT
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD KICKS IN-
IT'LL BE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABOUT. TWO TO THREE MONTHS OUT
WHO WOULD BE WE'D RUN THAT EX
PARTE PROCESS THEN THEY WILL GET
THE PACK IT WITH PLENTY OF TIME
TO SEND IT BACK IN. AND SO FORTH
SO- WE HAVE THAT WHOLE TIME- THE
TWELVE MONTHS IS TO INITIATE AND
THE FOURTEEN MONTH SAYS TO
COMPLETE THE KNOWING THAT IT'S A
PROCESS THAT TAKES A LITTLE
TIME. SO IT'S NOT LIKE
EVERYTHING HAPPENS ON DAY ONE.
IT'S ODD IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE AND
IDEALLY WILL BE AN ORDERLY
PROCESS- ONE LAST THING IS JUST
TO SAY THAT I THINK DH CS IS
REFERRING TO. THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO RECRUIT
AND ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY TO RECRUIT AS AMBASSADORS
FOR COVERAGE AT THAT THIS MIGHT
BE A WAY. TO SAY HEY LET'S TRY
TO WORK WITH THE UNIONS SO TRY
TO WORK. NOT JUST WITH OUR
COUNTIES WITH OTHER-
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES
WITHIN THE COUNTY TO BE THOSE
AMBASSADORS. AT SPECIFIC TO THIS
POPULATION SORRY TO. SORT OF
TAKE OVER BUT I THOUGHT THIS
MIGHT BE HELPFUL THOUGHTS. I WAS
HOPING TO GET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. TAKE ON THOSE
COMMENTS IF WE CAN- NOTHING M.
SPECIFIC CHAIR OTHER THAN AGREED
TO IN TERMS OF WHAT TO ANDERSON
TO THE NEW DOLLAR DONALD
OUTLINED IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS
STEPS IN. AGAIN WE'LL JUST NOTE
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE WE
ABSOLUTELY. WILL CONTINUE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH NOT
ONLY DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BUT WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO IDENTIFY
ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN BE DOING AT
TO GET MEDICATE MEDICATE
DESTRUCTION SO. I AGREE WITH
WHAT ADAM SANDERLING MCDONALD
OUTLINED IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS
STEPS AND AS I INDICATED YES
THAT CONFUSION AROUND AT
DISSEMINATION OF THE- RENEWAL
PACKETS IS WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE ALSO THAT LEE IS
COMMUNICATED CLEARLY THAT THIS
TIME YOU WHAT. ARE OPEN. TO PAY
ATTENTION AND GET THE GET THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO FULLY
COMPLETE THOSE. AT ENROLLMENT
PACKED THAT THEIR REPUBLIC
PACKAGES TO CONTINUE BENEFITS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I FEEL
LIKE WE WILL HAVE MANY MORE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
GOING FORWARD- I WILL HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION ON THE- CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM PAGE SEVENTEEN
OF THE AGENDA THEY HAD DONE A
LISTENING SESSION. AND IN IT
THERE WAS A CONCERN ABOUT
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND WHETHER
TRAINING WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. HAVING HEARD
ABOUT THE WORK FORCE AND THE
DIVERSITY AND STRENGTH THAT
COMES FROM THAT. HOW ARE WE- IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT DSS IS
WAITING FOR THE RESULTS OF AN R.
F. P. BEFORE CAN TELL US ABOUT
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND- THE MEDIUM
FOR ITS TRAININGS BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THE DEPARTMENTS TO
PLEASE SHARE THE DETAILS. WITH
BOTH US THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL
AS THE PUBLIC- ON THE OTHER
ASPECTS OF IMPLEMENTATION THAT
EMERGE AND AS DECISIONS ARE MADE
AND IN ADVANCE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS CAREER
PATHWAY PROGRAMS. IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS AMENABLE TO.
ABSOLUTELY REQUIRED TO DO THAT
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE LIFTING UP.
AT THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE OVER ARCHING
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY SO WE'RE GLAD TO
FOLLOW UP. ON THE SPECIFICS OF
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THAT WE WILL BE
PUTTING THIS TRAINING
OPPORTUNITY TRANSACTION IN A
REALLY CAN APPRECIATE IT AS A
PRIORITY FOR US. WITH THAT I
WILL THANKS VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE TWO WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE ON
SSI AND- S. S. P. AS WELL AS ON
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
BEFORE I DO THAT I DIDN'T WANT
TO MAKE A REQUEST FROM THE CHAIR
ON ISSUED TO I WOULD LIKE TO
KINDLY ASK FOR THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST FOR A CONVERSATION ACROSS
DSS AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY INCLUDED ON THE
RISKS AND POTENTIAL
SIMPLIFICATIONS OF THE MEDIC CAL
REACH READ DETERMINATIONS. TO
ASSIST IN THE CONTINUATION OF
COVERAGE FOR I. HSS RECIPIENTS
AND OTHER SIMILARLY COMPROMISED
POPULATIONS. SECONDS A LISTING
OF STAKEHOLDER ISSUES BEING
RAISED REGARDING THE I. HSS
PERMANENT EMERGENCY PROVIDER
BACKUP SYSTEM TRAILER BILL AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE TO
EACH WITH ANY NEW VERSION OF THE
LANGUAGE RELEASED. ALL BY APRIL
TWENTY NINTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AT THE LATEST AND THIRD A
CONVERSATION WHICH IS TO BE
CONVENED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
WITH STAKEHOLDERS COUNTIES AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF ON THE
RATIONALE FOR THE DEFINITION OF
HSS EMPLOYER TRAILER BILL.
POSTAL TO HELP US TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND TO HEAR FEEDBACK
AGAIN JUST WANT TO ASK IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS AMENABLE TO
THIS REQUEST. WE ARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE- WE WILL
BEGIN WITH CLAIRE RAMSEY THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOLLOWED BY KIM
RUTLEDGE WITH THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM
LIAISON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOLLOWED BY A NAM CON WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JACKIE BUT
OSSEO WITH L. A. KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD WITH CW DA.
AND MICHAEL HERALD WITH WESTERN
CENTER FOR LONG POVERTY LET US
BEGIN WITH DEPUTY DIRECTOR
RAMSAY WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
UNCLEAR RAMSEY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES OVER DISABILITY
ADULTS IN HOUSING INTEGRATION.
IF YOU WOULD BE THIS AFTERNOON
TO DISCUSS THE ACCESS LIVE AT
THE BOB GRAHAM. YOU MAY NOT FIND
QUESTIONS ABSENCE OR THE START
GOING MY RESPONSES. THE FIRST
QUESTION IS AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BY CHECK
FOR THE SS. PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROJECT THAT. AS HE
BY A AND WE BOARD BILL DOLLARS
THAT'S THREE ONE INTO. FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR CHIU CHOI THREE.
THIS INCLUDES SEVEN. FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX POINT
SIX MILLION FOR THE FULL YEAR
EMPOWER OF THE THREE POINT NINE
FIVE AS THE SPEAKER IN. THANK
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION THE HOUSE
YOUR IMPACT OF THE TWO POINT 7%
AS OF LIKE CALDWELL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION FOR THE FULL YEAR IMPACT
OF THE FIVE POINT 9% AS A CYCLE
OF TWENTY TWO. OF TWENTY TWENTY
. THEY ALSO HAVE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
OFTHE SSI. PROGRAM BY THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION.
AND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONALLY FOR
OUR CAPITAL PROGRAM. I'M JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHERE ARE- IN. PRIEST TWENTY
THREE POINT 5% INCREASE IN THE
PROGRAM WENT. OUR MONTHLY
PAYMENTS FOR INTO. BUT WILL IT
WILL BE ONE THOUSAND FOUR TWENTY
ONE CENTS FOR AN INDIVIDUAL. AND
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND SIXTY FOUR
CENTS. FOR A COUPLE. NEXT
QUESTION WHAT IS IT SURE THAT
ALL THOSE THE PROGRAMS ARE BEING
ENROLLED. BIDED FOR THOSE.
REMAIN BE FAMILIAR THE USE. I'M
SORRY IT'S OKAY I MASCO'S TO
TURN OUR VIDEO OFF WE'RE HAVING
A HARD TIME HEARING- AND IT MAY
IMPROVE THE SOUND AND TESTIMONY. APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECH. I
BETTER. A LITTLE BIT LET'S TRY
IT OUT. OKAY THANK YOUNG PLEASE
JIMMY IT AROUND THE BUDGET
OVERVIEW NOW I FEEL LIKE WE
HEARD THAT. OKAY THANKS THE MOVE
ON THE QUESTION TO NOW WHICH IS
AROUND WHAT IS THE STATE
DIRECTOR INSURE THAT THOSE WHO
COULD BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM
ARE BEING INVOLVED. AND WHAT
SUPPORT IS BEING PROVIDED FOR
THOSE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY. SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT- AS A SITE IS A
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT'S
ADMINISTERED BY THE SOCIAL
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION. AND
THIS MEANS THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY THE ONE TO ISSUE
PAYMENTS. THAT IS NOTICEABLE.
ALL THE GUY. OF AN IMPACT TO
SOME DEGREE LIMITS CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO HELP REACH RECIPIENTS
. SO.
MISTRANSLATED APPEARS WE MAY
HAVE LOST I'M SORRY. YEAH YEAH
WE DID.
FOR NOW MISS RAMSEY WE YOU THE-
CALLING ON A LANDLINE AND WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER AND COME BACK TO YOU
IF THAT'S OKAY- WE WILL MOVE YES. THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON TO
KIM RUTLEDGE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
RIGHT ADD GOOD AFTERNOON- CHEN
ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM GONNA HAVE MY
CAMERA ON FOR RIGHT NOW BUT IF
THERE IS SOME KIND OF ISSUE-
TECHNOLOGICALLY JUST LET ME KNOW
AND I CAN ONLY SEND A- I FELT. I
WILL- GO DIRECTLY INTO THE
QUESTION REGARDING. THE
OBJECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT
FACTORED IN- AND- SAID IF I ASK
THE FIRST QUESTION IS THE
PROVIDED OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET
FOR THE APS PROGRAM. INCLUDING
FEDERAL BECAUSE THEY NINETEEN
REALLY FUNDING AND HOW THE
COVETED FUNDING WITH YOU. I SO
JUST BIRD OVERVIEW- THE APS
BUDGET START WITH AS YOU ARE
AWARE OF THE PROGRAM WAS RELYING
TO THE COUNTIES IN TWENTY
ELEVEN. SO THE BOOK OF THE
FUNDING COMES FROM THE
PROTECTIVE SERVICES SUB
ACCOUNTS. I WILL TOUCH ON A FEW
OF THE CURRENT ITEMS THOUGH- IT
THAT GO BEYOND THAT THE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING- WE HAVE-
CREDIT RECEIVED AN INFLUX OF
FUNDS FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES
OVER THE LAST. YEAR YEAR AND A
HALF IN THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM THAT ARE VERY
NEW TO OUR PROGRAM- I WANT TO
START WITH THE SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL FUND.
AND THAT WILL HAS- A APR AND THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES EXPANSION.
DID APS EXTENSION THAT WAS AN
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR
WHICH WOULD ENABLE THE PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE LONGER TERM CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR MORE COMPLEX
CASES. EXPAND ATS MUMBAI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM TO INCLUDE
HOUSING REPRESENTATIVE ADDED
COUNTY AGES THAT AGENCY.
EMPLOYEES AS MANDATED REPORTER.
LOWER THE OTHER AGE THE FACT
DEATH OF- BUT OF EIGHTY SERVER.
FROM AGE FIVE TO EIGHTY SIXTY.
AND AT THE WITH THE WORK GROUP
TO EXPLORE THE- OF ITS STATE WHY
ITEM EIGHT. MANAGEMENT OR WHERE
THAT THAT. AND ALL THE ON THE
BIT MORE. ON BOTH THE AGE CHANGE
FOR EIGHT YEAH AND THEIR
TECHNICAL WORK AROUND EIGHT PM.
MANAGE SPENDING DATA WAREHOUSE-
THE LEADER IN MY COMPANY. YOUR
CALL ALSO ABOUT AND REALLY FOR
IT WANT TO SERVE THAT RECEIVE
FROM THE FUND GOVERNMENT. OUR
APRIL TWENTY TWO ONE THE
DEPARTMENT REACHED A NINE FOUR
MILLION AND ONE TIME FEDERAL.
FOR AIDS YEAH FOR KOBE REALLY. I
BROKE DOWN DIVERT YOUR OF THE
FUNDING. A LOT OF DIRECTLY TO
THE COUNTY IS THE PART THAT WAS
LEFT BEHIND WITH BIRTH MOM OUT
OF THE CHEMISTRY. AT THE STATE
LEVEL- BUT FOR- THE COUNTY IF
THEY WERE GIVEN BASICALLY A LIST
OF PARAMETERS TO WORK AROUND-
FOR THIS CODE AGREEABLY. A
VARIETY OF DIRECT SERVICES TO
VULNERABLE FINANCE WHO WERE VERY
ISOLATED DURING DEPEND ON IT- AS
WELL AS WITH THAT BACKING YOU
NEED. TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
THINGS THAT CAME UP WHEN WE VERY
QUICKLY HAVE THE SHIP FROM
DOING- IN PERSON VISITS WITH THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION YOU HAVING. TO DO THINGS A LITTLE MORE
REMOTELY. AND SO AT A RESULT OF
THAT I'M COUNTY THE HAVE- MAKE
TO MAKE TO SATISFY AND SO FAR
THEY DONE A VARIETY OF THINGS
WITH THAT THAT HAVE FALLEN INTO
OUR DEPARTMENT PROGRAM OCCURS-
AND THEY HAVE HELPED APS CLIENT
SECURE- LESS RESTRICTIVE
EMERGENCY HOUSING OUTSIDE OF
HOME SAFE OR OTHER HOUSING
PROGRAM. THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPLEMENT APS CLIENT RESOURCES
BEYOND TOP BRASS AS NEEDED-
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SUPPLEMENT
THE COST OF TRANSPORTING APS
CLIENT NECESSARY APPOINTMENTS-
CONTINUED EXPENSE OF ENSURING
THE APS CLIENTS HEALTH NEEDS
HAVE BEEN MET- BY BEING ABLE TO
CONTRACT WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES AND OTHERS WHO ARE ABLE
TO VISIT APF CLIENTS IN THEIR
OWN HOMES AS WELL. AS ADJUSTING
TECHNOLOGY GAP. THE NINE POINT
FOUR NINE DOLLARS THAT I'M
TALKING EIGHT HERE RECEIVED FROM
THAT THAT'S GOVERNMENT FOR
RIDLEY. WE DEFINITELY EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION AND ONE TIME
FEDERAL FROM AMERICAN RESCUE AT
- HELP ADVANCE A P. IN GENERAL
CALIFORNIA. OUR THAT EIGHT POINT
SIX DOLLAR. FOR THE WILL BE JUST
YOUR TO CAN IF YOU PROGRAMS- TO
ALLOW THEM TO CONNECT. THE WORK
THAT WE DONE DURING THE AND-
ONLY INDICATE I'M NOT JUST GONNA
. TO EIGHT YES I HAVE OUR DIRECT
IMPACTED BY KOBE THAT- ANALYSIS
TO EVERY- WE ALSO WERE ABLE TO
DO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY- HERE TO PUT
TOGETHER AN OPERATIONAL PLAN FOR
ATF IN CALIFORNIA. THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ALL THE
ADDRESSING. THAT FURTHER IN MY
NEXT QUESTION. ARE WE ARE ALL
RELIEVED FOR THAT WERE MAILING
ANOTHER FORMER AS THE AMERICAN
RED ACT. WHEN MONEY GO TO.
EXPANDING OUR SMALL PILOT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL WORK EDUCATION
CENTER OR WHAT. AND TO EXPAND
THE EIGHTY TWO YEAR- PROGRAM FOR
MASTER OF SOCIAL WORK STUDENT-
WHERE OFFICIALLY THIS IS MODELED
AFTER THE CHILD WELFARE PROGRAM.
WHERE MASTER OF SOCIAL WORK YOU
CAN HAVE PART OF THEIR EDUCATION
PAID FOR IN EXCHANGE FOR WORKING
IN EIGHTY ACT AFTER THEY
GRADUATE. WHICH WE'RE HOPING
WILL AND HOW ADDRESS. WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES THAT WE'RE. CURRENTLY
THINKING AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
AND FINALLY HAVE ALSO ENTERED IN
A- WITH THE REAL ARE ARE
CONFINED. WITHIN NATIONAL. I
DON'T THINK THE SERVICE IS THE
SENATE. PUT TOGETHER A PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN AROUND- ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND- ELDER
ABUSE IN GENERAL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. FINALLY ATS IS A HAVEN
THIRTY FEET ANOTHER ROUND AT
NINE THROUGH THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACT LATER THIS SPRING THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE MANY
OF THE PROJECT. I'M LIVING IN A
SECOND QUESTION HOW ARE THE
CHANGES AUTHORIZED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INCLUDING A
REDUCTION AT THE AGE. SIXTY FROM
SIXTY FIVE BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
ARE THERE ANY ISSUES OR
CONFLICTS COMING TO LIGHT.
CURRENTLY PROVIDING COUNTIES
WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
DETAILS THE PASSWORD AND THE
STATUTORY CHANGE. ALTHOUGH AB
ONE THIRTY FIVE CHANGES THE
ELIGIBILITY AGE FOR ELDER
ACCESSING APIS FROM A FIFTY FIVE
AN OLDER AGE SIXTEEN AND OLDER
THE ELIGIBILITY AGE DID NOT
CHANGE FOR THE PENAL CODE FOR
ELDER ABUSE. AND IT DID NOT
CHANGED MANDATED REPORTING LAW.
YES I HAVE YOU WTA COUNTY THEIR
CLUB ON SAKSHI AND FOR AT AND
EXTERNAL. INCLUDING MANDATED
REPORTERS LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE
EXCHANGE. ADDITIONALLY AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED ABOUT OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THIS HEARING TODAY.
COUNTY THEIR EXPERIENCING
DIFFICULTY HIRING ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO ADDRESS INCREASE
CASELOADS. AND THEY'RE CONCERNED
THEY WILL BE UNABLE TO SEND THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOCATION
PRIOR TO THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. LIVING ON YOUR THIRD
QUESTION- WHAT ARE THE
DEPARTMENT AND OUR LOCAL AGENCY
DOING TO ENSURE THAT ADULTS
MAYBE THAT SEVEN OF THE BE A
STAR COLLECTOR PROTRACTED. ARMED
WITH THE WIRES- THE PANDEMIC
OBVIOUSLY BROUGHT ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES AROUND BEING ABLE TO
PROTECT THE APS POPULATION. AND
WE HAVE BEEN COMPLEXITY XIN
DURING THE PANDEMIC YEAR WE
STARRCADE BUT- CAN'T GET A
LITTLE BIT AND NOW WE ARE
SEEING- THAT WE ARE HAVING OUR
CASES GO BACK UP AGAIN WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS LARGELY BECAUSE-
INDIVIDUALS ARE BACK IN THE
COMMUNITY AND HAVING MORE
INTERACTION. WITH MANDATED
REPORTERS AND OTHER. I LET SO WE
HAVE MADE THE AN EFFORT THOSE
ARE THE COURSE THE LAST FEW
YEARS TO REACH QUITE AND
DIFFERENT. WE WORK WITH AND
DEPARTMENT OF AGING CREATE A
LIGHT IN HER NUMBER EACH YEAR
REPORT. I'M CURRENTLY WEARING.
ON AVERAGE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY CALLS A WEAK STATEWIDE. TO
THAT EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER. AND
THAT THE NUMBER THAT FOLKS CAN
DIAL TO PUT IN THERE THAT COULD
AND THEY'RE DIRECTLY CONNECTED
TO THE COUNTY APS AGENCY- BUT WE
WERE BEEN ABLE TO SHIFT BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN VIRTUAL AND BRICK
AND VISIT DIFFERENT COMPANY.
THANKS AND AGAIN WE'VE HAD BEEN
ABLE TO UTILIZE- THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT HAS COME AND TO BE
ABLE TO REACH MORE INDIVIDUALS
AND WERE VULNERABLE. INDIVIDUALS
AND CREATIVE WAY- QUESTION THE
GOVERNMENT REQUIRE CALIFORNIANS
HE SAID MAY OPERATE PLAN FOR IT
IF YES PROGRAM BY CHANCE. THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY HILL. WE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE AND
DESCRIBE HOW IT WILL ENSUE
CONSISTENCY OF SERVICE AT THE
CLOCK. THE OPERATIONAL PLAN WITH
THE MESSAGE OF THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMMUNITY
LIVING AND APPROVED ON MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TALE. THE
PLAN WAS DEVELOPED BY C. B. S.
S. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
ATF AGENT THE NCWTS. MEDIA
ACCESSIBILITY TO THREE LISTENING
SESSIONS IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH CALIFORNIA APFA
. TOGETHER INTERNET OR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANCE AND INFORM
THE CREATION AND DIRECTION OF
THE OPERATIONAL PLAN. THE FIRST
SESSION I THE FIRST OPENING
SPECIAL ONLY OPEN TO COUNTY APS
LEADERSHIP AND STAFF WHILE THE
REMAINING SECTIONS WERE OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC AND PUBLICIZED IN
ADVANCE YOU HUNDREDS OF AGING
AND DISABILITY OVER STATE WIDE.
BASED ON THE FEEDBACK WE
RECEIVED FROM THE LOOKING. AND
THE FOLLOWING HIGH LEVEL NEEDS
AND GOALS FOR IDENTIFIED. AND WE
CAME UP WITH PERFECT DIFFERENT
HIGH LEVEL MEETINGS. THE FIRST
ONE IS ENHANCING SYSTEM
CORONATION AND COMMUNICATION.
BOTH DURING. THE AFFAIR BUT SAYS
WITHIN AND ACROSS COUNTY. DURING
AN ONGOING CASE MANAGEMENT BOOK
DURING THE A TF WORKFORCE AND
CAPACITY. PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION OF ELDER ABUSE IN APS
. AND ASSESSING AND ADDRESSING
TANGIBLE EMERGENCY NEEDS HOUSING
. A VOLUNTEER WORK GROUP OF APS
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
EIGHT COUNTY BUT ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE WTA WAS
ASSEMBLED TO REFINE THE
OPERATIONAL PLAN INCLUDING A
VISION AND MISSION AND VALUES
AND IDENTIFY CONCRETE
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT AMONG THE
HIGH LEVEL GOAL AREAS THAT I
OUTLINED ABOUT. THE WORKER TO
NINE TIMES IN JANUARY FEBRUARY
AND IDENTIFIED STATE AND COUNTY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THAT ALIGN
WITH THE SIX HIGH LEVEL NEED
THAT ARE LISTED ABOUT. YES THE
EXPECTED DURING A LITTLE OVER
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING THREE WOULD BE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACTIVE
BRING TWENTY TWENTY TWO- TO
EMPLOYMENT THE- PROJECTS THAT
WERE OUTLINED IN OUR OPERATIONAL
PLANS- BOTH THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMMUNITY
LIVING AND PDF THAT WILL RELIEVE
THE OPERATIONAL PLAN FOR THE
PUBLIC LATER THE- RANGE. AND I
ALSO PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE- BUT
WITH A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
THE OPERATIONAL PLAN AN EFFORT
LIKE THAT. NEXT QUESTION WHAT IS
THE STATUS. OF THE CONSULTATION
AND TIME FRAME ASSOCIATED WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED APS LIGHT MANAGEMENT
BUT THAT. I HAVE CREATED A
VOLUNTEER WORK GROUP AT TEN ATS
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH
LARGE AND SMALL COUNTY IS. LOOK
AT THE CURRENT APS DATA
COLLECTION LANDSCAPE. THE
WORKGROUP BURKE MET IN LATE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY HILL AND
DECIDED THAT PDFS SURVEY ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ON CURRENT
APS DATA COLLECTION PRACTICES
AND PREFERENCES. BUT I THINK MY
DATA COLLECTION AND OR CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. MEDIA CENTER
SURVEY. FROM FIFTH FIVE TO FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY. THE WORK GROUP
RECONVENED ON FIFTH TO AN THE
FAIRBURY. THE SURVEY SHOWED THAT
MANY COUNTY ONE AS STREAMLINED
THE WAY TO SHARE ETF DATA
BETWEEN COUNTY ALTHOUGH COUNTY
FARM NEXT ON THE NEED FOR A
STATEWIDE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
. CURRENTLY FIFTY OUT OF FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY YOU'D EXPECT THEM
CREATED BY THE SAME VENDOR.
HOWEVER MOST OF THE LARGEST
COUNTY TO THE STATE DO NOT USE
THAT THAT THE MORE THAT VENDOR.
THEY CALL THEIR WORK WILL
CONTINUE AROUND THE ISSUE IN THE
COMING MONTHS. AND WE WILL BE
HAVING A PUBLIC MEETING IN THE
COMING NINE AND OUR REPORT ON
THE FEASIBILITY OF A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM IN. THE LEGISLATURE AND
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY YEAH. AND
OUR FINAL IF YES QUESTION HOW
DID YOU ACCESS THE SURE THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR ATS
ALIGNED WITH THE MPA. AT EIGHT
ACCESS AT THE STATE AND COUNTY
LEVEL HAS BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
THE CREATION OF THE NEW OLDER
DISABILITY JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL WHICH CAME DIRECTLY OUT
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
NPA. ACCOUNTS HOLDING PROCEEDS
TO COUNTY APS REPRESENTATIVE AS
WELL AS EASY ACCESS
REPRESENTATION- AND THE COUNCIL
WILL PROVIDE A FORUM FOR BETTER
COORDINATION ACROSS THE STATE
FOR. THE EIGHTH. LANDSCAPE AND
ADDITIONALLY APR CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE DATA TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING FOR THEIR EMPTY A
DASHBOARD AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN ON GOING- DIALOGUE WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AROUND ANY ELDER
DISABILITY JUSTICE ISSUES THAT
COME UP AT THE PARK MASTER PLAN.
H. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND- THAT COMPLETE MY TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL
ATTEMPT TO GO BACK TO A CLEAR
RAMSEY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH CDSS. HELLO BUT CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW. MUCH BETTER
THANK YOU. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE EARLY
TECHNICAL ISSUES. I WAS GOING TO
RETURN WITH MY ANSWER TO
QUESTION TWO- SO AS I MENTIONED
. EVERYBODY IS LARGELYA
FEDERALLY ADMINISTERED PROGRAM
HOWEVER THE STATE ENTITIES THAT
ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURING ALL
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE
THE BENEFITS THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO- TO DEFEND THE EFFECT DOES
NOT HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM OF THAT WE TRY TO MAKE
SURE WE DO SPECIFIC APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE AND OUTREACH. TO
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
FROM AROUND AT THE FIGHT AND
OTHER DISABILITY BENEFITS- AND
WE ARE OPEN TO YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH THAT- LEGISLATURE TO THINK
OF OTHER POSSIBLE WAYS TO.
ENSURE THAT WE'RE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OUR AT THE BY
RECIPIENT. OF FOR THE APPLICANTS
WERE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
TECHNOLOGY ON SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION DOES ALLOW FOR IN
PERSON APPOINTMENT ON A LIMITED
BASIS. SO BOTH OF PDFS AND AFTER
THEY HAVE PROVIDED INFORMATION
ABOUT USING ALTERNATIVE METHODS
TO APPLY AND- WE ARE AT THE
MENTION OF MENTION ALSO IN A
LATER- ANSWER- WE ARE HOPING
THAT THE US SOCIAL SECURITY
FIELD OFFICES WILL BE RE OPENING
SOON AND THAT WILL ADDITIONALLY
MAKE. COMMUNICATION FOR
RECIPIENTS. AND APPLICANTS MUCH
SIMPLER. I'M ON NOW MOVES TO OUR
NEXT QUESTION. WHICH INSTRUCTED
MINISTRATION TRACKED THE
PURCHASING POWER OF THE AFTER
FIVE P. GRANT. AND WHAT
APPROXIMATE LEVEL WITH THE GRANT
BE OUT FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
COUPLES IF THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
EVERY YEAR WHERE FEDERAL HOLD
WAS PROVIDED. AND CAN BE TRACKED
WITH MOVING FORWARD TO INCREASE
THE TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE
IMPACT NOT PROVIDING STATE COLA.
THANK YOU FOR THIS QUESTION WE
DO NOT CURRENTLY TRACK THE
PURCHASING POWER OF SFI. GRANTS
HOWEVER CDS THAT IS GOING TO
WORK WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON THE BEST WAY TO CAPTURE THIS
DATA AND DISPLAYED AND PROVIDE
IT TO THE LEGISLATURE. TO HOPING
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU- POSITIONAL INFORMATION- OUR
NEXT QUESTION WAS HOW DID
MINISTRATION ENGAGE WITH. IFP
RECIPIENT AND THEIR ADVOCATES.
AND ONE OF THE RECIPIENTS STORY
TELLING US ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
THIS POPULATION SHE- DID.
PARTICIPATE IN STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS AND HAS THROUGHOUT THE
PAST YEAR WITH ADVOCACY GROUPS
SUCH AS CALIFORNIA FOR AFTER
FIVE. AND OTHER AND BESIDES THE
P. RECIPIENTS- TO HEAR THEIR
FEEDBACK AND WE REALLY HAVE
HEARD- FROM THOSE ARE
CONSTITUENTS AND FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. HOWEVER THE
RECIPIENTS STRUGGLE TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS WHEN AT THE
SIDE. OF THE P. R. THEIR ONLY
BENEFITS. AND WE ALSO THAT THESE
RECIPIENTS STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN THEIR HOUSING- SO WE
ARE HOPING TO- THAT ARE GRANT
INCREASE THAT WE PROPOSED BUDGET
IN. FOUR TWENTY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WILL HELP.
RELIEVE SOME OF THE PRESSURE. ON
EFFORT BY RECIPIENTS AND WE'RE
ALSO IMPLEMENTING TO A HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS BRANCH THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM
WHICH WILL BOTH PRESERVE AND
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF BEDS
AVAILABLE FOR AT THE BIASES P.
AND CAPPY RECIPIENTS STATEWIDE.
TROPE ALSO HOPING THAT THAT WILL
DO- REAL GAINES FOR PEOPLE TERMS
OF PRESERVING HELPING AND MAKING
SURE PEOPLE HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
SLEEP. AND THEN A FINAL QUESTION
IS HOW DOES THE EFFECT SURE THAT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR
EVERYBODY AT THE P. ALIGNED WITH
THE MASTER PLAN. SHE PREVIOUSLY
- WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
MOST OF THE FIGHT AT THE P.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES HOWEVER
WE ARE COMMITTED. TO WORKING
THROUGH THE MASTER PLAN PROCESS
AND THINKING ABOUT ALL THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT AS A FIGHT
THE- WORK FOR THE MASTER PLAN.
PART OF THAT WORK BE CONTINUED
BOTH IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND
IN OUR PROPOSAL FOR NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET TO INCREASE GRANT AMOUNT.
OF WHICH IS AN MPA PRIORITY. WE
ARE ALSO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE AS
A MEMBER OF THE DISABILITY AND
AGING COMMUNITY LIVING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO WORK ON ISSUES THAT
AFFECT AT THE FIRE THE P.
RECIPIENTS. INCLUDING THE NEED
FOR INCREASED HELPING. WITH THAT
I WILL STOP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM A NON CON
BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AN ONGOING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS
TIME BUT HAPPY TO HAVE INTERNET
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM JACKIE BUT ARE STILL
WITH THE L. L. YES IN OUR
INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE
EXERCISES PEAPOD JET- ONE THING
THAT WE NOTED IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES CONTINUE
TO ASSUME THAT CASELOAD WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE. FROM WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND OF POSSIBLE REASONS
WHY THIS MAY BE- AND- HAVE
REQUESTED TO GET JUST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON APPLICATION RATES
AN EXIT TRENDS. I'M TO SEE IF WE
CAN FIND ANYTHING THERE- BUT
WITH REGARDS TO SOMETHING ELSE
THAT IS ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS THE
DEPARTMENT. NOTED IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO SIGNALED
ITS INTENT TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TO INCREASE S. S. P. GRANT
LEVELS BY AN ESTIMATED TWENTY
THREE POINT NINE FIVE PERCENT-
EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- BASED OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROVISION OF
THE TWO NINETY SIX MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IS MEANT TO
COMPLY WITH INTENT LANGUAGE-
THAT THE STATE INCREASE S. S. P.
GRANTS BASED OFF OF THE SAME
CALCULATION. USED TO DETERMINE
THE RECENT GRAND INCREASE THAT
TOOK EFFECT THIS JANUARY. OUR
CURRENTLY- JUST TWO THINGS THAT
WE WERE FLAG IS THAT ONE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S S. S. P. GRANT
INCREASE REFLECTS ONE OF MANY-
SP GRANT GOALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CHOOSE TO
PURSUE FOR EXAMPLE WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO ASSIST
P. GRANT INCREASE- IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WOULD RESULT IN
GRANTS- FALLING ABOVE JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND NINE GRANT LEVELS
PRIOR TO WHEN- WE BEGAN TO DO
THE GRANT REDUCTIONS DUE TO I'M
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS- UNDER THE
GREAT RECESSION BUT ALSO AMONG
WE- AT AT STOPPED PROVIDING
ANNUAL COLAS- OTHER- IT WOULD
NOT BE ENOUGH TO FULLY RESTORE
PURCHASING POWER LOST OVER THOSE
YEARS- BUT ALSO IT WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH TO ENSURE THAT. ALL S. S.
P. GRANT LEVELS AT LEAST EQUAL A
100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL ADDITIONALLY WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION- IS NOT
PLANNING TO PROVIDE ANY FUNDING
I'M TO ALIGN WITH OTHER INTENT
LANGUAGE- THAT IS TO RESTORE
ANNUAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS I'M BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE-
SO WITH THAT SAID WE SUGGEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SET ITS OWN
GOALS IN TERMS OF WHERE IT WOULD
LIKE- ASSESSES PICK GRANT LEVELS
TO ALTERNATELY BE THINGS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IN
FORMULATING THOSE GRANT GOALS
INCLUDE WHETHER WOULD LIKE TO
PHASE IN THE GOAL FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS- WHETHER IT WOULD LIKE TO
TARGET RESOURCES. TO PROVIDE
GRANT INCREASES TO SPECIFIC
GRANT CATEGORIES OR RECIPIENT
GROUPS AND THEN ALSO CONSIDER
HOW TO MAINTAIN PURCHASING POWER
OF. GRAND STUDIO FUTURE
INFLATION. SECOND THING THAT WE
IN OUR ANALYSIS IS- WHATEVER THE
GOAL THE LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY
LANDS ON WE DO SUGGESTS-
REVISITING THE EXISTING INTENT
LANGUAGE. AND ALIGNING- THE
LANGUAGE WITH THE M. GOAL
EXPLICITLY ON THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS EVEN TRUE TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CHOOSES TO PURSUE. A WE BELIEVE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLANNED S.
S. P. GRANT INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- THIS IS BECAUSE-
BASED OFF OF JUST OUR READING OF
THE LANGUAGE IS. THE LANGUAGE
DOES NOT SPECIFY THE EXACT
FUNDING AMOUNT OR GRANT INCREASE
ALL IT SAYS IS THAT THE GRANT
INCREASE SHALL BE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME CALCULATION. SO WE JUST
THINK GIVEN THAT AND CLEAR UP
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE EXACT GRAN
INCREASE IF THE LEGISLATURE DID
WANT TO. SECURE THE AMOUNT THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO
PROVIDE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
IT COULD REVISE THE INTENT
LANGUAGE TO JUST SPECIFY THAT
THE TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE PROVIDED
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD WITH
CWD F. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
KATHY SUTHERLAND REBUTTAL TO THE
PDA I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT ABOUT
APS AND I WAS ASKED TO TALK
FIRST ABOUT THE TRAINING PROGRAM
SECOND ABOUT THE AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE CHANGES THAT MISS RUTLEDGE
A NEW MARIE DID WHICH AS YOU
KNOW WAS ORIGINALLY IN EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE LAST YEAR-
CHAMPION BY YOU SIR AND SO- I
CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
THAT'S GOING SO FAR AND THEN THE
ALSO TALK ABOUT ABOUT THE
AFFECTED DISASTERS ON OUR SENIOR
AND A POPULATION OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. THAT WE SERVE TO A
PS VITA SASS SO FIRST ON THE
TRAINING- I WAS ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THE
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THROUGH FOR THE FIRST TIME
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED- IN
THE AMOUNT OF THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND WE MATCH THAT TO
FEDERAL FUNDS IT BECAME SIX
MILLION TOTAL TOTAL FUNDS AND IT
WAS AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS
THAT WAS THEN RE UPPED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN FOR FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION BY GENERAL FUND ELEVEN
MILLION TOTAL AND THAT FUNDING
EXPIRES JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR. SO THE STRUCTURE OF HOW
THE TRAINING WAS PUT TOGETHER
HAS BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL WERE
UTILIZING THREE ACADEMIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND VARIOUS
TRAINING TOPICS ARE AVAILABLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE DELIVERED
MORE THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND EVEN
LEARNING COURSES AND THERE WERE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY- MORE
LIVE INSTRUCTOR LED VIRTUAL
COURSES AND MORE ON A SIMILAR
PATH IN TERMS OF NUMBERS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR. THE VIRTUAL
COURSES WITH THE INSTRUCTORS
REACHED TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS AND WE DO HAVE AN
ESTIMATED ELEVEN HUNDRED WORKERS
STATEWIDE SO AS YOU CAN SEE SOME
OF THEM TOOK MORE THAN ONE OF
THE CLASSES I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION HERE THAT WE'VE MADE THE
TRAINING AVAILABLE TO THE- P. A.
P. G. P. C. PARTNERS THAT WE
HAVE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS AT. C. W. D. . ALSO
EITHER- SERVE AS OR WITHIN THEIR
AGENCY. THOSE FUNCTIONS BUT IN
ALL COUNTIES APS WORKS REALLY
CLOSELY WITH THEIR- PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
OF PUBLIC CONSERVATORS BECAUSE
WE HAVE SUCH OVERLAP IN THE
POPULATIONS THAT WE SERVE. AND
THE NEEDS OF THOSE POPULATIONS
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO THEIR STAFF AS
WELL. THEY'RE ACTUALLY REQUIRED
I THINK TO GET FORTY HOURS OF
TRAINING- AND SO THAT PER HELPS
TO PROVIDE THAT FOR THEM. SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES OF THE AVAILABLE
TRAINING OF THAT'S A MORE KIND
OF HIGH LEVEL TRAINING INCLUDE-
HOMELESSNESS AND APS. DEMENTIA
INTERVENTIONS COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENTS AND SAFETY PLANNING
AND ACHIEVING CONSISTENCY IN KEY
FINDINGS FOR OUR APS STAFF. SO
WE- CURRENTLY HAVE AN ASK TO
CONTINUE THE FUNDING SURE THAT'S
NOT SURPRISING SINCE IT IS-
EXPIRING. IN THE REQUEST IS FOR
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND OF COURSE WE WOULD THEN
ALSO BE ABLE TO MATCH THAT WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS. AND TO DO THAT IN
THE EARLY GOING FORWARD- IF WE
WERE TO LOSE THE TRAINING WHERE
ASKED WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT I
MEAN IT I IT SERIOUSLY COULD NOT
BE A WORST TIME TO LOSE FUNDING.
IT WOULD DISMANTLE ALL OF THIS
WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO
DEVELOPING THIS VERY
PROFESSIONAL LIVES TRAINING AT A
TIME WHEN THROUGH THE CHANGES IN
AB ONE THIRTY FIVE. AS WELL AS
THE OTHER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE DISCUSSIONS THAT MISS
RUTLEDGE WAS TALKING ABOUT ARE
WE GOING TO DEVELOP IN CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM HOW DO WE
STANDARDIZE AND PROFESSIONAL
WISE THIS PROGRAM. THAT'S BEEN
IN EXISTENCE NOW FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND IT'S FINALLY JUST
GROWING UP TO START TO MEET THE
DEMAND THAT WE KNOW IS THERE AND
WILL BE GROWING OVER TIME- WE
ARE HIRING STAFF FOR INCREASING
OUR SERVICES AND THIS WOULD
JUST. KIND OF RIPPED THAT AWAY
AND MAKE US UNABLE TO PROVIDE
THE TRAINING NEEDED WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT AS WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW CHANGES
IN THE PROGRAM WILL ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT A CORE
TRAINING MODEL. THROUGH THIS
FUNDING SORT OF LIKE WE DO IN
CHILD WELFARE WHERE EVERY
COUNTY- HAS THEIR WORKER BUT
CHILD WELFARE GO THROUGH THE
SAME TRAINING AND WE'RE HOPING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN A PATH
AS WELL WHICH IS NOT BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO THAT. SO AS FAR AS HOW THE
AB ONE THIRTY FIVE- EXPANSIONS
ARE GOING- AS YOU KNOW THEY
HAPPEN ON JANUARY FIRST. THE
QUITE A FEW THINGS THE TWO THAT
WE FOCUS THE MOST ON OUR- OF
THAT SWITCH AN AGE FROM SIXTY
FIVE TO SIXTY WHICH PUTS THAT IN
LINE WITH THE OLDER AMERICANS
ACT PROGRAMS. AND THEN ALSO THE
ENHANCED CASE MANAGEMENT SO
THOSE WITH MORE COMPLEX NEEDS
ARE ABLE TO. STAY IN THE PROGRAM
WITH AN OPEN CASE LONGER AND
COUNTIES CAN PROVIDE MORE MORE
CASE SERVICES. IT'S STILL VERY
NEW AND SO WE'RE JUST GATHERING
DATA SO I'M NOT I CAN'T BE QUITE
AS DEFINITIVE NOW. BUT I KNOW
THAT WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
RESULTS WE HAVE ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION. I DID WANT TO
SHARE- FROM VENTURA COUNTY. THEY
RECEIVED A REFERRAL FOR A SIXTY
YEAR OLD WHOSE SON WAS VERBALLY
ABUSING HER FINANCIALLY ABUSING
HER. ODD TAKING MONEY WITHOUT
HER CONSENT LOCKING HER OUT OF
HER OWN APARTMENT THAT SHE
SHARED WITH HIM. AND BEFORE THAT
COUNTY WOULD HAVE NEEDED TO
REFER THAT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT APS CANNOT OF STEPPED IN
BECAUSE OF HER AGE. IN THIS CASE
THEY COULD STEP IN THEY
INTERVENE THE SON HAS MOVED OUT.
NOW THE- THE WOMAN IS HAVING
DIFFICULTY AFFORDING THE
APARTMENT BECAUSE HE WAS THERE
HELPING TO PAY THE RENT. SO YOU
DO SEE HOW THINGS CAN KIND OF
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL FOR
SOMEONE- THAT COUNTY IS HELPING
BOTH WITH TRAUMA INFORMED
SERVICES FOR HER. BECAUSE SHE'S
OBVIOUSLY BEEN THROUGH A LOT BUT
ALSO WORKING TO BRING HOME SAFE
THE ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE FOR A PS TO BEAR. TO
HELP HER RELOCATE TO MORE
AFFORDABLE AND SAFE HOUSING. SO
WE CAN JUST SEE FROM THAT ONE
EXAMPLE IT CAN REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE SOME FOR ONE
INDIVIDUAL PERSON AND OVER TIME
IT'LL BE MORE AND MORE OF THOSE
CASES. I WILL MENTION TO YOU
THAT THE SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PROVIDED. ALL WE WILL
PROBABLY REACH OUT TO YOUR STAFF
AS WELL AS TO DSS. TO TALK ABOUT
WHETHER WE COULD ROLL OVER SOME
OF THOSE FUNDING FOR THIS YEAR
TO NEXT YEAR. BECAUSE OF YOU
KNOW IT JUST GETTING STARTED
KIND OF MID YEAR AND WE'RE
WORKING ON HIRING. OF IT'S
EXPECTED THAT WILL WANT TO TRY
TO ROLL SOME OF THAT OVER SO
WE'LL BE IN TOUCH ON THAT- TO
OTHER THINGS THE FIRST IS THAT A
RELATED ISSUE WAS A LACK OF MSW
THIS I KNOW. I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE WORK FORCE ISSUES YOU'RE
HEARING THAT I THINK IN EVERY
PANEL AND EVERY HEARING- YOU
HEARD IT ON THE OTHER PANEL FOR
ME WE ARE EXPERIENCING THAT. AND
ONE OF THE SPECIFIC THINGS BLESS
YOU- IS THAT OUR MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES ARE VERY IN DEMAND.
ESPECIALLY IN APS OF CHILD
WELFARE THAT MASTERS LEVEL OF
SOCIAL WORK IS REALLY ABLE TO
SUPERVISE OTHERS PROVIDE THAT
HIGHER DEGREE OF SERVICE AND
THEIR- JUST ARE NOT ENOUGH OF
THEM. THE SOCIAL WORK SCHOOLS
ARE VERY IMPACTED LONG BEACH
STATE FOR EXAMPLE- RECEIVES
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS A YEAR THEY HAVE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SLOTS AND
THEIR PROGRAM. AND SO WE ARE-
ALONG WITH THE DEANS AND
DIRECTORS OF THE SCHOOLS OF
SOCIAL WORK AT S. W. AND S. C.
ARE YOU. ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN MILLION OVER TWO YEARS
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF NSW'S
IN THE PIPELINE- FOR PUBLIC
SECTOR AND- ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE PARTNER WITH AND THE INTENT
THERE IS TO BOTH INCREASE SLOTS
IN THE SCHOOLS OF SOCIAL WORK.
FOR NSW'S AND ALSO HOPE TO
PROVIDE STIPENDS AND DIRECTLY
SUPPORT THE FIELD PLACEMENTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED DURING THE TWO
YEARS OF THE PROGRAM THOSE ARE
OFTEN WITH THE COUNTY OR WITH A
NON PROFIT IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
BEING MARRIED TO A SOCIAL WORKER
I CAN TELL YOU FROM EXPERIENCE
THEY ARE AND THEY'RE NEEDED THEY
REALLY HELP IN THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS BUT ORGANIZATIONS
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF ABILITY TO
SUPERVISE THEM. THEY'RE OFTEN
THEMSELVES ON A LIMITED BUDGET
SO THIS WILL HELP WITH THAT. I'M
AND THEN FINALLY I. ABOUT A DOES
THAT. I AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
PRIOR PANEL FROM- YOU W. AND
ASKS ME- AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
JUST SUCH AN INCREASING NUMBER
OF ALL KINDS OF EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS- OUR POPULATIONS THAT
WE SERVE IN APS. AND I JUST
SASSER AMONG SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE THEY MAY HAVE DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT THAT RELIES ON
ELECTRICITY SO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUTDOWNS AFFECT THEM- HE-
EMERGENCIES- EXTREME COLD
WILDFIRES WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
GET IN THERE AND HELP GET THEM
OUT OF THEIR HOME SAFE. AND SO-
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT COUNTY
STAFF. ARE HIRED TO DO OTHER
THINGS THEY'RE NOT HIRED TO BE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THEY OFTEN
GET PULLED AWAY FROM THEIR
REGULAR JOBS AND SO THAT. PEOPLE
CAN'T GET SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED FROM THERE ARE FROM THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE WRITING. AND THAT CAN LAST
A REALLY LONG TIME. IN PARADISE
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S STILL GOING
THROUGH RECOVERY FROM THAT FIRE
YEAR YEARS LATER AND THAT WILL
BE CONTINUE TO DO SO AT A BUTTE
COUNTY THEY CONTINUE TO RE
DIRECT STAFF FOR THAT. AND SO-
WE'RE SPONSORING A REQUEST TO
HELP WITH THAT- ALONG WITH
CHILDREN NOW- IT WOULD BE
ASSISTING- AND ADULTS PROGRAMS
FOR EXAMPLE USING IHS. FOR HELP
RELOCATING SOMEONE- ALLOW OUR I
JUST THAT'S PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE HOURS RELATED TO
THAT. PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
DEDICATED COUNTY STAFF A
REVOLVING FUND TO HELP COUNTIES
WITH. EXPENDITURES THAT THEY
MAKE BUT THEY EITHER HAVE TO
WAIT A REALLY LONG TIME TO GET-
FINANCE FOR FROM FEMA OR FEMALE
WILL NEVER REPAY. AND SO
THINKING ABOUT PAYING BACK WHAT
YOU GET REIMBURSED FOR AND THEN
BEING ABLE TO USE THAT OVER TIME
AS WELL TO. REIMBURSE THE COUNTY
FOR EXPENDITURES- WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THAT AND THEN
FUNDING TO PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS. THERE'S A
FEW OTHER COMPONENTS AS WELL.
AND SO- JUST LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVE TO COVER. OF THERE'S A OF.
ON WORK FORCE AS WELL AS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE- AND SO HAPPY
TO BE PART OF THOSE AND THINK
ABOUT WAYS THAT ARE PROGRAMS CAN
BOTH HELP AND BE HELPED BY THE-
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
MIKE HERALD WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- STAFF-
MIKE CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON ON THE ISSUES
RELATED TO S. ASIDE. FROM SOME
OF THIS GROUND IT'S BEEN COVERED
A BIT BUT I HOPE THAT I CAN
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INSIGHT INTO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE CONFRONTING US ASIDE
RECIPIENTS- I THINK- YOU KNOW.
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THE DECLINES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE SS I
GRANT AMOUNTS THAT OCCURRED
SINCE 200-010-2000 ELEVEN BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK ACTUALLY
THOSE DECLINES REALLY STARTED
MUCH EARLIER THAN THAT THEY
REALLY STARTED BACK. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE- WIND THE
LEGISLATURE- BEGAN TO SUSPEND
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS
AND OVER THAT BEGINNING WITH
THOSE TIMES MANY YEARS EVEN
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND TEN NO
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR
BEING PROVIDED NO GRANT
INCREASES WERE BEING PROVIDED
FOR THE PROGRAM. AND SO THE
ATTRITION THE AT THE THAT WAS
OCCURRING WITH THE PROGRAM
SIMPLY GOT ACCELERATED IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WE DID THE REALLY DRASTIC
ACTIONS OF REDUCING THE GRANT BY
SEVENTY THREE DOLLARS A MONTH
DOWN TO THE FEDERAL MINIMUM. AND
THEN PERMANENTLY SUSPENDING THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT RATHER
THAN DOING IT ON AN ANNUALIZED
BASIS IS AS HAD BEEN THE
UNFORTUNATE PRACTICE PRIOR TO
THAT- AND SO DO YOU KNOW DUE TO
THAT WE KNOW THAT THE AT THE
VALUE OF THE SS I GRANT HAS
REALLY DECLINED OVER TIME- AND-
DURING THAT TIME WE'VE ALSO
SEEN. HOUSING PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHTS REMARKABLY-
AND IN FACT RIGHT NOW THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE COUNTY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE A STUDIO
APARTMENT RENTS. ON AVERAGE FOR
IN THE FOR FAIR MARKET RENT
WHICH IS 40% OF THE MARKET LEVEL
BY THE WAY. RENTS BEFORE LAST
DAM THE- SSI GRANT AMOUNT. NOT A
SINGLE COUNTY M. IN FACT THE-
THE AVERAGE PRICE IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW FOR SINGLE FOR A
STUDIO APARTMENT. EXCEEDS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS NOT
PROBABLY IS A BIT OF AN
UNDERESTIMATE SINCE. THE DATA
TENDS TO- IS A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE REALITY THAT OF THE MARKET
PLACE OUT ON THE STREETS. SO
THAT THIS PROBLEM CONTINUES TO
REALLY COMPOUND ON A ON A-
REGULAR BASIS AND- WE SEE THE
RESULT OF THIS- IN HOUSING
INSTABILITY OF OUR CLIENTS.
INCREASE HUNGER INCREASED NEEDS
FOR OTHER KIND OF BENEFITS AND
SERVICES- PEOPLE HAVING TO GO TO
FOOD BANKS- ENDS AND JUST NOT
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD THE BASIC
NECESSITIES OF LIFE- SO THIS
CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO. KEEP OUR EYE
ON AND- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE
THINK THE GRANT AMOUNTS ARE
INADEQUATE- WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR TO
INCREASE FINALLY INCREASE.
PARTIALLY RESTORE THE GRANT
INCREASE THAT WAS TAKEN IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN ELEVEN. WE GOT HALF
ABOUT ROUGHLY HALF OF THAT BACK-
AND THAT'S A GREAT START BUT I
WOULD POINT OUT IN YOUR ANALYSIS
WHICH I THINK DOES THIS VERY
WELL. THAT HAVE THE EFFECT OF.
INCREASING THE- THE VALUE OF THE
GRANT TO ABOUT 92% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL NOW.
BEFORE ALL THE GRANT INCREASE
THE COURTS WERE ABOVE A HUNDRED
PERCENT- BUT- WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK IN THE
ANALYSIS FROM THE COMMITTEE. IS
NEXT YEAR. WHICH SHOWS THE DROP
WE'RE DEFERRING THAT SECOND
PAYMENT. UNTIL TWO TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR SO WE'RE
MAKING WE'VE MADE GOOD PROGRESS
THIS YEAR NOT ENOUGH PROGRESS WE
MADE SOME GOOD PROGRESS. IN TWO
TWENTY TWENTY TO INCREASING THE
GRANT UP. BUT NEXT YEAR WE'RE
GONNA FALL BACK AGAIN. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE ROUGHLY BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE PRIOR TO THE IN
THE INCREASE IN THE GRANT
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW. INFLATION IS
VERY HIGH RIGHT NOW. SO THAT
THAT THAT IS WHY I THINK YOU
CAN- WESTERN CENTER AND
CALIFORNIA'S REST ASIDE OR
ASKING TO ACCELERATE THE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY FOUR.
INCREASED INTO THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY A TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET. SO THAT WE
DON'T FALL BACK SO THAT THE
GRANT THE F. P. O. AMOUNT DOES
NOT DECLINE BACK CLOSE TO THE
LEVEL WHERE WE ARE AT. IF WE
WERE TO INCREASE- IF WE WERE TO
PROVIDE THE SECOND PAYMENT IN IN
THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET. WE'D ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
PUMP UP THE PERCENT OF THE
APPEAL TO ABOUT NINETY THREE
POINT TWO PERCENT. SO I REALLY
THINK THAT'S THE CHOICE THAT'S
IN FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE DO
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE A STEP
FORWARD OR ARE READ THIS YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE FRANKLY A STEP
BACK. AND THEN IS YOUR ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT IN TWO YEARS. WE'LL
PUT THAT THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS
BACK AND WILL BE BACK EXACTLY
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. AND SO I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
NEEDS TO I THINK BE MORE
PROACTIVE IN THIS. AND TO REALLY
INCREASE GRANTS- ON A REGULAR
CONSECUTIVE BASIS SO WE CAN GET
THE GRANT LEVELS BACK UP ABOVE A
100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL AT MINIMUM- SO. YEAH I
THINK- THIS IS SOMETHING I
REALLY DO THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY. AND CONSIDER- SO THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY BE SOMETHING
THAT WE'D BE LOOKING TO GET-
DONE- THIS YEAR AND ON THIS
ISSUE THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT THAT WAS RAISED BY
VOEPEL AGO- WE ABSOLUTELY THINK
THAT THE- THE- COAL AS IT'S
CALLED. OUGHT TO BE MADE
PERMANENT THAT WE OUGHT TO GO
BACK TO THE DAYS WHERE THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT IS IN THE
STATUTE IT'S EXPECTED. WE WANT
TO MAINTAIN THE GRANT LEVELS NOT
HAVE THEM DECLINE EVERY YEAR.
AND THE- THE LEGISLATURE THEN
WOULD HAVE THE PREROGATIVE AND
NEGOTIATE WITH THE GOVERNOR ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO BE ABLE TO
DECIDE WHETHER NOT TO PROVIDE
THAT COAL OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR
COMPOSED THEIR BUDGET. BUT THE
LACK OF THAT I THINK PUTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN. A WEAKER
POSITION AND I THINK WE WANT TO
PUT THE LEGISLATURE IN A
STRONGER POSITION GOING FORWARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THIS
DEBATE ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND
THAT THAT MONEY IS ASSUME THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATURE AND TE GOVERNOR.
AND THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE BILL
THAT INCREASED INTO THE- INTO
THE BUDGET ON A REGULAR BASIS.
I'M AND LASTLY I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO ADDRESS. AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK WE'VE SEEN WE'VE HEARD
DISCUSSED BY. BY RECIPIENTS WHEN
THEY TESTIFIED IT VARIES HEARING
YOU MAY HEAR A BIT OF MORE OF IT
TODAY WHEN THEY COME ON IN A FEW
MINUTES. AND THAT IS THAT- WE
HEAR STORIES OF THAT NGUYEN WE
PROVIDE GRANT INCREASES TO- THE
RECIPIENTS. THAT THEY OFTEN
DON'T SEE MUCH OF THAT ACTUALLY
IN THEIR CHECK. AND THERE AND-
AND THERE ARE. AND THERE'S A
REASON FOR THAT AND THAT IS THAT
MANY. MANY RECIPIENTS ARE GOOD
NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS LIVING
HOUSING WHERE. THE COST OF THEIR
HOUSING IS A PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
INCOME SO AS WE DO THE RIGHT
THING INCREASE PEOPLE'S. GRANT
AMOUNTS- A HOUSING PROVIDER
MAYBE TAKE AN INCREASING
PERCENTAGE TAKING THAT SAME
PERCENTAGE. SO WE ALL FEEL GOOD
AND WE SHOULD ABOUT WHAT WE DO
IN TERMS OF INCREASING GRANTS.
BUT AT THE FOR THE RECIPIENT IT
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON THEIR LIFE- AND SO-
YEAH IT'S GREAT THAT THEY SAY
HOUSE- BUT IT'S NOT REALLY
GETTING TO WHERE THEY- GETTING
MORE DOLLARS IN THEIR POCKET. TO
ALLOW THEM TO MEET THE
ESCALATING COSTS THAT WERE THERE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW.
SIMILARLY WHEN WE SEE A GRAND
INCREASED WHAT A GRAND INCREASE
COMES THROUGH. IT ALSO HAS THE
EFFECT OF SLIGHTLY REDUCING
CALFRESH AMOUNTS. AND YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU WORK. VERY HARD A FEW
YEARS AGO. AND THE COUNTIES
WORKED REALLY HARD AND CDSS
WORKED REALLY HARD. AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE A REMARKABLE JOB
GETTING ASSISTS. CALFRESH
TESTIFY RECIPROCAL THINK WERE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND RECIPIENTS
NOW- WHICH IS. REALLY A
REMARKABLE ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
ONE THAT WE DON'T TAKE ENOUGH
CREDIT FOR. BUT WHEN WE INCREASE
THE SFI- AMOUNT IN JANUARY WE
HEARD VERY QUICKLY FROM
RECIPIENTS THAT WHEN THEY WERE
COMING IN FOR THE RENEWALS. FOR
A RECERTIFICATION FOR CALPERS.
THEY WERE GETTING YOU KNOW A TEN
DOLLAR MONTH CUT A FIFTEEN
DOLLAR A MONTH CUT. IN THEIR
CALFRESH AMOUNTS BECAUSE WE GAVE
PEOPLE MORE INCOME. NOT THAT'S
JUST THE LAW COUNTIES AREN'T
DOING ANYTHING WRONG HERE THIS
IS JUST THE WAY THE SYSTEM
WORKS- BUT YOU KNOW THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO I THINK
THAT. WOULD BE AN ALTERNATIVE OR
SOMETHING FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION. WHICH IS LAST
YEAR WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
GOLDEN STATE GRANT. TO TO SSI
COWART'S RECIPIENTS AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY PARENTHETICALLY.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES DID AN OUTSTANDING JOB.
M. COUNTIES IN GETTING OUT THE
COWART'S GRANTS AMBIANCES SITE
GRANTS. VERY EFFECTIVELY VERY
QUICKLY WITH ALMOST NO PROBLEMS.
SO YOU KNOW WE CAN DO THIS. AND
THE BEAUTY OF PROVIDING THE ONE
TIME PAYMENTS. LIKE THE GOLDEN
STATE GRANT LAST YEAR. WAS THAT.
BECAUSE IT'S A ONE TIME PAYMENT.
IT'S NOT TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BY HOUSING
PROVIDER BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN
INCREASE IN THE GRANT. IT'S JUST
A ONE TIME PAYMENT THE GOES INTO
PEOPLE'S ACCOUNTS. SO DOESN'T
REDUCE PEOPLE OR. DOESN'T
INCREASE PEOPLE'S RENT. ALL IT
DOESN'T GET INTO ACCOUNT. FOR
COVERAGE PURPOSES. SO THE GRANT
FOR CALFRESH STAYS THE SAME. SO
THERE'S A REAL ADVANTAGE I THINK
IN SOMETHING FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER WE LOVE THE GETTING
WE REALLY INSIST ON GETTING
HIGHER GRANT AMOUNTS WE THINK
THAT IS THE COURSE. OVER THE
LONG HAUL TO GET THERE BUT WE
THINK IN A TIME OF SURPLUS WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXTRA MONEY
WERE IN A PANDEMIC WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO SPEND MONEY. THAT
THOSE DOLLARS GETTING IN THE
HANDS OF COMMERCE INNOCENCE I
RECIPIENTS IS A VERY VERY WISE
POLICY CHOICES. AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO.
CONSIDER ADDING THAT INTO THE
BUDGET IS WE GET TO THE MAY
REVISE. SO WITH THAT OLD
CONCLUDE MY CAUGHT MY COMMENTS
THANK. WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS FOR QUESTIONS AND
KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR. I'D
LIKE TO STICK WITH THE SS I SS
P. GRANT LEVELS FOR THE FIRST
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE-
I'M GOING TO ASK BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES AND
THE L. A. L. TO SEE IF THERE'S A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE SSI. S.
S. P. GRANT LEVELS AND THE ENTRY
INTO THE SS I SS P. PROGRAM.
HOPING YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THOSE TWO.
JACQUI RESTED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH DSS- TO DIG
DEEPER ON THIS QUESTION BUT JUST
AN INITIAL POT- IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION IS. THE GRANT
LEVELS THEMSELVES SERVE AS THE
INCOME THRESHOLD- AT MY CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. I'M SO
IMPLICIT SO DIRECTLY THAT IN AND
OF ITSELF IS AN ELIGIBILITY ROLE
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT GRANT
LEVELS ARE KEEPING UP WITH
INFLATION. IN A WAY- WE'RE JUST-
ELIGIBILITY IS THAN JUST FURTHER
ERODING OVER TIME AND IT'SJUST
BEING REDUCED TO THE MOST POOR-
AND- PER PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS-
SAID THAT'S A DYNAMIC- WITH HOW
THE GRANT LEVEL SPECIFICALLY
TRANS. HOW DO THEY TRANSLATE
INTO THE ELIGIBILITY SIDE OF
THINGS. I GUESS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE CASELOAD TREND ANALYSIS
THAT'S ON THE TOP OF PAGE TWENTY
FOUR. DO WE FEEL THAT THIS- IS
FURTHER A ROADING ELIGIBILITY.
IS THIS WHY WE'RE HAVING THE
LOWER CASELOAD. TREND THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR THE-
CONNECTION POINT YEAH WE DO
THINK THAT THAT IS ONE THING
THAT MIGHT BE DRIVING KEITHSBURG
REDUCTION IS THE FACT THAT THE
DESTRUCTIVE SAID- THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY LIMIT IS THE
MAXIMUM. BUT THERE ARE SOME
DISREGARD BUT IT'S BASICALLY THE
MAXIMUM GRANT AMOUNT EQUALS THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR INCOME. HOWEVER
THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS THAT WE
THINK- HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DECLINE IN CASE WE DO THINK THAT
THE CLOSURE OF THE ATHLETIC
FIELD OFFICES FOR IT NOW AT THIS
POINT. LITTLE VER TWO YEARS-
MAY BE CONTRIBUTING AND MAY MAKE
IT MORE CHALLENGING FOR PEOPLE
TO GET ON TO TESTIFY AT THE
PEAK- WE DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE- ALSO SOME POSITIVE REASONS
THAT THE KIDS BOOK ARTICLE
WRITING IN. TERMS OF GREATER
AFTER THE HEALTHCARE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR PEOPLE- VEHICLE
LOCATION SERVICES THAT MAY BE
REDUCING THE IMPACT OF FROM
DISABILITIES. AND ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY THAT MIGHT BE MAKING
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO. PAY
EMPLOYEES AND HAVE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION I'M BUT WE DO
AGREE THAT- BOTH THE INCOME
LIMITS AND BE OUT THAT LIMITS
WITHIN THE AT THE STATE-
EIGHTEEN WITH AN EFFORT BY
PROGRAMS. LIKELY CONTRIBUTE TO
CASE BY. CASE OF THE QUITE WELL
. I'M GOING TO BRING THE
CONVERSE WE HAD- EARLIER WITH.
REGARD TO USE POVERTY AND HOW
HOME. AND HOURS. THAT I'D LIKE
TO REALLY. I'M SORRY FOR THE
LABORING THE POINT BUT ARE WE
ARTIFICIALLY RESTRICTING ACCESS
TO THIS PROGRAM. WITH THE
SUPPRESSION OF THE GRANT LEVELS
BY NOT PROVIDING THE S. S. P.
COLA PORTION OF THE GRANT. HAPPY
TO HAVE CONTINUED CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE- IN DETAIL ON GOING-
ACCEPTABILITY OF THE COLOR BUT I
DO WANT TO DEFER TO MY- SLOWLY
GET FINANCE ABOUT THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS ABOUT ONGOING-
WHOLE INCREASED AND I WHICH IS-
MENTIONED THAT. WITH REGARD TO
OLDER ADULTS AND HOMELESSNESS WE
HAVE BEEN MAKING TREMENDOUS
IMPACT- AND INCREASES IN OUR
HOUSING SPENDING OVER THE LAST-
LAST YEAR TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS. ANOTHER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IS- APPROACH FOR THIS
YEAR AND- WITHIN FIGURE IT OUT
BUT SELL WE'VE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING DIRECTED TOWARD OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO TRY TO MELIORATE
COMMITTEES PROBLEMS AND. WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE
CON. YEAH I GET THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- JUST PROVIDES THE- THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE CURRENT
LEVELS IN LINE WITH THE INTENT
OF THE- LANGUAGE PROPOSED- AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT HAPPY TO HAVE ANY.
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. AS THIS
IS A COR PROGRAM THAT HELPS US
TO SERVE OUR AGE TURN BLIND AND
DISABLED RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
I'M VARIAS INTERESTED IN THE RE
INSTITUTION OF THE COLA AS A
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO KEEP GRANT
SET PACE WITH INFLATION AND
TUITION ENSURE THAT THE ENTRY
POINTS TO THE PROGRAM IS
MAINTAINED SO THAT WE ARE NOT
ARTIFICIALLY SUPPRESSING
ELIGIBILITY FOR THIS BASIC NEEDS
PROGRAM. HI TO I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
THOSE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
BUT WANTED TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD. WITH THAT WE WILL
CONCLUDE AND THANK THIS PANEL
AND NOW TRANSITION OVER TO.
PUBLIC COMMENT. BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I AM GOING TO
MAKE A QUICK REQUEST FROM THE
CHAIR TWO OF ON. FIRST THEY ARE
BOTH NOTED ON PAGE TWENTY SIX OF
THE AGENDA BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK STAFF TO WORK WITH THE L. A.
AND DSS. IN REVIEWING THE COSTS
AND LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED TO REINSTITUTE THE STATE
COLA FOR SSI S. S. P. GRANTS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO DIRECT. STAFF
TO WORK WITH THE L. A. AND DSS
TO DRAFT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO REQUIRING A PURCHASING POWER
DISPLAY SHOWING THE TRENDS OF
THESE SS I SS P. GRANT AMOUNTS
AGAINST INFLATION. WHICH WILL
ALSO AID IN UNDERSTANDING THE
CHANGES IN BUDGET DOCUMENTS IN
JANUARY AND MAY ANNUALLY. WITH
THAT WE WILL HOLD OPEN ALL OF
THE OTHER BUDGET ISSUES PENDING
ACTION AT THE MAY REVISION
HEARINGS. WE WILL NOW. MOVE ON
TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE WHICH IS IN
THE AGENDA WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC.
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH IN
PERSON PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM IF YOU CAN. COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE AND
MAKE YOUR COMMENT. THANK YOU
CHAIR ARAMBULA- I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES. WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
REQUEST TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
SIXTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION IN
ONE TIME GRANT FUNDING FOR ADULT
DAY SERVICES PROGRAMS- IN ORDER
FOR. THESE FACILITIES TO HARDEN
THEIR INFECTION CONTROL AND BE
PREPARED FOR WHEN SHE'S AT THE-
SEABASS IN THE EIGHTY H. SEYIN
THAT DON'T THEY SERVICE
PARTICIPANTS ARE READY TO COME
BACK INTO CONGREGATE IN PERSON.
CARE SETTINGS THE GRANTS COULD
ALSO BE USED TO ADDRESS THE WORK
FORCE SHORTAGE ISSUE WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY PROFOUND FOR
FACILITIES. BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE
MINIMUM STAFFING REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO NURSING
HOMES IN TERMS OF OUR ENDS.
SOCIAL WORKERS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS OTHER PROFESSIONAL
STAFF AND THEY ARE SIMPLY UNABLE
TO KEEP UP WITH THE COMPETITIVE
OF WAGES OR I SHOULD SAY LACK OF
COMPETITIVE THEIR WAGES BEING
LACK. OF COMPETITIVE BECAUSE OF
BE OF HOSPITALS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE INSTITUTIONS THAT CAN
PAY MORE FOR THE STAFF AND WE
KNOW THAT THE MARKET RATE- LABOR
RATE IS EXTREMELY HIGH RIGHT NOW
SO. IT WOULD BE USED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PURPOSES AND ALSO
TO ADDRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
NEEDS AND WE ARE JUST URGING
PLEASE AT THE- COMMITTEE ATOP
THE REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER ED DARBY
KERNAN ON BEHALF OF LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA AND AS PARTNERS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT TWO ITEMS TODAY FIRST-
ABOUT WORK FORCE WHICH CAME UP
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY- LEADING
AGES WORKING WITH H. CHI TO
CREATE TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS AND
HOME HEALTH AID WORKERS AND
WE'RE HOPING FOR CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING TO GET THAT STARTED
IMMEDIATELY THE ONE THING WE
KNOW IS THAT THERE IS FUNDING
NEEDED FOR A CAMPAIGN TO GET TO
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO BE RECRUITED
AND THAT IS LOOKING AT-
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVE OF
PEOPLE WHO. ARE IMMIGRATING TO
CALIFORNIA WHO MAY HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR COUNTRIES
BUT CAN'T MAKE THEIR WAY AND
NEED TRAINING LANGUAGE SERVICES
AND SO WE ARE ASKING FOR TWENTY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEAR PERIOD
TO DEVELOP THIS CAMPAIGN IN
ADDITION WE HEARD A LOT TODAY
ABOUT DISASTER PREPAREDNESS-
LEADING AGE IS WORKING WITH A
COALITION OF INDIVIDUALS
ORGANIZATIONS ON DEVELOPING THE
LONG TERM CARE MUTUAL AID
PROGRAM THIS IS THROUGH CAL- YES
AND BUT HHS AND DEPARTMENT OF
AGING ALL NEED TO BE A PART OF
THIS BUT WHEN WE HAVE A DISASTER
WHETHER IT'S CODED. OF FIRE
WHERE YOU HAVE TO MOVE PEOPLE IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES. THERE IS NO
SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR SKILLED
FACILITIES OR SYSTEM LIVING
FACILITIES TO KNOW WHERE THEY
CAN MOVE PEOPLE QUICKLY. AND SO
WORKING WITH THE STATE TO
DEVELOP THIS SO THAT EVERYBODY
CAN WORK TOGETHER AND I THINK
ALL OF THE INFORMATION WE HEARD
ABOUT HSS TODAY REALLY KIND OF
ELABORATES ON THAT. SO WE ONE
AT- CONTINUE WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT AS WELL AND TO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
WORKING WITH US FOR A TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR I REQUEST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF MEALS ON WHEELS
CALIFORNIA WHERE A STATE WIDE
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT SPEAK
WITH A UNIFIED VOICE FOR OUR
SENIOR NUTRITION PROVIDERS.
AMONG ISSUE ONE MEALS ON WHEELS
CALIFORNIA IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SEA FOR A PROPOSAL AND THEN
SPECIFICALLY WANT ANYMORE
SUPPORT FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO HELP REPLACE
SUNSETTING FEDERAL SUPPORT.
THESE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WILL
HELP US MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE FOR HUNGRY
SENIORS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I'VE
HEARD IT THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING
BUT THAT FOOD ASSISTANCE NEED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AS PROFOUNDLY
INCREASED DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND IT'S REQUIRED US TO CHANGE A
LOT OF OUR PRACTICES AS WELL AND
THOSE HAVE COMBINED TO INCREASE
OUR COSTS AND IT. PROBABLY GOES
WITHOUT SAYING BUT AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED MEALS ON
WHEELS IS CONTENDING WITH THE
HIGHER GAS PRICES AS WELL SO- WE
KNOW AND I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THAT ARE SERVICES PROVIDED
DOUBLE PURPOSE FOR THE
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE
FOOD IS COMBINED WITH SOCIAL
CONNECTION. THAT KEEP THESE
FOLKS FROM HUNGER AND ISOLATION
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO KEEP WORKING
WITH YOU TO ENSURE THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE GREETINGS CHAIRPERSON
AND A- THANK YOU FOR THE MANY
HEALTH ISSUES THAT YOU ARE
BRINGING ATTENTION. I WILL START
WITH THE LAST ONE OF THE SSRI.
VICTOR YES I KNOW MANY BLIND AS
WELL AS DISABLED PEOPLE. THAT IT
IS ESSENTIAL PART IN THIS THE
WAY THINGS ARE GOING. IN THE WAY
THINGS OPEN HEADED. THAT
WHATEVER HELP CAN BE PROVIDED.
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I'VE
ALSO PARTICIPATED IN THE MEALS
ON WHEELS PROGRAM. AND WILL SAY
YES PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE PROPERLY FUNDED. DID I SAY
MY NAME JEFF TARA GEAR. AND AN
ADVOCATE. OF THROUGH THEIR-
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS
THAT I'VE PARTICIPATED IN THE
MASTER PLAN AN AGING. I AM ALSO
YOUR POINT IN TIME FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AND THE
HOMELESS COUNT IS INCREASING.
DRAMATICALLY AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE BETTER EFFORTS.
ON THAT THE HOMELESS AND THE
HOUSING ISSUES OR SOMETHING
THAT. WE'VE GOT TEN YEARS TO
MAKE UP FOR AND- IT'S GOING TO
TAKE AWHILE TO DO IT. I WILL USE
THE EXAMPLE OF HUMAN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AGAIN. THE HOUSING
VOUCHER. OPENING UP PROGRAM HAD
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND RECIPIENTS.
APPLY FORWARD SIMPLY THE FEW
THAT WERE MADE AVAILABLE AGAIN-
SO ALL OF THESE THINGS WERE
BASIC HEALTH NEEDS. OF SOME OF
THE- REPRENDRE MAKE I COULD WALK
AROUND AFTER THE PANDA. I AM
SITTING LIKE THIS NOW JUST
BECAUSE OF- I'M NOT ABLE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT I WAS ABLE TO DO
BEFORE. AND I THANK YOU FOR A-
ALWAYS BEING AVAILABLE AND
LISTENING TO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
SAID. YEAH APPRECIATE YOUR
REACTIONS AND YOU'RE TAKING CARE
OF THOSE THAT NEED IT MOST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JEFF GREAT
TO SEE YOU IN PERSON. WE WILL
NOW GO TO OUR PHONE LINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AS WE HAVE
FINISHED PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE ROOM. AS A REMINDER THE
PHONE NUMBER SHOULD. BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. 977-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. AGAIN IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS YOU
CAN ALWAYS CALL OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2090
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE
READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU. WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
FORTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MY NAME IS DIANA CASANOVA
AND I'M AND I CHOSE THIS
PROVIDER FROM ADAIR COUNTY AND I
AM RESPECTFULLY URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO. SUPPORT DISASTER
RELIEF RIDERSHIP OF PROVIDERS
TEARING AMERICANS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PROPER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I'M.
FORTY THREE. I WOULD SUGGEST
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THAT COMMENTING ON ALL
THREE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE PROGRESS THUS FAR. THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS THE
PRESIDENT EFFORT OUR NICE FAST
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
FURTHER ON THE BACK OF PROVIDER
SYSTEM TO BE L. AND OUR COMMENTS
ARE ALIGNED WITH THOSE THAT WERE
ARTICULATED DURING THIS HEARING
BY CWDM. FOR APS WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE I RECOGNIZING THAT
ATS TRAINING FUNDING IS
EXPIRING. THE CONTINUES TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR THE
SPAWNING AND FEEDBACK SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSAL FOR ITS
CONTINUATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COMMITTEE OSTAP
TECHNICALLY THE COMMON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IT'S SO
EXCITING SO MANY FABULOUS
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES BOB WHAT I'M
CALLING IS JUST TO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATION LEGISLATORS TO
INCLUDE THE FUNDING ALLOCATION
REQUESTS FOR THE GROWTH- THE
CALIFORNIACOMMISSION ON AGING
TO RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT BE A
FABULOUS PROPOSALS WENT BACK
PEOPLE RIGHT BOB AND
ADDITIONALLY ASKEDTHE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT FOR THE ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN THE APS AND LOCAL
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES. AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS GUARDIAN
CONSERVATORS WE ARE CHALCO IS
ASKING RESPECTFULLY AS YOU
CONSIDER THIS BUDGET YOU
ALLOCATE YOU THAT YOU AMENDED TO
INCREASE ITS ALLOCATION TO MAKE
THE SPECIALIZED TRAINING
APPLICABLE AND AVAILABLE TO THE
LOCAL LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
REPRESENTATIVES AT THE
PROPRIOCEPTION THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT OLDER
ADULTS TO CALIFORNIA GOOD NIGHT.
THANK YOU LISA. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK SIXTY. GET A
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS LUKE
ROLLING ON BEHALF A CAL CAL
PACES BEEN HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING IN SUPPORT MANY OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND THEY
SHOULD IS CONTAINED IN AND
RELATED TO THE MASTER PLAN. THE
EXPANSION OF THE AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS. AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NO WRONG
DOOR SYSTEM. MODERNIZATION OF
THE HEALTH INSURANCE COUNSELING
AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM AND THE
ALLOCATION OF TRAINING AND
STIPEND FUNDS TO PROMOTE
CLINICAL TRAINING AND CAREER
MOBILITY FOR DIRECT. CARE GIVERS
SUCH AS HOME HEALTH AIDES AND
SEE AN AIDS. WE SUPPORT AND
WE'RE WORKING TO ENSURE THAT THE
INCLUSION OF PACE AND ALL OF
THESE INITIATIVES. AND WE HAVE A
VERY WE HAVE HAD VERY
ENCOURAGING DISCUSSIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GLENDA HARTOUNIAN I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR NEW SENT BY
DEVELOPING HEALTHCARE CENTER IN
NORTHRIDGE SECONDLY COUNTY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BRIDGE
TO RECOVERY FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES CALL THE NINETEEN
EDUCATION AND RESILIENCE GRANT
THE COMBAT IN YOUR ISOLATION
SPONSORED BY CATS ARE CENTER
CURRENTLY HAS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE OLDER ADULTS WITH CHRONIC
ILLNESSES AND APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED NINETY THREE FAMILIES.
DURING THE LAST FEW YEARS WE HAD
IN THE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
DECLINE WITHIN THE POPULATION AT
THE JAIL BUT AT HOME THIS GRANT
PROGRAM WILL HELP BRING THEM
BACK TO THE CENTER AND RECORD
THEIR PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT THE SIXTY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
ASK WILL HELP CENTERS LIKE MINE
TO UNDERGO UPGRADES THANK GOD
BUT NOT NEARLY LIMITED TO FILL
TREATMENT COULD NOT REPLENISH
OUR OUTLOOK APRIL EIGHTH
GATHERING AND HIRE PROFESSIONAL
STAFF AT A COMPETITIVE AND FAIR
RATE. OUR STAFF TURNOVER HAS
BEEN HIGH AS WE CONTINUE TO
COMPETE WITH FINANCING AND
SOCIAL WORK GREAT THEN L. A.
COUNTY ARE PARTICIPANTS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE ENTIRE CENTER
STAFF IS READY TO GO BACK TO
INCENTER SERVICES TOGETHER AT
BTS POSSIBLE AND IT'S SIXTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR ASK
WILL. HELP US DO THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS ONE. HI
ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS NANCY BALLPARK
WITH JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF
LOS ANGELES THANK YOU FOR
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME TODAY ON
THESE CRITICAL ISSUES WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AND FOR OUR WORK WITH CDA AND
CDS THAT TO SERVE THE ELDERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT QUICKLY ON MULTIPLE
ISSUES SO I WILL PROVIDE MOSTLY
IN WRITING. BUT FULLY SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS TO INVEST IN SENIOR
NUTRITION THIS PAST YEAR WE PER
NIGHT AT OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEALS TO OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN
LOS ANGELES AND WE WILL FACE A
HUGE CLASH IF THOSE THAT SENDING
IS NOT MET WE SUPPORT AS-
MENTIONED EARLIER NOT ONLY THE
REQUEST FROM C. FOUR EIGHT BUT
ALSO THE ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS
WE ALSO THINK THAT THE EXERCISE
TO SPEAK RAMPS- INCREASING
COALITION BE IMPLEMENTED. MORE
QUICKLY AS SUGGESTED BY MR
HERALD AND THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE S. AND B. AND CAN
BE FUNDING IS KEPT CONSISTENT
WITH WITH WITH THE FUNDING FOR
THE CALIBRATION CREASES WE THINK
THE LA AND IS PROJECTIONS ABOUT
APPROACHING THESE ISSUES
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF EARLIER BILLS IT MAKES
COMMON SENSE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU GOING
FORWARD ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES-
ONE LAST ITEM IS THAT CATHY
SANDERLING MENTIONED THE ISSUE
OF NOT HAVING ENOUGH NSW'S WE
WOULD. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOU LOOK AT THIS MUCH MORE.
POLITICALLY AND INCLUDE MSPS AND
OTHER PROVIDERS IN THAT-
DISCUSSION- ONE FULLY ONE THIRD
OF OUR CLINICAL STAFF NOW THIS
OUR MSPS NOT NOT MSW WE HAVE
BOTH WE LOVE THEM BOTH- AS WELL
AS LPC CITIES AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE
CLINICAL STAFF CATEGORIES ARE
INCLUDED IN THESE WORK FIRST
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. TEN
FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU MY NAME IS-
A FAMILY MEMBER OF- OF AN
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER OF A
TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
UNPAID CARE GIVER HE LIVES WITH
ME- ALSO WITH BT CAN CALIFORNIA
DID BILLY YOUR COMMUNITY ACTION
NETWORK MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES PASSPORT
ALSO SERVED ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING STEP COMMITTEES. AND
ALSO THURMOND THE ELDER AND
DISABILITY JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL I'M COMMITTING OTHER
COMMENTER WRITING WHICH IS
POINTED INDICATE STRONG SUPPORT
ON THE ISSUE OF THAT'S THE
HIGHEST BE. ON THE COMMENTS
RAISED BY THE WEST AND DINNER
LONG POVERTY AND ALSO COMMENT
THAT YOU REYES MR RAM DEALER ON
THAT ISSUE- THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE ALL OF YOU AND ALL
OF US PUT FORWARD PROPOSALS
ENACTED PROPOSED THAT GRANT ON
CALIFORNIA IN OTHER AREAS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ET ON MEDI CAL
A CHILDREN AND WE JUST NEED TO
PUT WORK TOGETHER TO TRANSFORM
AS THE TIE IS TO BE-
FOUNDATIONAL TO HOUSING AND FOOD
AND SO MANY OTHER ELEMENT
FINALLY JUST WANT TO DO A
SHADOW. DIRECTOR KEN JOHNSTON
AND RECTITUDE THE MORRIS AND
THEIR TEAMS FOR THEIR WEIGHT
THAT GAVE OUT REACHED YOU TAKE
ORDERS- AND WORKING TOGETHER AND
LASTLY TO COMPLEMENT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF IN HOW YOU
PUT TOGETHER THE AGENDAS OF THIS
HEARING IN THE PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE AND FOCUSING ON
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT SPOKE CRITICAL AND REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW MANY THE
QUESTIONS. OR THE PROGRAMS-
LISTED ON THE AGENDA ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT HOW THEY CONNECT
WITH MASTER PLAN PREACHING THAT
REALLY INDICATE DAHLE ABOUT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE WHOLE
PERSON AND THAT. PEOPLE MATTER
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
MY- NEXT CALL PLEASE. NINE
SEVENTY NINE. HI THIS ROBERT
CALL HELLO I TO OR YOU LIVE CALL
BACK BUT WAS BILL TO RIGHTS. ARE
WITH EVERYTHING WITH MY CAROL
FAN. ALSO IF YOU INCREASE THE I
FOR US IF THAT'S PM. I BELIEVE
THAT WOULD PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS. BECAUSE OF A
CAR ACCIDENT- BECAUSE INFLATION
IS GOING UP ON EVERYTHING
CALIFORNIA INTERESTING LIFE
STATES THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON ARAMBULA MEMBERS
MANY OF THE SIXTY VICE FROM THE
AREA OF THE LEGAL AID- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
ALL THESE ISSUES AND- ENDORSED
THE PREVIOUS COMMENT TO CLEAN
THOSE UP FROM MY CAROL- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE INVESTMENTS
IN THE PRIOR BUDGET TO THE
HIGHEST PROGRAM WHICH ARE.
PARTLY RESTORED- THE GRANT CUTS
FROM THE PRIOR RECESSIONS WE
HOPE THAT YOU'LL FOR RESTORE THE
GRAMPIAN OF THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET- RESTORE
COUPLE LIVING ADJUSTMENTS
RECKLESS PD AND CONSIDER AN
ADDITIONAL GOLDEN STATE GRANT-
YOU KNOW THESE PROGRAMS ALL PUT
MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO REALLY NEED IT. ARE HIGHER-AT FIFTY GRANTS WILL HELP
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS WILL HELP
SB FIVE FIFTY RECIPIENTS TO MEET
THEIR OTHER NEEDS- OTHER THAN
FOOD AND HOUSING WELL. INCREASE
OUR HOUSING STABILITY- SO
REALLY- JUST ONE EMPTY PLEASE-
X. OR THROW ABOUT. DURING THE
CALL- AND A GOLD DAY GRANT AND
THEN I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THE DECLINING CASE BURKE OF
THEIR IT IS COMPLICATED BUT I
HAVE TO SAY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE-
YOU KNOW SOME OF THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA- SO
SECURITY ADULT HAVE DELAYS IN
PEOPLE DO BETTER WITH THE
REPRESENTED- THEY PRIORITIZE
REVIEWING PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
ON BENEFITS TO TRY TO CUT THEM
OFF AND OFTEN IT'S HARD TO FIND
REPRESENTATION OF CASES. SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED- WILL HELP WITH
THAT FOR YOU. WHO ARE REVIEWED
AT AGE EIGHTEEN- SOME OF THOSE
FOR ARE AT THE STATE AGENCY DDA
RICHARD PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S. SERVICES ARE FOR
YEARS WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED THE
THIRD OVER RELIANCE ON
CONSULTATIVE EXAMS OF NON
TREATING DOCTORS. AT THE AT THE
DDS AND I THINK THAT WOULD-
ATTENTION THAT OULD HELP TO-
EXPEDITE CLAIMS AND HELP PEOPLE
TO GET OUR BENEFITS FASTER-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I AM.
EIGHTY THREE. GERMAN ARAMBULA-
THIS IS CAROL SCHOOL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA I
WOULD SUGGEST JUST COALITION WE
ARE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE CDBG A REQUEST FOR APS
TRAINING DOLLARS. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON BEHALF OF A PATH
LAST YEAR- LEAVES COMPLETELY
BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER. AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE THAT
WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET-
DISCONTINUED FUNDING IT'S
CRITICAL. THE DOLLARS HUNG LOSS
THIS YEAR THAT BUDGET RECORDS TO
LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO SIGN TO ENTIRE-
FIFTEEN COUNTY AGENCIES TRAINING
BUDGET FOR THE YEAR WHICH IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. IN THIS
ERA- OF INCREASING ELDER ABUSE
AND- GROWING CALLING CASE. SO WE
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. SIXTY FIVE-
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN BIRTH
UNANSWERED GRUPO THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION NOT PERSON WANT TO
SHARE OUR BROAD SUPPORT OF THE
INVESTMENT IN THE HFF PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY THE PERMANENT
BACKUP PROVIDER- THE I ACCEPT
THE KERR PATHWAYS PROGRAM IN THE
FBS INVESTMENT INSIGHTS AT THAT
SECONDLY WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EATING CROW
THROUGH INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND THE
JANUARY PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TO
KEEP ME FROM BIRTH TO ADVANCE
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING WHICH
FOCUSES ON ISSUES CRITICAL THAT
THOSE. LIVING WITH DEMENTIA FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE OF THE DIRECTION
OF THE MASTER PLAN BRAIDS IN
LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO
ADVANCE THE STRATEGY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PROPERTIES
BUT CERTAIN INNOVATIVE COGNITIVE
HEALTH ASSESSMENT BENEFIT WITHIN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM SECOND THERE
IS BETTER VALUE IN GROWING THE
EXISTING WEB BERMAN THE
PORTRAYED IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
THEM EVEN PLAYED PARTICULARLY
FOR THE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTIONS PROGRAM
STOCKLEY I'LL MENTION OUR EFFORT
HERE THAT TOUCH ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AT THE EIGHT
SIXTY ONE BY TENTATIVELY NON
WHICH CREATED THAT DEMENTIA CARE
NAVIGATION PROGRAM. THROUGH A
GRANT ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THAT WILL GO
TO SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF SERVICE
BY EXITING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND FROM AFAR THIS WILL
HELP ADVANCE THE STATEWIDE NO
WRONG DOOR SERVICE OF THOSE
LIVING WITH DEMENTIA
PARTICULARLY AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THAT IN MANY CASES
ARE MONOLINGUAL THE BILL HAS
BEEN AFFECTED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR AFGHANI HOPE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT-
YEAH HELLO MY NAME'S KATIE COOL
ONLY THE OXON CARE MILITAR FELL
ABOUT THE CENTRAL INTO
ACCOUNTING. WITH CERTAIN LOW
INCOME SENIORS DISABLED AND NOT
WITH ANY ALTERNATE FROM FROM
NINETEEN YEAR. AND I AM CALLING
TO SUPPORT DEMOCRATS FOR SIXTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION IN ONE
TIME STATE FUNDING. READ THE
BRIDGE RECOVERY FOR INVOLVED A
SORT OF A FIFTY. FORTY NINETY
MITIGATION RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM. FIND INCLUDE ALLOWANCE-
TO ALLOW OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION TO HAVE A QUIET
ENVIRONMENT WAS URGENTLY NEEDED
THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT STATE
INFORMATION SYSTEM AND THEN
TRANSPORTATION. THE FUNDING WILL
ALSO HELP US TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN EMPLOYEES DURING THE
OVERWHELMING STOCKTON SHORTAGE.
OUR PROPER HEROES THERE NORTH OF
THERAPIST DRIVER SPEEDS THE
REASON FOR THEIR LIFE CARING FOR
HUNDREDS OF ISOLATED AND
VULNERABLE SENIORS. AND THERE
CAN GIVE. FOR THE TWO OF THE
ECONOMIC BILL YOU CITING TO
EDUCATION AND PROVIDING. THEY
ALL GIVE THE OR FOR US HERE PAY
COMPETITOR KATE. POLICE HELP US
TO SUPPORT ALL THAT STARTED FOR.
AND COMPETITIVELY SUPPORT PHONE
STOP I THINK SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. AND SEVEN EIGHT.
HEY THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ AND
I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND I'M ALSO-
COMMENTING FOR ALL HOME WHICH IS
ADVANCES REGIONAL SOLUTIONS THAT
DISRUPT THE CYCLE OF POVERTY IN
THE BAY AREA- WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
CARROLL'S AT ABOUT AT THAT BY AT
THE P. AND ALSO WITH OTHERS
CALLED FOR TO RESTORE FOR
RESTORATION OF THE GRANT AT THE
BE FULLY RESTORED IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE REINSTATE
THE COLAC AND INCLUDE BEST
POPULATION IN THE GOLDEN STATE
GRANT. AND I DON'T WANT SPORTS
COMMENTS MADE BY KATHY SPENDER
LANE ABOUT THE NSW WORKFORCE-
NSW'S WORK IN NOT ONLY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BUT WE ALSO
WORK AND CHILD WELFARE WOULD
WORK WITH THE HOMELESS WE WORKED
IN MANY DIFFERENT AREAS THAT YOU
NEED FOR THE STATE AND WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY RIGHT
NOW IN OUR SCHOOLS TO GRADUATE
AND NOT STUDENTS- SO THANK YOU.
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. LINE. EIGHTY FIVE.
HELLO JEFFERSON RAN BUT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
HENRY I'M A THREE ORGANIZER WITH
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY
FOOD BANK WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENT MADE THAT THE
FIGHT THAT HE GRANT- FROM CUT
DURING THE RECESSION HOWEVER- IN
MANY COUNTY THEN DEFINITELY AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY THIS GRANT DOES
NOT COVER THE COST OF. ONE
STUDIO APARTMENT- LOW BRANDT
PEOPLE AND HOUSE THE SENATE AND
HUNGER AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. MARK XCELERATED
RESTORATION OF THE GRANT AN APP
THAT THEY FULLY BE RESTORED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY. NINETY TWO.
AFTERNOON AT EIGHT IN THE
COMMUTER PADDINGTON ONE ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK- WE
AGREE THAT WE MUST EXPECT THE
FEDERATION THE GRANT WE ALSO ASK
THE PEOPLE AT RESTORING THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BUDGET WE NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF SENIOR
LIVING UNDER TRIPLE MENTAL
POVERTY MEASURE ANY STATE AND
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAD
MERELY EXACERBATED AND EVEN
EQUITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. NINETY THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICHIE MAY
BRING DEPUTY DIRECTOR. I HAVE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND
AND ON BEHALF OF THE VISION LOSS
COMMUNITY WHO IS GREATLY
REPRESENTED UNFORTUNATELY ON SSI
I'M- SUPPORTING MY CAROL'S
COMMENT. ABOUT THE RESTORATION
OF CUTS BEING ACCELERATED TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE FISCAL YEAR FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED AND ALSO JUST TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE BLIND OR LOW VISION IS.
OVER 70% AND PUSHING TOWARD 80%
SINCE THE PANDEMIC SO THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND IT
AFFECTS A LOT OF ADULTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE NINETY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WORKING ON THESE
IMPORTANT MISSION MY NAME IS
CAMERON DONALD PENN ON THE
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZING DIRECTOR
AT SAN FRANCISCO AND SENIOR AND
SENIOR AND DISABILITY ACTION.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR INSTANCE
CONDITIONS I'M COMING TO HE
SUPPORT MY CURL COMMENT. AND TO
REMIND YOU OF SOMETHING THAT YOU
ALREADY KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAD
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF SENIOR
LIVING UNDER A SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY MEASURE OF ANY STATE.
AND THEY ARE LIVING UNDER THE
POVERTY AT THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
LAND IN. ANY SAN FRANCISCO. THEY
GRANT DOES NOT COVER THE COST OF
THE STUDIO OR AN APARTMENT.
PLEASE RESTORE THE GRANT
SOUTHERNER SO PEOPLE CAN LEAVE
AN H. WOULD BE MAYBE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU KEEP
THE READING LINE AND I'M IN A
LONG LINE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE ALMOST TOM WINTERS
OUT THERE SAYING MERRY TUNE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THEIR HEALTHY JEFF
FIFTEEN AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COUNCIL BUILDINGS IT'S
AMERICAN OPEN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING ALL ASSETS I'D BEEN A
BLESSING AND A CURSE AT THE SAME
TIME THE BLESSING CORE IDEAS WE
HAVE ALLOW YOU THE ABILITY TO
EXCHANGE THE CURSED BY DID YOU
HAPPEN ALLOW ME THE ABILITY TO
MANAGE. EVERYTHING AROUND SEEMED
TO BE INCREASE IN MY HOW THE
NIGHT BOATS TRANSPORTATION AND
AT THE SAME TIME I AFTER FACT
TUESDAY THE STRONG SOME PEOPLE
FIND WAYS TO INCREASE AYE
AFTERTHOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GREAT
STATE BUT NOT ONLY ME BUT
EVERYONE ON TRACK IT WOULD GIVE
US THE ABILITY TO NOT GET THE
CHANCE BUT THE VET A HEALTHY
NORMAL AND PRODUCTIVE LIVESTOCK.
SHOULD THE RED LINE AND I'M
REALLY APPRECIATE THE PRIVILEGE
OF THE ATTACK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
FOUR. BOB AND CHARGER PER AROUND
ME AND OF THE CAN MONEY SUPPORT
NOW SKI I'M CALL ON OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FOOD BANK IN
ALWAYS ALSO ST MARY'S IN- AND I
- CALL TO ASK THE- SSI GRANT BE
RESTORED- AND THAT THAT BE
XCELERATED ABOUT LIKE TO QUICKLY
SHARE WITH YOU A PERSONAL. STORY
I HAVE A BROTHER THAT RECEIVES
SSI HE'S THAT HE'S BEEN ABLE
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN- DIAGNOSED
WITH THE- MENTAL ILLNESS-
BIPOLAR THIS IS BEN FROM YEARS
AGO AND BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE HE REFUSES TO TAKE
MEDICATION SO THERE WAS AN ISSUE
OF BUSINESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
SOMETIME AGO WE DO HAVE THAT
TAKEN CARE OF BUT THE ONLY
REASON THAT HE IS NOT- HOMELESS
IT IS BECAUSE HE DOES RECEIVE
THE ACCESS PRIVATE BECAUSE OUR
MOTHER BEFORE SHE PASSED IT ALSO
. LEAVE HIM A TRUST FUND THAT I
ADMINISTER IT IS A RACE AGAINST
TIME. BEFORE THAT- TRY FIND RUNS
AND IS ONLY LIVING ON SSI WHAT'S
THE POINT HE HAD RUN TO THE
DANGER OF BECOMING HOMELESS
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO LIVE
WITH ANY OF THE SIBLINGS. SO I
A- I'M TRYING TO KEEP THAT-
TRUST FUND GOING- SO THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO LIVE ON THE
STREETS. AND IT'S THIS BIZARRE
SITUATION WHERE- I HOPE HE
DOESN'T I HOPE HE ALMOST HOPE HE
- IT ALMOST WILL BE SO IF HE
DIES BEFORE THE- I TRUST FUND
RUNS OUT THEN HE DOESN'T WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HIM
BEING ON THE STREETS. SO AS I
SAY IF THIS RACE AGAINST TIME
YOU CAN OUT REALLY REALLY HELP
OUR SITUATION BY ACCELERATING
THAT RESTORATION THE GRAND AND
SLOWLY RESTORING IT TO THE
TWENTY. HI TO TWENTY TWO AND IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LIGHT NINETY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRANSPONDER'S JUSTICE
IN AGING WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT FOR THE MASTER PLAN
ON FOR AGING WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENTS MADE TO THE
EFFORT BY AT THE PROGRAM IS
WITHIN THE RECESSION ERA CUTS
THROUGH THAT BROWN'S. PACIFIED
THE FOUNDATIONAL PROGRAM FOR
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
IF THEY CAN DO- MORE TO BOLSTER
THE PROGRAM. THE BENEFIT NOT
ENOUGH MEET THE COST OF LIVING
IN. AND IT IS REALLY THROUGH THE
ACCESS P. THAT THE STATE CAN
ADJUST FOR THAT REALITY TAKES
STEPS TO ENSURE AN ADEQUATE
BENEFIT THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. I DON'T
WANT TO ANSWERING YOUR POVERTY
WE SUPPORT THE MANY GOOD IDEAS
MENTIONED DURING THE HEARING TO.
IT TO INCREASE THAT BY A FIFTY
MORE QUICKLY AND REINSTATE THE
STATE KALRA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I KNOW
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBER MY NAME IS DEBBIE TELLS
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CHOICE IN AGING A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING LONG TERM
SUPPORT THOSE SERVICES IN FOUR
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA I ALSO.
SERVED ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND I AM VERY PLEASED
WITH THE INVESTMENTS RELATED TO
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING I'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE COMMENTS- BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM AT SENIOR
DISABILITY ACTION- MY DEAR
FRIEND MARTY EMOTO NAME PEOPLE
PUT I COULD GO ON ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN WONDERFUL THINGS BUT
I REALLY AM CALLING TODAY ABOUT
THE- ASK FOR OUR ADULT DAY
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS ARE AS YOU
KNOW THEM FEEDBACK COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES- I'D LIKE
TO SEE YOU AT THE PORT THE
BRIDGE TO RECOVERY FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES. WE NEED TO HAVE THE
CENTERS OPEN WE NEED TO HAVE THE
CENTERS SAFE WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO PAY A LIVABLE WAGE THIS IS
NOT ONLY A HUMANE WAY TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF INSTITUTIONS THAT
THE JOYFUL WAY TO DO SO- SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THAT AND I JUST WANT TO SHOUT
OUT TO YOU THANK YOU FOR LETTING
US COMMENT MORE THAN JUST OUR
NAME OUR ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER WE SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
BECAUSE I THINK THE STORY MATTER
WE CHANGE LIVES WE SAVE LIVES
AND PAY TAX. DOLLARS THANK YOU
SO MUCH I AGREE AND THANK. YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE NINETY
A- GOOD AFTERNOON MR MAI MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARINA MONSTER A
GENUINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YEAR I
JUST PROVIDERS WHO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AND NATURAL
DISASTER RELIEF SYSTEM THE I. H.
SAYS PROGRAM THAT'S PROVIDERS
AND ARE QUITE. IT CLIMATE CHANGE
THE RATE OF NATURAL DISASTERS
SUCH AS WILDFIRES WILL INCREASE
AND AFFECT MY FELLOW CARE
PROVIDERS LIVING IN THOSE ENGAGE
YOUR AREAS IN MY QUEUE WITHOUT A
PROPER NATURAL DISASTER RELEASES
SYSTEM IT WOULD CONTRIBUTE. TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS POPULATION
. IN THIS WOULD BE A INTO. TO
PROTECT NOT ONLY THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS. BUT
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
BUREAUCRATICALLY. VULNERABLE
AGES AS WORKFORCE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE SUBJECT
. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN CAÑADA
HERNANDEZ FROM HOME AVENUE ADULT
DAY HEALTH CARE IN DOWNEY AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR THE
BRIDGE TO RECOVERY FOR ADULTS
THE SERVICES KOPET NINETEEN
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE GRANT
TO COME BACK IN YOUR ISOLATION.
SIXTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM WILL HELP
US WITH THE EXPENSES NEEDED FOR
SAFETY UPGRADES. SUCH AS
TRANSLATION SYSTEM THE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THE
SANITATION CREW FOR OUR FACILITY
AND BE A CALL THAT PROVIDE ROUND
TRIP OUR PARTICIPATION. THE ALSO
HELP MAINTAIN SAFETY EVENT
COVERED NINETEEN WILL HELP
PROTECT AND REASSURE
PARTICIPANTS AND CAREGIVERS TO
CONGREGATE IN THE BATH CENTER.
THE GRANT WILL ALSO HELP WITH
EXPENSES RELATED TO SHORTAGE OF
STAFF ARTS CENTER AND THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY IS EXPERIENCING
ATTACHED ARE REGISTERED NURSE IN
IT WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT IN
ORDER FOR ARTS CENTER OPERATE.
AND EVEN OUR PROGRAM EIGHT WHO
ARE DEPENDENT PARTICIPANTS RELY
ON FOR HEALTH CARE PERSONAL CARE
NEEDS LIKE MEDICATION
ADMINISTRATION TOILET LONG
BEATING AND EVEN AMBULATION. SO
THE GRANT WILL HELP WITH BILL
AND PROVIDE HEALTHCARE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS WE ARE
PREPARING FOR THE FULL RE
OPENING OF CONGREGATE SERVICES.
PLEASE HELP IN SUPPORTING THIS
GRANT AND THE FEEDBACK INDUSTRY.
AT A TIME CARD FABLED ADULTS AND
SENIORS GET BACK YOUR THEIR
CENTER RESPONSIBLY AND SAFELY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY THREE. NINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
IT YES YOU ARE. FIVE MY
APOLOGIES FIRST TIME CALLER. THE
LAST- GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE WHAT AND I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND
I'M ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR ACCOUNTABLE AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO AGREE WITH THE COURT
COMMENT. ON TO MY CALC AND
EVERYONE THAT CAME AFTER WELL AS
YOU THOUGHT SHARE I THINK IT'S
AN OFFICE JOB OF ARTICULATING
ISSUES- ESSENTIALLY ALL THE
TWENTY FOURTH COMIC WITH
RESTORATION OF THE AFFECTED BY
AND FIFTY CLIENTS. AND ASK. HIM
THIRTY COLLUDED. TWENTY QUITE
TWO. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU STEPHANIE. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BY. EIGHT ONE.
AND EIGHTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
EVERYONE MY NAME IS RUBY
RODRIGUEZ- AND ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE- ARMED ELECTRICALLY WE
STARTED FORTY SIX DOLLARS THE
RESTORATION OF THE GRANT. BUT
THEY BE FULLY RESTORED TO THE.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BUDGET. SINGERS ARE WE
SERVE HELLO RANGE OF
DISABILITIES BUT DEPEND ON
APPETITE INCOME- BASICALLY
DURING A TIME OF HIGH INFLATION
. WE KNOW THAT LOW GRANT HAD
PUSHED WONDERFUL COMMUNITIES
INCOME. AND HUNGER CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST. NH OF SENIORS
LIVING UNDER THE KPOP. MEASURE
OF ANY STATE. THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT IRAQ SHOULD AFFECTED BY
GRANT MUMBLED. AT THE START AND
I THOUGHT P. RECIPIENT CAN PAY
FOR UTILITIES. FOOD MEDICINE
TOILETRIES AND OTHER NECESSITIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND.
ONE HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS ARE BACK ON MARKET ON
BEHALF OF LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
AND LIFE THAT'S THE PART OF THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OVER FIVE YEARS WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE HELP YOUR
HOME AGENT PLACE NURSING PROGRAM
AT TDA DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A
LINK HEALTHCARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICES IN AFFORDABLE SENIOR
HOUSING SITES ENABLING ORDER
RESIDENTS REMAIN LIVING
INDEPENDENTLY AND AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES SUCH AS
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY DAYS WE ARE
ALSO ASKING FOR A CORPORATION
AFTER ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS. TO
ESTABLISH A HOUSING SUBSIDY
PROGRAM AT TDA FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS THE FIRST YEAR IT'S
COSTING TWENTY IT'S ACTIVATED
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IF FUNDED THE COULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE PARK COMMUNITIES
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE HOUSING IS
IMPORTANT CONTACT COMPONENT EVER
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND WE NEED TO
PUT MORE OF AN EMPHASIS ON
KEEPING OUR SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THERE IN A CHAMPION AT
THE BUDGET AND BASS THAT'S
CORRECT THIS YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I DIDN'T ONE
ZERO. WHAT PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON ARAMBULA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAN GALLAGHER. I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF STEPPING
STONE ADULT DAY HEALTH
CONSERVATIVES GO AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULTERY SERVICES
. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT REQUEST
FOR SIXTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME STATE
FUNDING. TO CREATE THE BRIDGE
RECOVERY COURT OKAY SERVICES
COVERED NINETEEN MITIGATION.
RESILIENCE GRANT PROGRAMS. THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP IT OKAY
SERVICES PREPARE FOR SAFE RETURN
TO OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES TENER. I DON'T
THINK SANDERS OLDER ADULTS WHO
TURNED IN PERSON SERVICES WILL
RECREATE THE ACCELERATION AND
LONELINESS ARE EXPERIENCING THE
PAST TWO YEARS. BOTH MCGEORGE IN
THE DEATH TO THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. THIS FUNDING IS
NECESSARY AND TO SUPPORT THE
NEED FOR AN EFFECTIVE WORK FORCE
I REMEMBER ATTENTION ISSUES.
UPGRADE OUR FACILITY AND PORTS
OF THE MEDICATION EFFORTS TO
REDUCE AND PREVENT KOGAN'S
ACTIONS TO ENSURE SAFE RETURNS
IN PERSON SERVICES FOR THE
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS AND
ADULTS WITH POP ADULT WITH
DISABILITIES POPULATIONS THAT WE
SERVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. HERE WE HAVE NO
FOR THE LUNCHEON Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE THAT AS THE
CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING BEFORE WE CLOSE
I WANNA. TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
ALL OF THE PANELISTS ESPECIALLY
THE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FINANCED THE L.
A. O. THE SERGEANTS TECH D. G.
S. AND MOST OF ALL THE PUBLIC
FOR. BEING INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS AND FOR MAKING THIS THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. WITH THAT WE ARE
JOINED FOR THE NIGHT.